ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO START JUST YET I
NORMALLY DON'T LIKE TO START
WITHOUT THE STATE REPUBLICAN
MEMBER HERE. BUT IF WE DON'T
GET.
ENOUGH FOLKS HERE.
WITHIN ANOTHER COUPLE MINUTES WE
WILL START ANYWAY AS A
SUBCMMITTEE SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE
I WE HAVE A BUSY AGENDA TODAY SO
WE ARE GOING TO START.
AS IT SUBCOMMITTEE.
THAT COULD GET EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION WE WILL START WITH.
ITEM NUMBER ONE MR FRAZIER.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS WITH US TODAY
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY AND A NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY THREE.
MORNING GOOD MORNING SIR
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY SIMPLY
ALLOWS A PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICER.
WHO'S REQUIRED TO TAKE HOME A
VEHICLE FOR ON CALL EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WORK.
PART THE VEHICLE IN FRONT OF
THEIR HOME.
WHEN MERE SECONDS CAN MEAN LIFE
OR DEATH IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION. ADDING EVEN A MINUTE
TO GET TO AN EMERGENCY VEHICLE
COULD HAVE A PROFOUND IMPACT.
THIS BILL ENSURES THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS HAVE IMMEDIATE
ACCESS TO A TAKE HOME EMERGENCY
VEHICLE. AND CAN RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY TO A CRISIS.
OTHER STATES LIKE COLORADO HAVE
ALREADY IT OUR ARE ALREADY AHEAD
OF THE US ON THIS AND HAVE NOT
SEEN ANY CONCERNS. WITH
IMPLEMENTATION.
CHINA HAS A VETO ONE OF MY OWN
CONSTITUENTS WHO IS WITH ME
TODAY. BROUGHT THIS ISSUE TO MY
ATTENTION AS HIS OWN AGE AWAY
THREATENED THREATENED
UNREASONABLY DAILY FINES.
FOR PARKING HIS EMERGENCY
VEHICLE. IN THE ON STREET
PARKING AREA OUTSIDE HIS HOME.
THIS ISN'T ONE INSTANCE THOUGH
IT HAPPENS TO POLICE
FIREFIGHTERS AND WAS DRIVERS
SHERIFFS AND HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ULTIMATELY IT'S BAD POLICY TO
ALLOW EACH WAYS TO DICTATE
PUBLIC SAFETY. FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WITH ME TODAY'S CHAT AS A VETO A
FIRE CAPTAIN WITH THE CITY OF
VACAVILLE TO PROVIDE HIM. UP.
IMPORTANT INSIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER WRITER AND
THERE ARE. AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANNOUNCES I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
NOT PREPARED TO TAKE THOSE TODAY
YES SIR OF RESPECTFULLY DECLINED
THE AMENDMENTS THAT.
THANK YOU.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CHAD AS
VETO AND I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
THAT BILL.
EARLY EARLIER I LAST YEAR IN
JANUARY I RECEIVED A LETTER A
FORMAL LETTER FROM MY HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION STATING THAT I HAD.
VIOLATED RCC AND OURS.
THE. LETTER STATED THAT I HAD
MULTIPLE VEHICLES TO A MORE
VEHICLES PARKED ON.
THE STREET WHICH DOES ALLOW
PUBLIC PARKING THERE.
AND THEY ALSO STATED THAT MY
VEHICLE WAS THE COMMERCIAL
VEHICLE BECAUSE IT HAD A OF
LADDER RACK ON TOP AND AND
STICKERS ON THE SIDE DE
SIGNIFYING WAS EMERGENCY
VEHICLE.
SO I CONTACT MY HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION ASKED THEM IF OTHER
WAS A WAY FOR THEM TO GIVE MEAN
AND VARIANCE BECAUSE I DO USE
THAT VEHICLE TO RESPOND.
IN THE EVENINGS WHEN I'M OFF
DUTY TO LARGER EVENTS A
STRUCTURE FIRES A LARGE VEHICLE
ACCIDENTS HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
ABOUT CULTS.
BECAUSE I'M ARE OUR SAFETY
OFFICER FOR THE FOR THE CITY AS
WELL.
TOM. SKIS ME.
THEY BASICALLY STATED THAT THEY
WERE SORRY THAT MICHAEL MY
VEHICLE WAS A COMMERCIAL VEHICLE
AND THERE THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
ALLOW ME TO USE AYE TO KEEP THAT
VEHICLE THERE. THEY DECIDE TO
CHANGE THEIR MIND.
THEY.
TO GO PLAY ON WORDS THEY SAID
THAT THEY WERE NO LONGER GOING
TO BE WORRIED ABOUT MY
COMMERCIAL VEHICLE THAT I COULD
PARK THE COMMERCIAL VEHICLE BUT
I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO PARK MY
OWN PERSONAL VEHICLE SO. I WOULD
BE ALLOWED ONE VEHICLE ON THE
PROPERTY.
WHICH.
WOULD ELIMINATE ME BONILLA PARK
MY OWN PERSONAL VEHICLE THEY'RE
THEY'RE AT HOME.
SO I DECIDED THAT I WOULD TRY TO
LOOK AT THE CASE LAW TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT WOULD
SUPPORT.
MIKE MY POSITION AND I WAS NOT
ABLE TO FIND ANYTHING THAT
SUPPORTED ME OF MY POSITION OR.
ACTUALLY OPPOSED MY POSITION
THERE'S NOTHING OUT THERE THAT
WOULD.
SIGNIFY EITHER WAY.
SO.
I WENT BACK TO THEM AND SAID
WELL. IS THERE ANY WAY WE CAN
ACTUALLY JUST COME TO SOME
AGREEMENT AND AND BECAUSE THEY
BASICALLY SAID THERE WAS THERE
WAS NOTHING WE WERE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DO SO. I STARTED US
SPEAKING WITH SOME OTHER.
FIRST RESPONDERS IN THE AREA TO
SEE IF THERE WAS ANOTHER ANY
OTHER ISSUES OR WAS THIS JUST AN
ISOLATED THING FOR FOR ME.
I DID COME ACROSS ONE OF OUR
OFFICERS IN IN BACK OF IL WHO
EXPERIENCE THE SAME US SITUATION
ANOTHER HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
WITH HER PATROL CAR.
SO.
BEANS I REALIZE THIS IS A MUCH
BIGGER ISSUE THAN JUST MYSELF
AND MY HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION I
CONTACTED.
.
SO THAT FRAZIER AND ASKED IF HE
COULD ASSIST ME IN IN THIS
MATTER.
AND HE DID.
I WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THERE'S THERE'S PLENTY OF
OPEN SPOTS AND I DON'T WANT TO
GET INTO THE DETAILS OF OF MICE
SPECIFIC CASE BUT THERE'S PLENTY
OF OPEN SPOTS IN MY COMMUNITY I
I'M NOT. I'M NOT POSITIONING
SOMEBODY ELSE'S CARS OUT OF
SIGHT OUT OF.
CLICK CLOSE TO THEIR HOME BY ME
PARKING THERE WE HAVE.
HUNDRED FIFTEEN'S OPEN SPOTS
AND THERE'S NO ONLY ABOUT FIFTY
SIX VEHICLES PARKED THERE AND
THAT'S ACCOUNT THAT I TAKE ABOUT
TEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT SO I
COUNTED. AT TEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT
ONE THE AFTERNOON SIX IN THE
MORNING JUST TO SEE IF. AND I
DON'T I DON'T WANT TO GO TO PUT
SIMPLY OUT OF POSITION.
I COULD I COULD PARK MY VEHICLE
WITHIN ABOUT A FIFTY FEET OF MY
HOME AND NOT IMPACT ANYONE ELSE.
SO THE POSITION THAT THE SO
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS NOW
TAKEN IS THAT MIKE MIKE I SAID
MY VEHICLES NOT A COMMERCIAL
VEHICLE.
BUT I CAN'T PARK MY OWN
PERSONAL VEHICLE THERE NOW SO
I'M KIND OF IN A SITUATION WHERE
EITHER A I. DON'T HAVE OF THE
RISK EMERGENCY VEHICLE TO
RESPOND TO CALLS FROM MY HOME.
OR.
I DON'T HAVE A PERSONAL VEHICLE
TO GO RUN ERRANDS LIKE GO THE
GROCERY STORE OR THOSE TYPE OF
THINGS I HAVE TO PARK IT OFF OFF
PREMISES.
WOULD THAT THE POSITION THAT
THEY HAVE SAID THAT IF IF AT
THIS POINT TOM I DO DECIDE TO
BRING MY MERCY VEHICLE HOME.
WHAT THEY'LL DO IS THEY WILL
THEY WILL TAKE IT MY PERSONAL
VEHICLE WHICH DOES HAVE A
REGISTERED STICKER ON IT
SEDATING THAT IT CAN BE THERE?
BECAUSE THEIR DIFFERING SAYING
THAT THE EMERGENCY VEHICLE DOES
TAKE PRECEDENCE OVER MY PERSONAL
VEHICLES THAT'S THAT'S THE
SITUATION I'M IN AND.
I WOULD APPRECIATE SOME
ASSISTANCE WITH THAT IF.
I COULD.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON I KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS A SHOW MUCH LARA BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ASSEMBLY.
IF YOU KNOW NELSON SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT SEE NONE OPPOSITION.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE.
WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL.
AND APPRECIATE THE CIRCUMSTANCE
THAT.
.
MISTER FRASIER'S CONSTITUENT
BRINGS TO THE TABLE BUT.
AND WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR
CONSULTANT AS WELL AS. I MISTER
FRAZIER STAFF.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE PATH FORWARD
AS PRESENTED IN THE ANALYSIS IS
THE MORE APPROPRIATE PATH FOR
THIS.
A SIMPLY THE WAY THE BILL AS
DRAFTED IS IS MUCH TOO BROAD
THEIR FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA ALL
OF THEM WITH A DIFFERENT SIZE
AND DIFFERENT SCOPE. PARKING IS
ALWAYS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
I FEW HAVE A CONDOMINIUM COMPLEX
A WITH UNDERGROUND PARKING
THERE'S JUST NOT FLEXIBILITY
THERE YOU HAVE OTHER SITUATIONS
A SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCE.
QUAD PLEXUS.
LEX'S EXCEPT FOR WITH LIMITED
STREET PARKING.
A COLORADO HAS TAKEN THE LEAD ON
THIS AND IN FACT THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL
REALLY FOLLOW THE PATH OF
COLORADO. IN ALLOWING FOR.
CERTAIN SIZE SPECIFICATIONS
ALLOWING FOR CERTAIN REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS TO BE MADE UP BY
THE ASSOCIATION TO FIT THE
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT THEY SEE
THEMSELVES AND. AS WRITTEN RIGHT
NOW.
THE BILL WOULD JUST SIMPLY
EXCLUDE ALL RULES.
AND ALL RESTRICTIONS ON PARKING.
YOU COULD THEN SEE OTHER OWNERS
IN THE PARKING LOT IN THAT.
ASSOCIATION WHO HAVE A RIGHT TO
A PARKING SPOT LOSE THAT PARKING
SPOTS SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE WAY
HIS BILL DRAFTED THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT. TO ACTUALLY SHOW
THAT THE THE USE OF THE
EMERGENCY VEHICLE IS REQUIRED AT
THAT ANYTIME I AT THAT TIME AND
PLACE SO.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE TO
OPPOSE THE CURRENT VERSION OF
THE BILL HOW WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE STAFF AND WOOD.
LIKELY TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
OUT ONCE WE WERE SEE THESE
AMENDMENTS IN PRINT IF THEY WERE
TO MAKE IT THAT FAR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO.
THE COMMITTEE IN THIS FRAZIER
AYE BUT I APPLAUD YOUR
CONSTITUENT WORK AND AND
STEPPING UP YOUR CONSIDER THINK
THAT'S. ABSOLUTE NOBLE.
ON THIS ONE THOUGH I HAD NOT AT
A POINT TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
AND.
WERE.
WE WENT SORT OF A A A BALANCE
THAT WITH THE HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS INDIVIDUALS AND
ISSUES ACROSS THE STATE AND. AND
I'M SYMPATHETIC TO YOUR
PARTICULAR SITUATION BEFORE WHAT
WE'VE SEEN.
I I DON'T KNOW HOW BROAD THIS IS
SO I DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE
REALLY IN A POSITION TO WANT TO
DO SOMETHING STATEWIDE. TO TO
SOLVE YOUR PARTICULAR PROBLEM
AND WE.
LOOK THAT.
COLORADO WE LOOKED AT OTHER
POSSIBILITIES AND AND PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AROUND THAT SO WE
WERE GONNA MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD. AMENDMENTS I THINK
WOULD BE KEY OTHER THAN THAT
IT'S JUST NOT AMERICAN.
THEY CAN I DO TO FLETCHER CAN I
JUST ASK WHAT.
IT DOESN'T WORK IN THE
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE I I WANT TO
SUPPORT THIS WITH THE AMENDMENTS
BUT I CAN'T OBVIOUSLY WITHOUT.
SO THE FACILITY WHERE THE H.
AWAY SUGGESTING IN PARK IS OVER
A QUARTER MILE AWAY BEHIND A
LOCKED GATE.
AND SO THAT JUST DOESN'T WORK I
MIGHT AS WELL BE OUTSIDE THE
PREMISES.
EN ROUTE ON THE PUBLIC STREET
OF BECAUSE THAT'S THE NEXT EXIT.
AND SO IT'S JUST IT'S JUST NOT
WORKING CAN I LIVE IN AN H.
AWAY.
ALSO AND I HAVE A MARTINEZ
POLICE OFFICER CANINE WHO PARKS
IS THE ONLY ONE ALLOWED TO PARK
ON THE STREET THEY TAKE IT ALL
OF US ALSO IF WE HAPPEN TO DO
SO.
AND SO I IN THE EVENINGS AND SO
YOU KNOW IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE WE DID TRY TO.
CONTACT FIRST THE H. AWAY AND
THEY'VE NEVER EVEN GAVE US THE
CONSIDERATION OF A RETURN PHONE
CALL OR. AT ED OUR LETTER.
AND SO WE THOUGHT THIS WAS THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE CAN DEMONSTRATE
THAT WE WERE. YOU KNOW
SUPPORTING NOT ONLY PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT OUR CONSTITUENTS
CONCERN. MEAN THE SAFETY OFFICER
FOR THE CITY OF VACAVILLE AND
BEING ABLE TO RESPOND TO ANY
KIND OF TRAGEDY.
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND SO THAT THAT WOULD THIS
LEFTIST NO KIND OF RECOURSE
AND AGAIN THE AMENDMENTS.
ARE ARE KIND OF JUST HE MIGHT AS
WELL PARK OUT ON THE STREET
OUTSIDE OF THE H. AWAY BECAUSE
THAT'S I MEAN IT'S VERY CLOSE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE. COOLER
THINGS JUST.
KIND OF A.
WHY WOULD YOU?
OTHER QUESTIONS ADDRESS.
I I TOO AM IN THE SAME SITUATION
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
THAT.
THINK THAT IT IS A PROBLEM THAT
NEEDS TO BE RESOLVED I THINK
THAT YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO. IT
AS A SAFETY OFFICER BE ABLE TO
RESPOND.
AT ANY MOMENT.
BUT I THINK THAT.
YOU PROBABLY ARE HAVING A BAD
EXPERIENCE WITH THE.
YOUR H. AWAY.
AND PERHAPS IF IN THE
AMENDMENTS.
TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT HAS AN
APPEALS PROCESS SO THAT IT ISN'T
AN ARBITRARY DECISION FROM NH
AWAY. BUT TO HEAR ABOUT THAT THE
BROAD.
HOW BROAD THIS IS DOES CAUSE
CONCERN?
BUT.
I I.
I WOULD SINCERELY REQUEST
THE DO CONSIDER THE AMENDMENTS
TO ALLOW IT TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND MS REYES I APPRECIATE THAT
NIGHT AND REALLY WANTED TO DO
THAT. FOR THIS TO MOVE FORWARD
TO HELP.
MR AS VETO OF BUT THIS DOESN'T
HELP MR AS A VETO IN THIS
SITUATION. A IT ACTUALLY IS HE
HAS TO RUN FROM HIS HOUSE.
GO ACQUIRE A LOCKED GATE
UNLOCKED IN. THE THAT THE GATE.
OPEN THE GATE GO OUT AND GET IS
VEHICLE COME OUT LOCK THE GATE.
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST NOT.
IT'S NOT.
CONDUCIVE TO WHAT THIS IS ALL OF
THIS PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICER NEEDS
TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND.
AND HIS TITLE OF OF PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICER WAS FEEDBACK OF
ILL I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
TO HAVE A WIN ON THIS BUT THIS
ISN'T A WIN THIS IS ACTUALLY.
PUNITIVE IN AND PUNISHING HIM
FOR BEING IN THAT AGE AWAY AND
WE AND AGAIN WE DID TRY TO
CONTACT THEM SEVERAL WAYS. TO
ITS DID SEE HOW WE CAN GET TO
YES WE WANTED TO WORK WITH THEM.
AND THEY PUT THEY WOULDN'T
ACKNOWLEDGE US AND AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE PENITENT AND WE HAVE
HEARD OF MANY MANY INSTANCES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THROUGH
POLL RACK.
ENSUED DIFFERENT.
ASSOCIATIONS THAT THEY'RE
HAVING THE SAME KIND OF. OF A
PROBLEMS IN IN THE STATE AND
THIS COMMITTEE HAS THE
JURISDICTION OVER. ON THIS THIS
ABILITY TO HAVE PUBLIC SAFETY.
ACKNOWLEDGED IN H. WAYS AN
UNFORTUNATE HOPE AND THAT
THERE'S NO PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES
COULD EVER HAPPEN IN AN H. AWAY
BECAUSE. FOR NOT ALLOWING THEM
IN.
I MEAN WHAT A TREASURE TO HAVE
SOMEBODY IN IT AND PUBLIC SAFETY
IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
BUT THEN THEY HAVE TO GO OUTSIDE
TO GO GET THEIR VEHICLE TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND. EVEN INSIDE.
BY YOUR RESPONSE SAYING THAT THE
THE AMENDMENTS ARE JUST
COMPLETELY OFF THE TABLE ARE YOU
WILLING TO LOOK AT THAT LOOK AT
THE AMENDMENTS. TOO SICK TO WORK
AT THE NEXT LEVEL TO SEE HOW YOU
CAN WORD IT IN SUCH A WAY. THAT
DOES PROVIDE THE PROTECTION FOR
THE REST OF THE HOMEOWNERS BY
HAVING SOMEBODY WITH THAT SUCH
AS MR SURVEY THOUGH THERE BUT
STILL THAT BROUGHT PROVIDES SOME
CONTROLLED BY THE H. HIGHWAYS.
AS TO HOW MANY OF THESE PERMITS
ARE GIVEN.
BECAUSE IT IT DOES WITH FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND SO SESSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND HAVING ALL OF
THEM BUT TOLD EXACTLY WHAT THEY
CAN AND CANNOT DO I THINK.
APPEARS TO BE OVER REACHING ON
OUR PART.
AND AGAIN I WOULD HOPE THAT THAT
THAT THAT PUBLIC SAFETY WOULD BE
EMBRACED INSTEAD OF VILIFIED.
NIGHT WHEN I THEY ARE VILIFYING
THIS MAN AND NOT RESPECTING HIS
POSITION IN THIS COMMUNITY AS AS
A LIFESAVER.
AND AGAIN IN MY AGE AWAY THERE
IS AN EXEMPTION FOR THAT
MARTINEZ POLICE OFFICER WHO HAS
A CANNON.
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT. OF ANY
AND WE DID TRY TO WORK WITH THE
H. AWAY WE TRIED EVERYTHING THAT
WE COULD. AND THEY THEY JUST
ABSOLUTELY REFUSE TO TO TO
RESPOND TO US.
.
THEY WANT THIRTY DOLLARS A
MONTH.
AND FOR HIM TO PARK HIS PRIVATE
CAR OVER BEHIND A LOCKED GATE IT
IN LIEU OF.
A IT JUST IS NOT REASONABLE WHEN
THERE'S ALL OF THESE EXTRA
SPACES THAT HE'S ACKNOWLEDGED.
THEY'RE AVAILABLE AND NOT
PUTTING ANYBODY ELSE OUT.
YOU NO FOR THIS FOR THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE IN AGAIN.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO.
.
MAKE IT HARDER MISTER AS VETO.
A.
BY TAKING THESE EXEMPT THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE JUST THEY JUST
DON'T WORK IN THIS SITUATION
THEY MAN OTHERS BUT THIS
SITUATION THEY JUST DON'T WORK.
AND AGAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY THE H. WAYS ARE
ARE ADMINISTERED TO BY.
THE LEGISLATURE NOT CITY
GOVERNMENTS
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE AND
ARE TRYING TO GO FORWARD.
TO WORK AND MAKE SURE THAT MR
AS YOU CAN DO HIS JOB IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
IF YOU OTHER.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT SING NONE.
IT'S FRAZIER MAKE CLOTHES OR
RELY STATEMENTS COULD BE YOUR.
I JUST WANTED RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE BUT I KNOW IT
WON'T HAPPEN TODAY.
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF THE
CHAIR AND I AND APPRECIATE BEING
A CHAIR ALSO.
BUT WE DO HAVE SUPPORT FROM
PORAC CAL FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA SET OF.
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION.
I WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AS THE CHAIRMAN
TRANSPORTATION ALSO AND HOW WE
CAN FURTHER SUPPORT THIS CAUSE
GOING FORWARD. IN ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THERE IS A NEED TO BE ABLE
TO.
.
BRIDGE THE SUBJECT WE'RE GOING
FORWARD AND.
AGAIN.
THIS.
I APOLOGIZE FOR RESPECTFULLY
DECLINING YOUR AMENDMENTS BUT IT
IS JUST THIS IS SOMETHING ABOUT
IT. ON MY CONSTITUENT I HAVE TO
RESPECT.
THANK YOU.
SO YES LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
STONE HERE CUNNINGHAM CHAO.
CHIU GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN. RACE HERE.
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
I AM LOOKING FOR A MOTION MOTION
WOULD BE TO PASS.
THE OF THE MOTION IS THEIR
SECOND.
SECOND IT THIS OCCURRED SEE.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECOND MOTION IS IS TO PASS.
KALRA PLEASE
STONE NO STONE NO CUNNINGHAM
CHAO.
CHIU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REST.
NOT VOTING.
SO WE'LL PUT THAT YOUR BILL A
CALL FOR OTHER MEMBERS WHEN THEY
SHOW UP THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST THANK YOU. AND
THEN YOU ALSO HAVE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
THREE.
YES SIR IN PROUD TO. ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT
SIMPLY BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY
THREE CONCERNS INSPECTIONS
INVOLVED CONSTRUCTION. DEFECT
LITIGATION REQUIRE INSPECTORS
TO BE LICENSED BY THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD.
I HAVE AGREED TO TAKE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE TODAY
OF THE BILL.
HOWEVER THERE'S GOING TO.
HOWEVER THERE'S ONGOING ABUSE OF
THE UNNECESSARILY LONG STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR CONSTRUCTION
DEFECTS.
WHICH LOCKS UP FUNDING THAT
COULD BE USED FOR FURTHER
DEVELOPMENT AND ULTIMATELY
DRIVES UP THE HOUSE OF COSTS A
COST OF HOUSING.
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION DEFECT
LAWS WERE HEAVILY NEGOTIATED
WELL OVER A DECADE AGO AND WE
HAD THE TIME TO SEE AND WE'VE
HAD THE TIME.
TO SEE THE FLAWS COME TO LIGHT.
PROBLEMS STEM FROM THOSE WHO
ABUSE THE SYSTEM TO MAKE A QUICK
BUCK.
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LAWS AROUND
FOR SALE RESIDENTIAL PROJECTS DO
NOT REQUIRE CLAIMANTS TO PROVE
ANY DAMAGE.
AND MANY TIMES A BRING
UNLICENSED INSPECTORS TO CONDUCT
DESTRUCTIVE TESTING.
COSTING BUILDERS COUNTLESS HOURS
AND.
AND DOLLARS TO CORRECT.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S DESPERATELY
NEEDED TIME AND.
EXCUSE ME OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED TIME AND
MONEY THAT COULD GO TOWARD
CLOSING CALIFORNIA'S HUGE.
HOUSING GAP.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR HAVE BEEN IN
THE BUILDING INDUSTRY FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AND I'VE SEEN THE
CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS BEING USED
AND AND A PREDATORY PRACTICES.
BEING USED TO.
TO A.
AGAINST THE DEVELOPERS AND
CONTRACTORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
IN THE NEXT SIX YEARS IT IF THE.
MY CONSTITUENTS CURRENT
CONTINUE TO KEEP ME HERE ON
WORKING TOWARDS A SOLUTION THAT
WORKS ON A CONSUMER PROTECTION.
AND ALSO A.
.
BUSINESS PROTECTION OF GOING
FORWARD.
.
IT IS JUST.
HE'S BEEN MANIPULATED AND THE
ONLY PERSON THAT LOSES IN ANY OF
THIS IS THE HOMEOWNER OR DID THE
A LANDOWNER. WHO'S DONE MULTI
FAMILY.
TO DATE WITH ME IS ROBERT OF A
PODCAST A WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS TO SPEAK ON
OF THE HARDSHIPS.
THIS LAW CREATES AS THEY TRY TO
BUILD HOMES FOR LOWER AND MIDDLE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
A GOOD FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ROBERT BACA
I'M A CO FOUNDER AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF. CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS.
UP UNLIKE WHAT THE THE NAME OF
ORGANIZATION IS WE'RE ACTUALLY
NOT A EIGHT A BUILDER NOT A
DEVELOPER.
AND I'LL GET BACK TO THAT.
WE ARE ADVOCATES FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND CLOSING THE
RACIAL AND AND ETHNIC WEALTH
GAP.
OF THAT WE HAVE HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY JUST AS A REMINDER
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION. ARE
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINOS
LOST BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OVERS OVER A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME DURING THE
MORTGAGE FORECLOSURE. A CRISIS
IT JUST TOOK A COUPLE YEARS FOR
THEM TO WIPE OUT SIX YEARS OF
ACCUMULATED WEALTH.
AND SO OF TODAY WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY IT WE'RE HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR APPROVAL FOR. AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY THREE WHICH IF
APPROVED WILL REQUIRE A TRAINED
AND LICENSE OUR INSPECTORS WHO
ARE THEN WILL GO TO INSPECT THE
BE.
CLAIMS FOR OF CONSTRUCTION
DEFECT.
AND.
WE THINK THAT WOULD BE STRAINED
EARNS AND AND.
CERTIFIED INSPECTORS THAT WILL
RESULT IN LESS CONSTRUCTION
LITIGATION A LAST OF LOWER COST
OF CONSTRUCTION. BY DEFINITION
HOPEFULLY LOWER COST OF
INSURANCE.
THAT THEREOF. DEVELOPERS WILL
WILL WILL BUILD MORE OF
AFFORDABLE CONDOMINIUMS AND
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO.
DRIVE LESS AND LIVE MORE AND
AND AND AND DICK AND BE
HOMEOWNERS OUT THAT'S THE
DESIRED RESULT OF AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY THREE.
BUT JUST A MINUTE ABOUT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BUILDERS OF
OF. ABOUT.
TWELVE YEARS AGO WE WANTED TO
APPROVE THE FACT THAT THE LOW
INCOME FOLKS COULD.
BUY A HOME SO WE WE.
SAID ABOUT TO BUILD OF HOMES AND
FIREBALL CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY THE GREAT
RECESSION STARTED ABOUT THEN BUT
MANAGED TO GET A CONSTRUCTION
LOAN AND BUILT TEN HOMES AND
SOLD THEM AND NOBODY HAS GONE
BANKRUPT SINCE THEN. SO WE WE WE
PROVED OUR POINT BUT WE ALSO.
LEARN THAT THERE'S PREVAILING
WAGE AND.
CONDO INSURANCE IN A LOT OF
OTHER FACTORS THAT GO INTO
DEVELOPMENT AND WE QUICKLY
CHANGED FROM BEING A DEVELOPER
TO BE AN ADVOCATE. AND I THINK
IT WAS A GOOD DECISION.
OF.
WE WE WE BELIEVE THAT.
SO WE START FOCUSING ON ON
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA
WHILE EVERYBODY ELSE IS TALKING
ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
NOW IT'S COMPLIMENTARY BUT WE
JUST DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH.
APPLY BEING BUILT IT IN IN THE
STATE.
AND.
AND SO UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
A LOT OF HOMES ARE BEING.
BUILT THAT ARE LIKE FOUR EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND A LOT MORE
BUT THERE'S IS MISSING MIDDLE
FOR OF WORKFORCE HOUSING AND
MILLENNIALS.
NO ONE'S PAYING ATTENTION TO
THAT PARTICULAR MARKET THERE'S A
LOT OF MONEY BEING SPENT. MAYBE
NOT ENOUGH ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUT THAT THE MISSING MIDDLE
DON'T HAVE VERY MANY OPTIONS AND
I BELIEVE THAT. KIND OF MILLIONS
ARE IT CAN BE A GATEWAY INTO
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
AND SO OF HARM I'M I'M IN FAVOR
OF OF THIS PARTICULAR BILL WHICH
WILL ENCOURAGE DEVELOPERS TO
BUILD.
OF MORE CONDOMINIUMS COULD
RIGHT NOW THEIR PRIORITIES TO
BUILD APARTMENTS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE OF THE THOSE THAT
ARE HAVE THE COMPLICATIONS OF
DEALING. WITH ITS INSPECTIONS
AND SO PLEASE VOTE YES.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RICHARD
MARX AND ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF THOSE SPECIAL TWO
GENERAL CONTRACTORS INCLUDING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS.
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION.
PLUMBING HEATING COOLING
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA WE
LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
BILL ONCE IMPRINT UP BUT WE
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH MISTER
FRAZIER. THAT LITIGATION
PARTICULARLY FOR LIST LITIGATION
A DRIVES UP HOUSING COSTS
A REDUCES HOUSING AVAILABILITY A
AND WE SUPPORT A INCREMENTAL
CHANGE BUT TO IMPROVE THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
RUTH WHAT CAL PASSED ESPECIALLY
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANGER RURAL CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR TAUGHT BLOOM SIGN
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
SPORTS WELL.
PETE MONTGOMERY FOR THAT STILL
JUST ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MANUALS AND SUPPORTS.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SINGER.
COME.
THEY DREADED TAKING THE THE
COMMITTEES.
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
MIX IT'S A MUCH EASIER BILL TO.
TO MOVE FORWARD ON.
TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TREASURY MAY CLOSE THANK YOU OF
AS I MENTIONED MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WAS PROUD
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR TO CREATE A HOUSING
BONDS.
BUT AS I TOLD MY CAUCUS MEMBERS
THAT THERE IS A HESITANCY. OF
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD MULTI FAMILY
HOMES BECAUSE OF S. B. EIGHT
HUNDRED.
CONSTRUCTION DEFECT LAW.
GENERALLY THESE LARGE SCALE
PROJECTS GOING TO LAWSUIT AT
NINE NINE YEARS SIX MONTHS
BECAUSE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IS TEN YEARS FOR
LLEYTON PEYTON DEFECTS.
BUT PRIMARILY HAVE BEEN FOUND
THAT THE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE OF LACK OF MAINTENANCE
AND IT BECOMES A BUSINESS
DECISION. FOR THE LIABILITY
COMPANY DE EITHER SETTLE OR
FIGHT THE THE CLAIM.
OF. KNOWING THAT AS AS AS
SOMETHING IS DONE THE SPECIAL
SCOPE OF WORK.
.
AS A SUPERINTENDENT FOR
DEVELOPERS I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THIS PROCESS BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW HOME INSPECTORS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. DO NOT NEED
TO BE LICENSED.
AND I'LL BE WORKING ON THAT ALSO
IN THE UPCOMING LEGISLATURE
BUT THE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE HIM AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT THEY'VE DONE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN HAVE A STEPPING
STONE TOWARDS FAIRNESS AND A
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
IF YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU. CHIU GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
CONSULT WATCHER I HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES I.
IT'S ONE MORE SOAP WITH A BILL
BECAUSE WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU.
SO THAT BRINGS THIS TO MISTER
BLOOM ITEMS NUMBER THREE AND
EIGHT.
AND AS MISTER BLOOM COMES UP
HERE I WILL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA UNLESS ANYONE
LIKE SOMETHING REMOVED.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ON CONSENT AGENDA CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAO.
CHIU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA. KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES REYES AYE.
THE CONSENT AGENDA IS ON CALL IT
NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE SO WE WILL
WAIT. IN ANTICIPATION.
THE MEANTIME.
TO BLOW YOU HAVE TO BILLS WITH
THIS ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
SIX.
SEVENTY ONE.
AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING CHO I'LL
BEGIN WITH AB TWENTY SEVENTY ONE
AND.
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR STAFF'S
WORK ON.
PROPOSING THOSE AMENDMENTS.
I AUTHORED AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
NINE A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHICH
EASTERN STREAMLINED A NUMBER OF
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE BUILDING OF
FIX A THREE TO ALLEN UNITS AND.
I'M GRATIFIED THAT SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THAT BILL WE'VE SEEN
IN A.
SPLOSION OF PERMITS FOR EIGHTY
IS ACROSS THE STATE.
SOME CITIES SAW HOWEVER STILL IN
THE DARK ON THE NEW RULES AND
IT'S TAKEN SOME TIME.
ARE BUT WE'RE WORKING ON THAT
AND OTHERS CONTINUE TO DRAG
THEIR FEET BUT WERE MAKING A
DENT IN ARE HOUSING NEEDS WITH
THESE RELATIVELY SMALL CHANGES
THAT. DIDN'T COST THE STATE
ANYTHING AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
NINE HAS LED TO THE CONSTRUCTION
OF MORE THAN FOUR THOUSAND
EIGHTY IS ACROSS THE STATE
ALREADY. NEARLY EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
OPEN PERMITTED IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES ALONE. AND DOES
THERE ARE.
OVER FOURTEEN HUNDRED UNITS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN PLANT
CHECK IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
CURRENT ELLIE DWP RULES
GOVERNING WATER EMPOWER ALLOW
FOR BUILDINGS TO BE BUILT IN THE
POWER LINE EASEMENT
WHICH IS THE DROP LINE UP.
OF FOR HIGH VOLTAGE LINES. OF.
THE COMMITTEE OUT NEAR THE EDGE
OF OUR PROPERTY LINE.
I.
THIS IS ALLOWED OVER UNINHABITED
BUILDINGS AND WHAT THIS IS
RESULTED IN.
IS A TREND OF GARAGES OR
RECREATION ROOMS BEING BUILT IN
THESE EASEMENT AREAS. OF THE
CITY OF LA HAS FOUND THAT SOME
OF THESE BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN
CONVERTED TO HABITABLE UNITS.
AND THERE'S PEOPLE LIVING IN
THEM THAT THE CITY WANTS TO AND.
COURAGE THE CONSTRUCTION OF BOTH
NEW INSTRUCTION. CONSTRUCTION OF
A BUT FOR OWNERS OF NON
PERMITTED CONVERSIONS THE CITY
WANTS TO.
UP PROVIDE FOR BRINGING THESE
UNITS
TWO OTHER BUILDING CODES
TO AID IN THEIR SAFETY.
I AB TWENTY TWENTY SEVENTY ONE
REMOVES LIABILITY RELATED TO
UTILITY SYSTEM FAILURE OR DAMAGE
TO STRUCTURES THAT WERE BUILT.
FOR JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT'VE BEEN CONVERTED
TO EIGHTY USE AFTER JANUARY TO.
FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THIS SMALL CHANGE COULD FREE UP
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIX HUNDRED PERMITS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY STALLED DUE TO THIS
VERY SPECIFIC AND UNIQUE ISSUE.
CONCERNING POWER LINE AND GARAGE
CONVERSIONS FOR EXISTING HOMES
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
THE LANGUAGE OF THE BELL DOES
NOT REMOVE LIABILITY FOR NEW
BUILDINGS BUILT IN POWER LINE
EASEMENTS AFTER JANUARY TWENTY
ONE. SUCH IN JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
BUT WITHOUT THIS CHANGE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER EMPOWER WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO ALLOW THESE UNITS
TO BE CONVERTED. UNLESS PART OF
THE BUILDING IS ACTUALLY REMOVED
FROM THAT EASEMENT AND THAT'S
VERY IMPRACTICAL.
A A SO THIS WOULD DISCOURAGE
HOMEOWNERS FROM SEEKING PERMITS
AT ALL FOR EXISTING NON
PERMITTED CONVERSIONS.
AND THAT WOULD RESULT IN THE
CONTINUATION OF ILLEGAL
STRUCTURES.
WITHOUT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND
INTRODUCE RD MANDELL WHO IS HERE
FROM MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI EASE
OFF.
THANK YOU. FIRST WITNESSED LA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
BILL WHICH.
ADDRESSES A VERY SPECIFIC ISSUE
FACED BY THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
AS WE A TEMPLATE AND ATTEMPT TO
IMPLEMENT THAT EIGHTY
LEGISLATION UPRIGHT PROVIDING
THIS NARROWLY TERROR TAILORED
CLARIFICATION OF CURRENT LAW. IN
CASES WHERE THE PRESENCE OF
THESE LADWP EASEMENTS ARE
PREVENTING THAT EIGHTY YOU
CONVERSIONS FROM TAKING PLACE.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOMS BILL.
AS HE MENTIONED WE SEEM
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED.
NEED TO USE A PERMITTED IN LOS
ANGELES AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR STRATEGY FOR
TACKLING.
THE CITY'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS.
THIS IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION TO
THAT CURRENT LAW WILL ALLOW
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED TO SIX
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL CONVERSIONS
TO TAKE PLACE.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED.
THERE ARE LOTS OF STRUCTURES
ARE IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
OUR REC ROOMS GARAGE IS THAT OUR
BELTS CURRENTLY IN THESE
EASEMENTS THAT MAY HAVE ALREADY
BEEN CONVERTED ILLEGALLY TO
THESE.
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS WERE.
AND WE'D LIKE TO HAVE THOSE
UNITS PROVIDE OF THE SHADOWS AND
BE BROUGHT UP TO CODE.
OR THAT WE'D LIKE PAT TO BE
CONVERTED.
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE BOTH THIS
NEW CONSTRUCTION FOR OWNERS OF
NON PERMITTED CONVERSION
SUPREMES UNITS UP TO CODE AND
ENCOURAGE NEW CONSTRUCTIONS ON
AND WITHOUT THIS CLARIFICATION.
THAT THE EXISTING COMMUNITIES
ALREADY IN LA APPLY.
THAT DID THAT LADWP WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO LEVEES UNITS TO BE
CONVERTED.
AND LESS THAT HOMEOWNER TAKES
THE.
PROHIBITIVE COST OF REMOVING
PARTS OF THE BUILDING IN SOME
CASES I'M WE'RE NOT EXACTLY SURE
HOW MANY PROJECTS.
MAY ULTIMATELY GET REJECTED.
OR ALTERED TO ME DWP
REQUIREMENTS.
BUT OF A DO YOU EIGHTY YOU
CONVERT FROM PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ISSUED PERMITS SINCE I
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ONLY EIGHT PERCENT HAVE.
RECEIVED A CLEARANCE TO PROCEED
FROM DWP. AND WE KNOW THAT
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THE
UNITS.
.
IN PLANCHETTE MEET BACK CLARENCE
SO THERE'S CLEARLY.
ADULTERY HERE AND AND.
NUMBER PROJECTS THAT CAN
ADDRESS OUR.
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THAT ARE
GETTING APPROVED.
SIR THANK YOU OFFER
CONSIDERATION INVESTMENT.
.
PATENT.
THANK YOU THANK IF ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
CIGNA BRING BACK THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
TO HAVE SECOND.
AND A SECOND THINK IT WAS KILEY.
I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION IT
LOOKS LIKE THE BILL REGIONALLY
PRIDE TO OTHER CITIES AND WAS.
AMENDED TO JUSTIFY LA.
ANY REASON WHY I YOU KNOW ONE
EXTENDED OTHER CITIES AT THIS
POINT.
BR A PROMISE ONLY BROUGHT BEEN
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION VIA THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AT THIS TIME
AND SO.
WAS CONSIDERED BEST JUST
RESTRICTED TO THAT ONE CITY.
SING OTHER QUESTIONS
BLOOM YOU MAY CLOSE.
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS CERTAINLY
AT THE REFORM OF THE EIGHTY YOU
LAWS HAS PROVEN TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL IN A BIPARTISAN WAY
AND I DON'T MEAN REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS I MEAN. NIMBIS IN THE
EMBRACE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
BRIDGING THE DIVIDE MISTER BILL
BRIDGING THE DIVIDE.
ALL RIGHT WE DO OF THE MOST TO
SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAO.
CHIU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KILEY. KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILLS ON CALL.
NOT FOR LACK OF POPULARITY BUT
LACK OF MEMBERS.
SO WITH YOUR TAXATION OKAY. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU AGAIN THAT OF MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SAID AND TO
ONCE AGAIN WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS. ANALYSIS AND
WORK ON THIS BILL THIS BILL IS
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THE ALICE
ACT IS USED FOR ITS INTENDED
PURPOSE.
WHICH IS SET SIMPLY PUT TO
ALLOW LANDLORDS TO EXIT THE
RENTAL MARKET.
BUT IT IS NOT INTENDED AS A
TOOL TO AVOID COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LOCAL RENT CONTROL LAW.
THE ELLIS ACT.
EXPRESSLY PROHIBITS WITHDRAWING
LAST ALL OF FOR THE UNITS OF A
BUILDING FROM THE RENTAL MARKET.
THE LOG INDICATES THAT THERE'S
ONLY ONE WITHDRAWAL DATE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CALCULATING RENTAL
AMOUNTS WHEN UNITS ARE RE
OFFERED FOR RENT.
AS CAN BE A AS CAN OCCUR UNDER
THE HOUR FACT BUT THERE IS ALSO
LANGUAGE GOVERNING THE TENANTS
LEASE TERMINATION DATE. THAT
SEEMS TO ALLOW MULTIPLE
WITHDRAWAL DATES IN ADDITION
THERE IS A PROVISION THAT
SPECIFIES THAT THERE'S ONLY ONE
DAY THAT APPLIES IF THE PROPERTY
IS PUT BACK ON THE RENTAL
MARKET.
AS A CONSEQUENCE
SOME LANDLORDS
OF TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THIS
CONFUSION AND REMOVED UNITS FROM
THE RENTAL MARKET. AND RETURN
THEM IN A PIECEMEAL FASHION TO
AVOID THE ACT'S RESTRICTIONS AND
EVADE RENT CONTROL.
SOME ARE ALSO APPLYING DIFFERENT
WITHDRAWAL DATES TO DIFFERENT
UNITS AND CLAIMING THAT
RETURNING ONE UNIT TO THE
MARKET.
DOES NOT OBLIGATE THE LANDLORD
TO RE OFFER ANY OTHER UNITS TO
FORMER TENANTS.
THIS ALLOWS LANDLORDS TO
EFFECTIVELY WITHDRAW LASTED ALL
OF THE UNITS FROM THE RENTAL
MARKET AND IN FACT NEVER.
ACTUALLY LEAVE THE RENTAL
MARKET.
IS THE INTENDED PURPOSE OF
ELLIS.
OF ALL WHILE STILL HAVING
SUCCESSFULLY EVICTED ALL OF THE
EXISTING TENANTS AND INCREASING
THE RENTS.
SO THIS CONFUSION AS LEAD AT
LEAST ONE COURT OF APPEAL TO
FIND THAT A LANDLORD COULD APPLY
DIFFERENT WITHDRAWAL DATES TO
DETERMINE THE RENTAL AMOUNT WHEN
RE RENTING A UNIT.
THIS ALLOWED THE LANDLORD TO
CHOOSE A DATE OUTSIDE THE WINDOW
OF TIME WHEN THE ACT WOULD
REQUIRE THOSE UNITS TO BE
OFFERED.
PRIOR RENT CONTROLLED RAE
DESPITE HAVING RETURNED MULTIPLE
OTHER UNITS ON THE PROPERTY THE
RENTAL TO THE RENTAL MARKET AT
AN EARLIER TIME.
THE LANDLORD NEVER ACTUALLY LEFT
THE RENTAL MARKET BUT
NEVERTHELESS WAS ABLE TO EVICT
ALL THE TENETS AND RE RENT ALL
OF THE UNITS AT MARKET RATES.
THIS I THINK A OF WE SHOULD ALL
AGREE IS A GROSS DISTORTION AND
SUBVERSION OF THE PURPOSE OF THE
ALICE ACT.
WHETHER WE AGREE WITH THAT
PURPOSE OR NOT.
ACCORDING TO THE RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS THE COURTS ARE
MISINTERPRETING THE LAW AS A
RESULT OF THE CREATIVE ACTIONS
OF A FEW LANDLORDS.
AND IT'S IMPERATIVE TO CLARIFY
WHAT THE LAW HAS MEANT ALL
ALONG.
I. THANK YOU AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE IN ONE INTRODUCED
ALISON REAGAN WITH THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD AND BRIAN
AUGUSTA.
WHO IS REPRESENTING THE SANTA
MONICA RENT CONTROL?
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS
ALLISON REGAN I'M A STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD.
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
ALICE ACT WAS TO ALLOW LANDLORDS
TO EVICT ALL THE TENANTS FROM
THE PROPERTY ALL AT ONCE.
IN ORDER TO COMPLETELY LEAVE THE
RENTAL MARKET AND PUT THAT
PROPERTY TO A DIFFERENT YEARS.
BUT BECAUSE THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT IN THE ALICE ACT TO
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY A VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE USE BEFORE SERVING
EVICTION NOTICES. AND BECAUSE
COSTA HAWKINS ALLOWS LANDLORDS
TO SET THE RENTS AT MARKET RATES
UPON A VACANCY WE'RE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN ABUSE OF THE ELLIS
ACT BECAUSE OF THE ENORMOUS
PROFITS TO BE MADE. IN GETTING
OUT FROM UNDER THE RENT
LIMITATIONS IN JURISDICTIONS
WITH RENT CONTROL. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS ARE JUST
TOO WEAK TO PROVIDE A REAL
DETERRENT. IN THE FACE OF
SKYROCKETING MARKET RENTS.
SO THAT AND WE AGREE THAT MOST
LANDLORDS YOU SALAS
APPROPRIATELY WHICH IS ALL THE
MORE REASON TO CRACKDOWN ON
THOSE UNSCRUPULOUS LANDLORDS WHO
ARE CREATING HOUSING
INSTABILITY.
AND PUTTING THOSE LAW ABIDING
LANDLORDS AT A DISTINCT
DISADVANTAGE
SO THESE AMENDMENTS ARE DESIGNED
TO REDUCE THE INCENTIVE TO GAME
THE SYSTEM. PRESERVE AFFORDABLE
HAVE PRESERVE EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE IS PLAYING BY THE
SAME RULES AND THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT ELLIS IS USED ONLY AS IT
WAS INTENDED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S BURKE THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS TRYING TO CAST ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA MONICA
RECTAL BOARD AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE.
THE THE THE GOAL OF THE BILL
HAS BEEN WELL DESCRIBED OF HIS.
.
NOW ATTACK EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE
DOING THIS BILLS CONSISTENT WITH
THE ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF THE ALICE ACT AND WILL LIMIT
MISUSE OF THE ACT AND HELP
PRESERVE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AND SOME OF OUR MOST EXPENSIVE.
WHEN HOUSING MARKETS AND FOR
THAT REASON WE URGE IN ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS.
GRANT MARK NO BE OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION STONE.
JEFF TURKEY HAVE AN APPLICANT.
NATIVE SACRAMENT BUT HAVE LIVED
IN LOS ANGELES AND SO INDEED
SEEMED THE SIG EGGED HER SO.
GUESTS PLEASE
MAKE THIS CHANGE IN SUPPORT.
AND SEE WHAT YOU DO ABOUT HOW
YOU ENFORCE IT. THANK YOU.
A ROBERT CULP CONCERNED CITIZEN
IN SUPPORT.
TURN MEMBERS SYLVIA SO LEAST
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA.
SELENA COUPLED WITH A LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SAY NONE OPPOSITION.
MORNING MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MERSHON'S A PECKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING
VERY DILIGENTLY WITH US TO CRAFT
AND THE COMMITTEE TO CRAFT
LANGUAGE.
THAT PROTECTS THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE ELLIS ACT.
IT'S A VERY CRITICAL TOOL USED
BY PROPERTY OWNERS AND IT'S ONE
THAT WE HAVE ALWAYS OPPOSED ANY
CHANGES TO. BUTI THINK WITH THE.
AMENDMENTS IN THE IN THE
LANGUAGE. WE ARE COMFORTABLE
REMOVING OPPOSITION ALONG WITH
THE REST OF OUR.
COALITION PARTNERS THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THE CHAMBER THE
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION.
HARLEM AND CIVIL DISSOCIATION
SLOGAN WE THANK YOU FOR THAT
ONCE WE SEE LANGUAGE WERE A
FAIRLY CONFIDENT WILL REMOVE ALL
OF OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M.
IT IS MINISTER CHAIR RUN
KINGSTON I REPRESENT FOR
REGIONAL PARK ASSOCIATIONS.
PARTNERS SO FUTURE ORANGE COUNTY
EAST BAY.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
NORTH VALLEY.
I'M I WANT TO SPEAK TO ONE
PRIMARY ISSUE AND THAT'S IT.
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE.
THE AUTHOR GRACIOUSLY AGREED TO
RESTORE LANGUAGE RELATING TO THE
NUMBER OF YEARS.
THAT.
THE RESTRICTIONS WOULD APPLY
HEAT IT UP ORIGINALLY PROPOSED
THAT THE RESTRICTIONS WOULD BE
DOUBLED FROM FIVE YEARS TO TEN
YEARS.
HE DID THAT IN PARAGRAPH A IN
THE BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY. WE DIDN'T FINISH.
MAKING THOSE.
AMENDMENTS
AND THOSE AMENDMENTS ALSO NEED
TO BE MADE IN PARAGRAPH SEE.
IN PARAGRAPH SEE.
APPEAR THE NECESSARY LANGUAGE
THAT NEEDS TO BE MODIFIED HAVE
EVERYTHING INTERNALLY
CONSISTENT.
APPEARS ON PAGE FIVE LINES FOUR
THROUGH SEVEN.
IT IT SAYS IN EFFECT.
THAT THE OWNER SHALL OFFER THE
SAME TERMS AND CONDITIONS.
INCLUDING THE SAME RENT FOR TEN
YEARS SHOULD YOU EVER GO BACK
INTO THE RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS
THAT IS NOT CONSISTENT.
WITH.
THE FIRST PARAGRAPH WHICH
APPEARS ON PAGE THREE WE'VE
OUTLINED THIS SET TO YOUR STAFF.
AND.
MANY OTHERS ARE WE BELIEVE THAT
MISTER BLOOM.
NOW WILL.
MAKE THE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS
IN PARAGRAPH
SEE TO HAVE EVERYTHING FLOW THE
RESTRICTIONS WILL.
ASSISTANT LEE APPLY TO THE FIRST
FIVE YEARS ONCE.
THEPROPERTY OWNER GOES OUT OF
BUSINESS ARE AND SHOULD THOSE
AMENDMENTS BE MADE OR OF MEN
MEANT.
NOW WE WILL WITHDRAW OUR
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
UP MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DEEP
CARLSON FOR THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES IN THE SANTA BARBARA
PROPERTY ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS HAVE DONE
AND THE WORK THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS DONE. WE WOULD AGREE WITH
MISTER KING STAND UP WE AND
ORDERED FOR THE BILL TO BE
CONSISTENT. ALL THOSE TYPE
PERIOD SHOULD BE THE FIVE YEAR
TIME PERIOD. UP.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT IS
THAT WITH THE WITH THE
COMPLICATION OF THIS LAW. THEIR
A LOT OF VERY SMALL OWNERS THAT
CAN STEP THEIR TOE FROM ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE BILL
REQUIRES IS THAT IF THE UNIT IS
BROUGHT BACK. EARLY CLOSE QUOTE.
THAT THEY CAN BE HIT WITH
PUNITIVE DAMAGES ON THE CAP ON
PUNITIVE DAMAGES THAT HAS BEEN
IN THE BILL FOR.
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS WAS REMOVED
IN A PREVIOUS AMENDMENT AND WE'D
LIKE AT LEAST A CONSIDERATION
THAT SOME KIND OF A CAP ON
PUNITIVE DAMAGES BEACON CENTER
TO BE ADDED ESPECIALLY IN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE. SOMEONE
MIGHT NOT HAVE.
ACTED IN A.
IN AN INTENTIONAL FASHION BUT
CAN TO STOP THEIR TOE ON ON SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT CAN BE
COMPLICATED THIS LEVEL WE
APPRECIATE WHAT THE AUTHOR IS
TELLING THE FOUR PORT CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
AND WHAT I WILL TAKE A MORE
TESTIMONY IF YOU JUST GIVE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION.
YES SIR ARE GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CREAM GREASY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION.
SECURE MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY APARTMENT ASSOCIATION TO
ASSIST TERROR CELLS WITH MR
CARLSON'S COMMENTS.
OVER STILL OPPOSED WEEK LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
SINGH NANDA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
COMMENTS.
AND STILL LOOKING FOR THE MOTION
MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
I DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SO BLOOM EMEKA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF. A YOU'VE HEARD THAT
TESTIMONY AND OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WILL CONTINUE TO DISCUSS
THOSE ISSUES WITH THE OPPOSITION
THAT.
MISTER KINGSTON FIRST RAISED
THE ISSUE DIRECTLY WITH ME ABOUT
TEN MINUTES AGO.
AND SO I'M NOT PREPARED TO
DISCUSS THE ISSUE IN DETAIL IF
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT A.
THAT MEANS THAT REAGAN CAN
RESPOND TO THEM BUT I I I I I I
WOULD SAY THAT IT'S PUT IT THERE
BY BOTH THE FATHER. OF MY
WITNESSES SETUP PRIVATELY TO ME
THAT OF THESE ARE TWO SEPARATE
TO UP PROVISIONS. OF THAT AND
THAT THERE'S.
NOT AN INTERNAL COULD THEY ARE
DIFFERENT THEY'RE DIFFERENT TIME
PERIODS FOR A STE
IT REASON AND THEY'RE NOT
INTERNALLY. INCONSISTENT AS A
RESULT OF THAT I'M WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND PROCEDURALLY YOU HAVE
SATISFIED THIS COMMITTEE AT
LEAST IN MY VIEW AND THEIR
RECOMMENDATION STILL STANDS.
SO THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHOW. CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN NO
REYES.
REYES I.
WE NEED ONE MORE SOAP WHICH
ALONG COUGH THANK YOU.
SO MISTER CALDERON UP YES HERE
SO MISTER CALDERON.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT.
THEY IS YOU MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND EFFORTS
LIKE START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
FOR THE WORK.
WHAT THE SOME BUT THE
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH OF BALK WATCHING
WORKING GROUP TO STUDY THE USE?
THE USES OF RISKS AND BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH AND THE LEGAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THE USE A
BLOCKCHAIN BY STATE GOVERNMENT
CALIFORNIA BASED BUSINESSES.
A BLOCKCHAIN IS A TYPE OF
DISTRIBUTED LEDGER THAT KEEPS
CONTINUOUSLY UPDATING DIGITAL
RECORDS BLOCKCHAIN HOLD
TREMENDOUS PROMISE AND HAS MANY
POTENTIAL APPLICATIONS THAT CAN
BENEFIT CONSUMERS. BUSINESSES
AND INDUSTRIES AND CALIFORNIAN
WORLDWIDE BLOCKCHAIN ALLOWS
PARTIES WHO HAVE NEVER MET AND
HAVE LITTLE REASON TO TRUST EACH
OTHER TO CONDUCT SENSITIVE
BUSINESS TRANSACTIONS.
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY AS A
COMPLEX EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES IS
IMPORTANT A FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
LEGAL IMPLICATIONS OF THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF STATE
OR LOCAL REGULATION A
BLOCKCHAIN.
THE WORKING GROUP WILL REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE POTENTIAL
USES REST AND BENEFITS. OF THE
USE OF BLOCKING TECHNOLOGY BY
STATE GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA
BASED BUSINESSES THE WORKING
GROUP WILL ALSO RECOMMEND
AMENDMENT STICK TO CODE SECTIONS
IN ORDER TO FOSTER INNOVATION IN
CALIFORNIA WITH BLOCKCHAIN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS. DAVID ROTHBLATT IT
AND.
BERKELEY VICE MAYOR BAND
BARTLETT.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS WITH.
BLOG MORNING THANKS MUCH AND I
WANNA THANK FOR YOUR WORK AND
THAT WAS SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS LAW AND THIS BILL IN THE
AMENDMENT. UP TO GUARD THE
WORKING GROUP.
MONEY'S BEEN BARTLETT VERSUS
VICE MAYOR BERKELEY AND AUTHOR
OF THE BIRTH THE BLOCKCHAIN
INITIATIVE. AND THAT INITIATIVE.
WE WE WERE OUR EFFORT IS TO USE
BLOCKING TECHNOLOGY TO ISSUE
BONDS
A THREE CAN EXPAND ASSET CLASSES
THESE BONDS CAN BE. ARE WE
BOUGHT FOR THOSE FIVE DOLLARS.
THIS HAVE EXPAND OUR ASSET
OWNERSHIP ARE ADDRESS POVERTY.
AND WEALTH CREATION AMONG AMONG
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN ORDER A BEER
THEIR NAY PEOPLE.
SPILLED TECHNOLOGY.
NOW CALIFORNIA'S JUST BECOME THE
FIFTH ARTS ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
WHICH IS FANTASTIC.
BUT ORDER FOR US TO MAINTAIN
THIS LEAD AND TO GROW IN THE
FUTURE WE HAVE TO EMBRACE THE
TECHNOLOGY.
BECAUSE ASIA AS.
JAPAN IS CHINA'S KOREA AS INDIA
IS
SO WE SHOULD AS WELL.
ARM AND THEY'RE BUILT THE
PERMUTATIONS AND THE BENEFITS
ARE ARE LIMITLESS AND SO I URGE
THE CREATION OF A WORKING
GROUP'S REALLY OUTLAY.
A MECHANISM TO EMBRACE OUR
ECONOMY AND WILL FORWARD INTO
THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
WHAT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH UP MY
NAME IS DAVID CROSS FLAT.
I RUN A CO WORKING AN INCUBATOR
IN SAN FRANCISCO CO FOUNDERS
DOJO.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
WE'VE WORKED WITH HUNDREDS OF
START UPS AND FOUNDERS THAT HAVE
GENERATED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY AS WELL. A WE GOT
INTO BLACK CHAIN AROUND TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND WE QUICKLY
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS COULD BE A.
MAJOR IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGY THAT
COULD REVOLUTIONIZE THE WAY
BUSINESS IS HELD AS WELL AS THE
WAY HOMELESS OFF SYSTEMS ARE
OPERATED ONE LINE. ITEM.
ALREADY IT'S HAD HUGE IMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE GLOBAL CENTER FOR BLOCKCHAIN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE COME
INTO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AROUND
THE BLOCK CHAIN. AND I'M HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT THIS TIME IT'S
NOT JUST A BAY AREA PHENOMENON.
.
BAY AREA SINGLE BLOOM THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT FOUNDERS
ENTREPRENEURS ARE COMING IN A
WAY THAT I HAVEN'T SEEN SINCE
WEB ONE POINT NOW. BUT IT'S ALSO
HAPPENING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND SILICON BEACH
AND OUR MANY OF THE TECHNICAL
APPLICATIONS OF BLOCKCHAIN. CAN
APPLY TO LOGISTICS AGRICULTURE
INFRASTRUCTURE GOVERNMENTS THESE
ARE ALL IMPORTANT INDUSTRIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THINK IT'S SUPER IMPORTANT AND
RELEVANT REP RELATIVE THAT THIS
IS GOING TO HAVE BIG IMPACT
ACROSS THE ENTIRE ECONOMY
CONTINUE TO HAVE IMPORTANT.
ARE WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW
IS THAT WE NEED SOME PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
TO UNDERSTAND THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY TO DEFINE THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY SO THAT. ARE
ENTREPRENEURS CAN.
MOVE FORWARD WITH SOME SOME
CONFIDENCE
I AS WELL AS SO THAT WE CAN
COMMUNICATE WELL WITH.
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AND PUBLIC
POLICY.
ETCETERA SO I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS WORKING GROUP
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED TO
GET THE NEXT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CHRIS MCKAY WE
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
JERRY MCKEE REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
AND SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
HI TERRY SO YOUNG UP PREVIOUS
PUBLIC SERVANT BUT DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE AND CURRENT BLOCKCHAIN
ENTREPRENEUR AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
JASON WONG CRYPTOCURRENCY
ENTREPRENEUR AND I SPLIT THE
SPELL.
NICHOLAS ANDREW BLOCKCHAIN
ENTREPRENEUR STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND THE WORKING GROUP
AMENDMENT.
MICHELLE SHANG HAN SUCH AN
ENTREPRENEUR IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND THE AMEND.
OKAY I'M OKAY SHIMMER MAJOR
PARTNERS YES BLOCKCHAIN IN A
SUPPORT THIS AMENDMENT UNTIL.
JACK BENNETT OAKLYN INDUSTRY
AFFILIATION INDUSTRIAL HAVE
MANUFACTURING LLC.
SUPPORT THE BILL AN AMENDMENT.
IF YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SAY NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THINK THIS CALDERON
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD THE
BLOCKCHAIN. TECHNOLOGIES IS NAY
SINCE AND I THINK TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
HOW ITS APPLICATIONS ARE
RELEVANT OR USEFUL IN THE IN THE
PUBLIC SPACE I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT?
IT HAS.
HUGE POTENTIAL IN
COULD IN THE ENTIRE REFORM IN
THE PAYMENT SYSTEM.
BECAUSE OF ITS PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC COMPONENTS TO IT HAS REAL
VERY INTERESTING.
POTENTIAL EVEN FOR VOTING AND
FOR OTHER THINGS ROLES THAT.
THAT THERE ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
THE GOVERNMENT WHERE WE WANT TO
PROTECT PRIVACY TO THE EXTENT WE
CAN BUT ALSO HAVE PUBLICLY
VERIFIABLE.
SYSTEMS THAT ARE THERE.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF OF WORKING
EXAMPLES THE BLOCKCHAIN BITCOIN
AND A FEW OTHER THINGS OTHER
EXAMPLES HAVE YET TO REALLY SEE
BUT I KNOW THAT. THAT THAT IS
DEVELOPING SO IT'S IT'S AN
INTERESTING TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS HELP THE STATE
IDEALLY KEEP CURRENT. AND THAT
WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE A GOOD
THING AND AND FIND USEFUL
APPLICATIONS FOR.
PUBLIC INTERESTS.
SO ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS.
RIGHT SIGNIN SOUTHERN YOU MAKE
LOVE WELL ONE I THINK YOU GUYS
OFFER YOUR TIME JUST SO YOU KNOW
IT'S A BIT QUAN WHICH IS GROUP
THE CURRENCY BLOCKCHAIN IS THE
PIC COIN WHAT. THE INTERNET IS
TO EMAIL AND ALSO IT'S A IT'S A
COMPLETELY ARE UPDATING SYSTEM
WHERE IT PROVIDE CERTAINTY IN
CLARIFICATION SO THAT
INTERMEDIARIES CAN COMMUNICATE
AGAINST IT. LIVE WITHIN EACH
OTHER LEASE MONETARILY TO BE
ABLE TO VERIFY THAT MONEY IS
THERE IF YOU SAY IT'S THERE SO
IF YOU. I'M HERE IN THIS IN THE
UNITED STATES IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S
IN ANOTHER COUNTRY AND I WANT TO
SEND MONEY TO SOMEBODY ELSE
ANOTHER COUNTRY WHAT HAPPENS NOW
IS A BUNCH INTERMEDIARY BANKS
TRY VERIFIED THAT THE MONEY IS
IN THE MY ACCOUNT BEEN ORDER
TRANSFER THAT MONEY. WILL BE
GOING TO BLOCKING TECHNOLOGY
ALLOWS IT TO BE INSTANTANEOUS.
WITH CONSTANT UPDATING OF THAT
LEGISLATIVE LEDGER TO BUILD THE
VERIFY THAT THE MONEY'S THERE SO
YOU CUT OUT ALL THOSE ANY MERIT
IN IT INTERMEDIARY BANKS SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF.
USEFUL APPLICATIONS OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS REALLY SOMETHING
AS AN INNOVATIVE AND IT'S AN
INNOVATION LEADER IN THE WORLD
NOT JUST THIS COUNTRY BUT THE
WORLD THAT THE STATE. I THINK
THE SERIOUSLY I THINK THIS
WORKING GROUPS HELPS ESTABLISH.
YOU KNOW A GREAT POLICY MOVE
FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RELIABLE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS A
MEDICAL ROUGHLY STONE BY STONE
AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAO. CHOW I CHIU
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AND THOSE FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY THAT PUTS
OUT. THE FIRST BILL
THAT TODAY THAT'S WONDERFUL
LET'S CONTINUE THE TRENDS.
OKAY MISTER BERMAN.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS WITH US TODAY
I'M LOOKING FOR THE VOTE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AND ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN.
I NEVER SIX IS AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY AND OVER FOURTEEN IS. AB
TWENTY THIRTY TWO SEVENTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WILL TRY
TO CONTINUE THE TREND.
AND ALSO WITH AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY.
THAT WOULD BE FUN.
I DON'T EVER SIX AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES I
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY A BILL TO
CREATE. TO SEPARATE STATEMENT
RELATED EFFICIENCIES IN CIVIL
LITIGATION.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR HIS
WORK ON THIS BILL WILL BE
PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
SEVEN AND TOP OF PAGE EIGHT OF
THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY ON
THIS BILL.
THANKS FOR JOINING ME APPRECIATE
IT.
COLLEAGUES AS YOU WERE FAMILIAR
FROM YOUR SERVICE ON THIS
COMMITTEE ONE COURTS LACK OF
RESOURCES CIVIL LITIGATION IS
AMONG THE FIRST TO FEEL IT.
AS A RESULT THE PLAINTIFF AND
DEFENSE BAR TWO GROUPS THAT ARE
NOT ALWAYS ON THE SAME PAGE HAVE
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER IN RECENT
YEARS TRIED THEN A FIVE FISH AND
SEES THAT CAN BENEFIT ALL
PARTICIPANTS.
FOR THOSE WHO DID WHO.
FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT PRACTICE
CIVIL LITIGATION SEPARATE
STATEMENTS ARE RECITATIONS OF
THE LAW AND FACTUAL EVIDENCE AT
THE CORE OF A MOTION.
WELL THE GOAL OF ATTACHING
SEPARATE STATEMENTS IS TO HAVE A
SINGLE DOCUMENT THAT
ENCAPSULATES ALL ISSUES IT CAN
EASILY BECOME UNWIELDY.
ACCORDINGLY THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW CORDON DISCOVERY TO HAVE A
PARTY SUBMIT A CONCISE OUTLINED
IN LIEU OF OF A WOMAN IS FILING.
IN ADDITION FOR SUMMER JUDGMENT
MOTIONS THE BILL WOULD ALLOW A
PARTY TO LIST STATEMENTS IN A
MORE LOGICAL ORDER BY CAUSE OF
ACTION OR COUNT.
THESE CHANGES ARE NEITHER
RADICAL NOR CONTROVERSIAL BUT
THEY WILL PROVIDE HELPFUL
STREAMLINING.
AYE ASKER AYE VOTE AND I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY SABRINA TO CAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA. AND MIGHT BELOW
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL.
IT WE GIVE MOTION IS THEIR
SECOND.
AND A SECOND
NICE TO SEE BOTH AT THE SAME
TABLE SAMETIME THAT'S HOW LOVELY
THEIR SUPPORT SUPPORT. OF BOTH
SIDES SO FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
THE ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS THE CALIFORNIA THINK
WE'VE COVERED MOST WEBER PLEASED
TO COSPONSOR THE BILL. EVERY
YEAR ON THE SEA AT THE NCTC ME
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT CAME UP AND WE THINK IT
GIVES THE JUDGE IN OPTION TO.
ALLOW FOR MORE EFFICIENT MEANS
AB DID MOVING RUSHED TO COMPILE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS MIKE BLOOD ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL AND
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION WHO HAVE AN INTEREST
IN THIS WE DO BELIEVE THIS THAT
WILL LEAD TO EFFICIENCIES. WE
APPRECIATE MISTER KILEY IN
AUTHORING AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
ONE SOME OF WHICH HAS BEEN
INCORPORATED HERE IN. A WEEK
WILL CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION.
.
SOMETIMES EFFICIENCIES AND
ECONOMIES ARE IN THE EYE OF THE
BEHOLDER. WE HOPE TO A ASSIST OF
THE OTHER PARTNERS AND BEHOLDING
THE WISDOM OF SOME OF OUR OTHER
IDEAS AND WE'LL KEEP THE
COMMITTEE INVOLVED IN THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THE EDITORIAL
COMMENTS.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
CIGNA CIGNA OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SAY NOT BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
TO BERMAN YOU MIKLOS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK
BAKING BICU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS
AS A MEDIC CULTURAL PLEASE STONE
AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM. CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA. KALRA IKE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES.
REYES I.
THAT ELIZABETH'S
SO MISTER BERMAN ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY.
GREAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES I
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY TO PRESENT
AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTEEN A BILL
TO ADDRESS MISLEADING
ADVERTISING IN THE LEGAL SECTOR.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR HER
WORK.
ON THIS BILL IN THE CHAIR FOR
YOUR EARLY ENGAGEMENT I'LL BE
PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT
SPECIFIED ON PAGE TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS.
I SUSPECT THAT EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM HAS WATCHING ADVERTISEMENT
ASKING IF YOU'VE TAKEN A
PARTICULAR PRESCRIPTION DRUG OR
HAD AN IMPLANTABLE MEDICAL
DEVICE SUCH AS A HERNIA MASS.
THE MESSAGES CAN EASILY LEAD A
PERSON TO WONDER IF THE
MEDICATION PRESCRIBED OR DEVICE
IMPLANTED BY THEIR DOCTOR IS
DOING MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED THE
EXISTING CONTEXT OF THE BILL
WOULD BE STRUCK AND REPLACED BY
A NARROW TO SENTENCE ADDITION TO
THE CONSUMER LEGAL REMEDIES ACT.
THIS BILL LIKE THE CONSUMER
LEGAL REMEDIES ACT IS INTENDED
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM
DECEPTIVE BUSINESS PRACTICES.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD
EXTEND THE CONSUMER LEGAL
REMEDIES ACT TO MATERIAL MEANT
TO MATERIALLY MISLEADING
ADVERTISING OF LEGAL SERVICES TO
PERSONS WHO MAY ALLEGE INJURY
FROM PRESCRIPTION DRUG OR
IMPLANTABLE MEDICAL DEVICE.
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL PROVIDES
THAT AN ADVERTISEMENT MAYBE
CONSIDER MATERIALLY MISLEADING
IF IT EITHER MATERIALLY
UNDERSTATES THE BENEFITS OF A
DRUG OR DEVICE OR MATERIALLY
OVERSTATES THE RISK ASSOCIATED
WITH THE DRUG OR DEVICE.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS CAN SAVE
LIVES AND MEDICAL DEVICES CAN
MAKE QUALITY OF LIFE BETTER BUT
I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT NEITHER
IS PERFECT.
MY HOPE IS THAT THE BILL WILL
LEAD TO DO WHAT LEAD THOSE
PUTTING FORTH THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS TO MORE CAREFULLY
CONSIDER HOW THE CHARACTERIZED
BOTH THE UPSIDE AND DOWNSIDE OF
DRUGS AND MEDICAL DEVICES.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND I HAVE
WITH ME.
TODAY MIGHT BELOW.
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUL JUST
ASSOCIATION.
ORGY.
JOHN DOUGHERTY.
OR WHOEVER WANTS TO DIRECT
APPRECIATED.
ARE JOHN DORY AND HAVE THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO ONE
SEVEN. I DO WANNA ECHO BOTH
THANKS TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND
HIS STAFF AS WELL AS THE CHAIR
AND AND HIS STAFF TO.
TRY AND REACH AN AGREEMENT
ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS THIS.
ISSUE AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
WE THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN HELPING TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WITH OUT LIMITING THE
ABILITY FOR CONSUMERS TO LEARN.
ABOUT DANGEROUS ARE DEFECTIVE
PROP UP PRODUCTS FOR
ADVERTISING.
SO THE BILL FOCUSES ON.
LEGAL ADVERTISING FOR LEGAL
SERVICES BECAUSE OF THE
CONTINUING EXPLOSION AND.
IN EXPENDITURES AND NUMBERS OF
COMMERCIALS THAT THE PUBLIC IS
BEING HIT WITH.
IT'S TRIPLED OVER THE LAST
DECADE ON AND THE LATEST
FIGURES.
INDICATE THAT.
ALMOST A BILLION DOLLARS WERE
SPENT ON ON ADVERTISING AND.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ON AND THERE IS NOW CONSIDERABLE
EVIDENCE THAT THE SHEER VOLUME
THE NATURE OF THE ADVERTISING
WHICH IS OFTEN DESIGNED. TO
SHOCK AND SCARE COMPETE.
CONSUMERS AND ACTION IS HAVING
AN IMPACT THAT GOES BEYOND.
JUST SIGNING UP THEM PEOPLE FOR
LAWSUITS.
WORK CONCERN BECAUSE THE ADS
INFLUENCE CONSUMERS BY.
UTILIZING SOME TACTICS THAT ARE
CONCERNING.
THEY.
FREQUENTLY ARE LABELED AS
MEDICAL OR HEALTH ALERTS THEY
INCORPORATE MEDICAL SYMBOLS THEY
USED THE TERM FTA. AND IN MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THE ADS OFTEN
WARNED THAT USE OF THE DRUG OR
DEVICE CAN RESULT IN DIRE
CONSEQUENCES.
HEART ATTACK STROKE BIRTH
DEFECTS WITHOUT ACTUALLY TALKING
ABOUT WHAT LEVEL OF RISK THAT
IS.
AND SO IN ADDITION TO THE.
NUMEROUS POLLS SURVEYS THAT
HAVE BEEN OUT THERE SHOWING THAT
THIS THAT THESE DO HAVE IMPACTS
ON THE FTA ITSELF.
TRACKS THESE CLAIMS.
AND IN ONE INSTANCE.
JUST LOOKING AT THE ONE DRUGS
ALTER THEIR ELDER IDENTIFY
THIRTY ONE CLAIMS WITH DOCTORS
AND PATIENTS WERE THEY THOUGHT
THAT THE. ON PERSON STOP TAKING
THEIR MEDICATION AFTER.
AFTER WATCHING ONE OF THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS AND HAD A SEVERE
INJURY OR DEATH AS A AS A
PROXIMATE CAUSE THEY'RE. ON IN A
SEPARATE.
INQUIRY LAUNCHED BY CONGRESS.
LOOKING AT A BROADER PERIOD
TIME THEY FOUND SIXTY ONE
DIFFERENT COMPLAINTS OF THE SAME
STE.
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH SIX
RESULTING DOUBTS
SO WHAT ON I JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT WHY EXISTING
LAW ON ISN'T ENOUGH TO HANDLE
THIS AND ONE OF THAT IS THE
NATURE OF PHARMACEUTICALS AND
MEDICAL DEVICES. ON MANY OF THEM
ALTHOUGH THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THAT IN A PERFECT WORLD WOULD
NEVER DO ANY HARM. ON A LOT OF
TIMES FOR DOCTORS AND PHYSICIANS
IT'S COMPETING BENEFITS VERSES
POTENTIAL HARMS.
ON AND SO IT IS TRUE THAT SOME
OF THESE MEDICAL DEVICES AND
PHARMACEUTICALS FAR SUIT
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS. ACTUALLY
SHOW THAT THERE IS POTENTIAL
HARM THAT COULD RESULT IN A
SMALL NUMBER OF CASES AND SO THE
ADS CAN BE FACTUALLY ACCURATE
ABOUT THOSE DANGERS BUT IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CONTEXT IN THE
BALANCE.
THAT'S A PROBLEM WE ALSO A
APPRECIATE THAT WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE RULES OF PROFESSIONAL
CONDUCT.
WE THINK THAT ANY EFFORTS TO
SORT OF EXPAND ON THE ETHICAL A
REGIME FOR ATTORNEYS IS GOOD ON
HOWEVER WE THE LIMITS ON THOSE
ARE ONE WHO THEY CAN APPLY TO.
ON THAT NEEDS TO BE.
ATTORNEYS FOR THOSE ASSOCIATED
WITH ATTORNEYS WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT MOST OF THE.
MOST OF THE INDEPENDENT AT
FIRMS WOULD QUALIFY UNDER THAT
AND ALSO THOSE ARE ALL FOCUSED
ON ON THE NATURE OF THE LEGAL
SERVICES SO. I'M FOR THOSE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US WE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WURSTER THOMPSON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION A WE ARE SUPPORT
THIS BILL PRIOR TO THE AMENDMENT
TO REMOVE THE OPPOSITION
CONSULTATION PIECE WE DO
BELIEVE.
THAT THAT CONSUMERS WHO DO STOP
TAKING THEIR MEDICATION OR
MEDICAL DEVICE AS A RESULT OF
THESE ADVERTISEMENT SHOULD
CONSULT A PHYSICIAN BEFORE DOING
SO.
THAT'S THAT STILL AMENDED WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS SENSIBLE
POLICY TO OF MAKE THESE ADS MORE
A FAIRLY BALANCED ENSURE A
PATIENT SAFETY SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EX WITNESS PLEASE.
THAT OUR ANNUAL.
GIVING A TALK A CONSUMER TWENTY
THE CALIFORNIA WE WERE OPPOSE
THE BILL AND PRINTS WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BALLOT
BUT THE AMENDED WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WORK IN THE
COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THERE REALLY IS NO INCENTIVE
FOR ATTORNEYS TO DO FALSE
ADVERTISEMENT THERE'S A LOT OF
RULES THAT WE ARE DISCUSSED
TODAY AT THE GOAL RULE STATUTES
THAT ARE IN PLACE TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. SO WE WILL REVIEW THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT THERE'S ANY
CONCERNS WE HOPE TO WORK THEM
OUT IN THE SENATE THANK YOU.
ACCUSE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SAY NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND THANK
YOU MISTER BERMAN FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS.
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE GOING
BEFORE WE AMENDED IT I DON'T
COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH THAT.
BUT IT'S UP TO IT'S A BIGGER
ISSUE ULTIMATELY AND SORT OF
FOCUSING ON THE ATTORNEYS WHO
ARE SUBJECT TO RULES DOCTORS WHO
ARE SUBJECT TO RULES THERE ARE
OTHER PLAYERS MAYBE WE NEED TO
GET THAT.
I GUESS I'M A LITTLE OLD CHOOL
WHEN IT COMES TO ATTORNEY
ADVERTISING AND.
DON'T LIKE THE PROLIFERATION
WITH THE WAY SOME OF IT GOES NOR
DO I LIKE WE HAVE A BIT OF A.
SOCIETY SUBJECT TO SOME
HYPOCHONDRIA AND SINGLE THE DRUG
ADS AND THAT MEDICAL DEVICE IT'S
DISPENSED THROUGH.
ADVERTISING MECHANISMS LEADS
OFTEN TO.
WRONG CONCLUSIONS BY CONSUMERS
WHO MAY STOP IN THIS CASE STOP
TAKING A MEDICATION THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T WITHOUT CONSULTING
THEIR DOCTOR OR WHO MAY DECIDE
THAT THEY NEED SOMETHING THAT
THEY REALLY DON'T.
THEY NEED TO CONSULT THEIR
DOCTOR SO IT'S.
WITH WE'RE JUST BOMBARDED WITH
ALL OF THIS ON KIND OF ALL SIDES
AND. GETTING OUR HANDS AROUND IT
IN THEIR PRODUCTIVE WAY.
WE GIVE SOMETHING THAT THAT WE
DEFINITION BE LOOKING AT AND AND
AND THIS IS A STEP AND ALSO
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THINK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT NEXT STEPS MIGHT BE AND AND
WHAT WE CAN INFER.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
TAKE ME AMENDMENTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
FOR MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
BUT WAS CUT OFF LETTER.
THE CHAIR VOICE MY CONCERNS I AM
IT WAS AMAZING TO ME TO HEAR.
THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE OUR THAT
SUPPORT I GUESS OF OF WHY WE
NEED THIS BILL BECAUSE. I'M YOU
COULD LISTEN TO THAT ENTIRE.
.
TESTIMONY AND IT COULD HAVE
APPLIED TO THE PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES THAT ARE ADVERTISING
THESE DRUGS.
AND SO I I FEEL CONFLICTED A
LITTLE IN THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW
WHERE WE'RE GOING AFTER ONE AND
WHICH MAY NEED SOME.
CHANGES.
BUT WE HAVE ACCEPTED AND STILL
ALLOW MASSIVE ADVERTISING BY
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES.
ON ON TELEVISION WHICH HAS LED
TO A LOT OF THESE ISSUES SO I
JUST WANTED TO KNOW I AM GOING
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY I'M
UNCOMFORTABLE.
.
TAKING ON ONE AND.
PORTION OF IT WITHOUT BEING ABLE
TAKE ON THE OTHER I WOULD PREFER
PROBABLY THAT NONE OF THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS ARE HUNT
TELEVISION.
.
NOW I CAN'T THAT FAR BUT I'M.
THE REBUILT MY BARCHART.
.
I'M JOKING I'VE BAD AYE I DO IT
I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY TELLING
AND SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE AWARE
OF THAT AT AS YOU TESTIFIED.
THE VERY SAME THINGS COULD BE
SAID OF ABOUT THE WHAT I FIND.
THE TRIGGERING OF
PHARMACEUTICAL COMMERCIALS THEY
GET PEOPLE.
ONTO THESE DRUGS IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
SO I YOU KNOW HOW MANY WE DON'T
HAVE THE STUDIES OF HOW MANY
PEOPLE STOP TAKING MEDICATION
THAT MAYBE THEY NEVER NEEDED TO
TAKE IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND
THAT WOULD BE A POSITIVE THING
SETTLED. THAT PROBABLY WOULD BE
A GOOD STUDY AS WELL THANK YOU
I'M GONNA MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION
IS OUR SECOND.
CUBA SCHOLAR.
YEAH I KNOW I SHARE SOME OF THE
HESITANCY AS WELL HOWEVER I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS
THAT I DO THINK THERE'S ABOUT A
CONVERSATION.
THAT IS NECESSARY ONE QUESTION
I HAD.
I'M REGARDING.
WHO THE BILL IS REALLY TARGETING
BECAUSE AS AS WE KNOW?
IS.
THE WITNESS TESTIFIED IN AN
OPPOSITION ARE CONCERNED
POSITION IS THAT I'M THERE ARE
SO MANY WARS HAS I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR KNOWS. BOB BEING ATTORNEY
AS WELL THAT THAT ALREADY GUIDE
TO ETHICS IN THE RULES AS TO
WHAT ATTORNEYS CAN DO INCLUDING
REGARDING ADVERTISING AND SO. I
IF YOU ARE A WITNESS CAN
ELABORATE LIES TO THE THE
TARGET.
OF THIS OF OTHER LEGISLATION.
VERIFY THAT BECAUSE
I THINK THAT.
REQUIRES LITTLE CLUE LITTLE
CLARITY CHIRP ABSOLUTELY.
SO IN TAKING A LOOK AT RULED
SEVEN POINT ONE WHICH ACTUALLY
GUIDES THIS. ON THE OVER RIDING
PRINCIPLE ABOUT THEM LEGAL
SERVICES ADVERTISING'S IS ABOUT
HOW YOU ARE MATERIALLY
REPRESENTING.
THE LEGAL SERVICES.
AND SO.
THE VERY FIRST LINE OF THAT IS
A LAWYER SHALL MAKE SHALL NOT
MAKE A FALSE OR MISLEADING
COMMUNICATION ABOUT THE LAWYER
OR THE LAWYER SERVICES.
AND SO.
THAT LEAVES OUT.
CLAIMS ABOUT DEVICES OR
PRODUCTS THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
DEFECTIVE.
AND SO THE CONCERN IS ON YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN YOU RUN
THROUGH ALL OF THOSE RULES THERE
ABOUT DON'T PROMISE A PARTICULAR
RESULTS FROM THE LAWSUIT. DON'T
PROMISE YOU CAN NEW YOU KNOW YOU
CAN SPEAK SPANISH WHEN YOU DON'T
SPEAK SPANISH DON'T YOU AND SO
THERE ARE A LOT. BUT YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T APPLY.
TO THE CLAIMS ABOUT PRODUCTS
AND THEY ALSO HAVE A LIMIT ON IN
TERMS OF HOW FAR THEY CAN REACH.
INTO.
.
PEOPLE THAT ARE LAWYERS
I'M AND SO THAT THETHE WAY THE
BILL AS DRAFTED IS ANYBODY WHO'S
DOING ADVERTISING FOR LEGAL
SERVICES REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
OR NOT THEY'RE A LAWYER.
AND AND THAT'S PART OF THE
REASON WHY IT'S BEING PLACED.
BUTTON OR UNDER THE CONSUMER.
LEGAL REMEDIES ACT AND NOT AND
NOT SPECIFIC IN. BUT I'M TO BE
JUST CONDUCT OF LAWYERS RIGHT.
AND I'M.
YEAH AND I THINK THAT.
I.
AGREE THAT THERE'S YOUR IN TERMS
OF FALSE OR MISLEADING
ADVERTISING I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE CAUTIOUS AS WELL. IN TERMS
OF.
THE.
IN OF THE OFTENTIMES WHEN
THERE'S. ABOUT LITIGATION AFTER
ISSUES THAT OCCUR THAT HAVE BEEN
FOUND. TO HAVE BEEN
SUBSTANTIATED AND LAWYERS ARE
REACHING OUT TO FIND OUT IF
PEOPLE ARE VICTIM OF THAT. THAT.
THERE'S OTHERS ALSO UP ON.
A PUBLIC GOOD IN AND THE ABILITY
BILL TO DO THAT AS WELL AND SO I
A.
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN FROM THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS AGO THAT THIS
REALLY DOES COME DOWN TO THE
DETAILS. OF EXACTLY HOW IT'S
AMENDED AND HOW.
YOU KNOW THAT MUCH ABOUT THE
FINAL TEXT IS IN SO. I'M I WILL
CERTAINLY BE INTERESTED IN IN
SEEING THAT WERE CONTINUE I KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN CONVERSATIONS
FROM. THE SPONSORS AS WELL I'M.
AS THE AUTHOR AND I KNOW THAT
THE CHAIR HAS BEEN HELPFUL IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT.
I THINK THAT THIS IS DEATHLY
ONE OF THOSE PILLSBURY REALLY IS
IN THE FINE PRINT. IT AS TO BUT
THE FINAL PRODUCT WILL LOOK LIKE
BECAUSE I I JUST I STILL HAVE
THAT WORRY THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
GO TOO FAR.
I THINK THERE'S IS A VALUE TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO MARKET
OPTICALLY.
SUBSEQUENT
TWO A A PRODUCT WOULD HAVE YOU
BEING FOUND HAVE SOME ISSUES.
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO. LET THE
WORLD KNOW AND AND TELEVISION OR
OTHER ADVERTISING.
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT IS HOW
WE GET THAT WORD OUT THERE AND
SO. THAT AS WE PUT PARAMETERS
ARE JUST TO BE CAUTIOUS AS TO
NOT OVERREACH. AND I KNOW THAT
THAT'S BEEN ABOVE MUCH OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT'S BEEN
OCCURRING.
NIBBLED THE. AS THIS BILL HAS
MOVED FORMER SOME OF THE
AMENDMENT SO THAT. DOES MY
COMMENTS ON IT I THINK IT
PROJECT THANK YOU GIVE THIS RACE
IN THE MIST MAIENSCHEIN.
I DO WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY.
COLLEAGUES COULD DO HAVE STATE
PARK CARDS.
.
THE CONVERSATION THOUGH WITH
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
ORGANIZATION THAT BEST
REPRESENTS.
THE PROTECTIONS OF THE CONSUMERS
AND THE ATTORNEYS WHO REPRESENT
THEM SO I DON'T CORD YOU TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THEIR RESPONSE
WANT ONCE THEY HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
PROPOSED.
THANK YOU.
SO I TRIED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT JUST A
COUPLE OF REALLY BRIEF POINTS.
I THINK THIS THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT'S GETTING OUT WHETHER
WHERE WE KNOW.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF ABUSES.
SORT OF IT ANECDOTALLY AND
OTHERWISE.
AND AND BUT MOST MORE THAN WHAT
I WANNA SAM LIKE TO CREDIT THE
AUTHOR AND PEOPLE SEE AROUND THE
TABLE IT'S GREAT TO SEE THIS
COALITION WORKING TOGETHER.
AND SO I THINK GOING FORWARD
HOPEFULLY.
THAT WILL LEAD TO TO MORE.
YOU KNOW PRODUCTIVE LEGISLATION
IN GETTING OUT AND SOLVING A LOT
OF THESE PROBLEMS SO KUDOS TO
ALL OF YOU GUYS FOR WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
AND IN FOR MEMBERS TO RAISE
CONCERNS IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT THIS IS NARROWLY TAILORED
SO WE HAVE A CHANCE TO KIND OF
THINK IT THROUGH. UNDERSTAND
IMPLICATIONS IS ADVERTISING
LEGAL ADVERTISING AT ITS BEST IS
GETTING INFORMATION LEGITIMATE
INFORMATION OUT TO CONCERNED
CONSUMERS.
IN WAYS THAT THEY NEEDED AND
THEY CAN BENEFIT FROM IT AND BUT
THERE DOES SEEM TO BE POOR
PROLIFERATION OF POTENTIALLY OR
SOMETHING IS NOT NECESSARILY THE
LEGAL ADVERTISING BUT KEPT AS
LEGAL ADVERTISING.
AND THAT'S MISLEADING WITH AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS ABOUT SORT OF THE THE
FLIP SIDE WERE FLOODING THE
AIRWAVES. AND IN CREATING
PERCEPTIONS OF NEED THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE THERE SO IT IT'S.
.
IT'S A COMPLEX VERY MODERN.
ISSUE FOR US.
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CENA MISTER BERMAN YOU MAKEUP
JUST I REALLY WANT THINK THE
CHAIR AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD.
AND YOU KNOW WORKING WITH FOLKS
FROM ALL SIDES OF THIS ISSUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE NARROWLY
TAILOR SOMETHING.
THAT PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BUT THAT
ISN'T OVERLY ONEROUS.
ON THE LEGAL SECTOR IN THEIR
ABILITY TO IT TO YOU TO REACH
OUT TO FOLKS WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN
HARMED. A WHICH IS THE BALANCE
THAT WE'RE STRIVING FOR SO.
WOULD RESPECT ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED KALRA PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
JOE I CHIU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY MISS CERVANTES ITEM NUMBER
FOUR A. B. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE.
MISTER MISTER KILEY.
SOMALIA MISTER KILEY ON NIGHT OF
FOURTEEN A. B.. THIRTY TWO
SEVENTEENTH OUTSIDE.
WAS FUND IS WELCOME THAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DIED TODAY I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE. AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
WITH MORE TIME TO IMPLEMENT THE
TRANSITION TO DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS. THE ENACTMENT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SET UP THE
CURRENT SYSTEM WHICH GOVERNS
THESE TRANSITIONS. HOWEVER SINCE
AB THREE FIFTY BOTH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS HELP THEM FOUND
THAT MORE TIME IS OFTEN NEEDED
TO IMPLEMENT THESE TRANSITIONS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEED MORE TIME
TO DO PUBLIC OUTREACH AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS OFTEN NEED
MORE TIME TO HELP UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES ORGANIZE
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO ADVOCATE
FOR THEIR INTEREST.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE WOULD HELP ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BY PROVIDING FOR A
MUTUALLY AGREED UPON EXTENSION
OF NINETY DAYS TO IMPLEMENT THE
TRANSITION TO DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS. DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD POTENTIAL PLAINTIFFS
WOULD BE.
REMAINED BARRED FROM COMMENCING
LITIGATION AGAINST A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UNDER THE CBR A.
JUST AS THEY ARE UNDER THE
EXISTING SYSTEM UNDER AB THREE
FIFTY I WANT TO KNOW THAT THIS
IS A CONSENSUS BILL THAT IS
SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES. AS WELL AS MALL DEATH
ACL YOU COMMON CAUSE ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE WE
HAVE HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL DANE HUTCHINGS ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
AS WELL AS NICHOLAS. HIGH DORAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMING
BECAUSE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE.
CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLAS ITEM WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THE
TRANSITION.
FROM AN AT LARGE ELECTION
SYSTEM TO BUY DISTRICT ELECTION
SYSTEM SORT OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGES IN LOCAL CHURCH. LOCAL
DEMOCRACY THE JURISDICTION OF
WILL EXPERIENCE IT'S IMPORTANT
REMEMBER THAT THE REASON FOR
THAT TRANSITION UNDER THE CVR ES
STRENG PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES TO
ELECT CANDIDATES THAT REPRESENT
THAT COMMUNITY. THAT'S WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT THOSE UNDER
REPRESENT COMMUNITIES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A VOICE IN
THE PROCESS OF CREATING THOSE
INAUGURAL DISTRICTS.
AS THE MEMBERS MENTION WHAT WE
FOUND THOSE IN MANY CASES IT CAN
BE DIFFICULT TO WITHIN ONLY
NINETY DAYS TO BE ABLE TO
MOBILIZE AYE COMMUNITIES EDUCATE
THEM ABOUT WHAT DISTRICTING
DOES.
IMPORTANCE AND TO GET THEM
INVOLVED IN THOSE HEARINGS SO WE
THINK THIS ADDITIONAL TIME
EXTENSION OR PROP SEEMING TO BE
A A SIMPLE CHANGES ACTUALLY ONE
OF PROFOUND IMPORTANCE THAT WILL
REALLY IMPROVE THAT PROCESS. BY
ALLOWING MORE PEOPLE TO BE PART
OF THIS.
INITIAL DISTRICTING AND TO
FURTHER IMPROVE REPRESENTATION
HAS THAT TRANSITION BECAUSE FOR
SO THAT REASON WERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT ONE THINK THE OFF FOR
BRING IT. AS WELL AS THE VOTED
CLOBBER IT MORE QUICKLY CITIES
ON THAT'S
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN RETAIN
HUTCHINGS DELETED CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
AGAIN ALLY MY COMMENTS WITH.
MIKE A COLLEAGUE FROM COMMON
CAUSE.
AS THE AUTHOR NOTED TWENTY ONE
TWENTY THREE TO SIMPLE EXPANSION
OF AB THREE FIFTY WHICH WAS A
LEAK SPONSORED MEASURE THAT
PROVIDED NO TO SECURE PROVISION.
FOR CITIES OR CONVERTING
DISTRICT BASS ELECTIONS.
WHILE THE LEAD STILL CONTENDS
THAT DISTRICT BASS ELECTIONS ARE
NECESSARY TO BE A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH.
IT IS THE LAW OF THE LAND AND
SO WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE
LAWOF THE LAND WE ARE TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT. I WE HAVE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION.
AND ALLOW FOR THE MOST.
DELIBERATE PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT WE
THINK THIS IS A BILL MISSED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION A HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT FOR
YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
LIZ IF YOU CAN WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GENETIC MACLEAN'S OUT ATTORNEY
WITH MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL
DEFENSE AND EDUCATIONAL FUND
ALSO A. STRONG SUPPORT.
THEIR ARE A DELUDE GIVES WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION.
WOULD LIKE TO LIVE MY COMES
WITH THAT OF THE LEAGUE AND
SCORED BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
THING NOT BRING IT BACK
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU.
MOST IN THIS TO PASS.
CERVANTES MIKLOS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RACE AYE REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK POLITICS.
MS RAFE'S.
THIS RATES ARE YOU.
ARE YOU ABLE TO PRESENT YOU
WILL.
OKAY SO WE'LL GO TO ITEM.
NUMBER ELEVEN AB THREE ZERO ONE
NINE
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB
THREE ZERO ONE NINE. WHICH IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND SMALL.
TECHNICAL BILL THAT REQUIRES ON
THOSE ISN'T HOME HAVE POSITIONS
TO BE TWELVE POINT FONT FOR EASE
OF READABILITY.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
THAT PARTIES DESIRING TO TAKE
GIRL DEPOSITIONS FROM ANY PERSON
TO GIVEN WRITTEN NOTICE OF THE
DEPOSITION TO THAT PERSON.
SIMPLY INSURES THAT THE NOTICE
IS.
AND AT LEAST TWELVE POINT FONT
IN ORDER TO BE READABLE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU COULD COULD.
YOU TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OUTSIDE PLEASE
OR YOU A QUIETER THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU. I DON'T IT SUPPORTS.
ALRIGHT SINGLENESS ANY
OPPOSITION.
SINGER A BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THE THREATS HE MAKE LOVE.
EXPECT FULLY ESRI I. THANK YOU
MOSHE'S DO PASS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM
CHAU.
CHAO AYE CHIU. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
CONSULT FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES AYE REYES
AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER MAYOR
TO CHI.
DO YOU HAVE TO ITEMS WITH THIS
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY ONE AND AND NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT.
THANK GOODNESS CHAIR.
MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
LIKE TO.
THANK THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR A WORKING.
WHICH IF WE ITEM OF THIS IS WHAT
I'D LIKE TO TAKE UP THE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY ONE OKAY THAT IS
OUR NUMBER TWO THANK YOU OKAY.
I LIKE THINK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME AND MY STAFF ON THIS BILL AND
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT. ALL THE
AMENDMENTS LAID OUT IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
AB SEVEN SIXTY ONE THE HOTEL
HOUSEKEEPER PROTECTION ACT
PROTECTS.
HOTEL EMPLOYEES FROM SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT FROM
HOTEL GUESTS.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THEY MEET
TO MOVEMENT LEADS TO SAFER
WORKPLACES FOR ALL WOMEN.
INCLUDING HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS.
ATTACK HOUSEKEEPERS ARE AMONG
THE. MOST VULNERABLE OF WORKING
WOMEN TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND MANY ARE WORKING CLASS
IMMIGRANTS WORKING ALONE IN
HOTEL ROOMS.
OFTEN WITH MALE GAS PLACE IN
THEM AT PARTICULAR RISK
HEIGHTENED RISK OF ASSAULT. OR
HARASSMENT
ACCORDING A SURVEY OF CHICAGO
AREA HOUSEKEEPERS FIFTY EIGHT
PERCENT. OF THE HOUSEKEEPERS.
INDICATED THEY HAD BEEN
SEXUALLY HARASSED BY A GUEST.
AND FORTY NINE PERCENT HAVE SAID
THAT THEY HAVE HAD IN THEIR
EXPERIENCE I GUESS ANSWER THE
DOOR NAKED EXPOSING HIMSELF FOR
FLASHING THEM.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY ONE PROPOSES
SOME COMMON SENSE PROTECTIONS
FOR THESE WORKING WOMEN.
BY PROVIDING A PANIC BUTTON TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES IN ORDER TO
SUMMON. ASSISTANCE AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION.
THE WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING GOT.
SEVERAL OTHER.
COMMONSENSE PROTECTIONS HAVE
FOR THESE WORKING WOMEN.
AS OUTLINED.
AND AS WE HAVE ACCEPTED IN THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
I M..
.
PROUD TO PRESENT A PHOBIA OF
DISSENTING A HOTEL WORKER WHO IS
HERE IT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
OKAY WHETHER THEY AFFECT THOUGH
OF LOS HE NOBODY'S FABULOUSLY
THIN THING.
ON SENATE COMMITTEE COME IN AND
THEY WANT THE DEPTHS OF THE
COUNTY FOR MIA. ME END THAT MIA
BUT I NEEDED TO YOU KNOW IF THEY
LOOK A LONG THING.
IF ANYTHING THEY PASSED OUT ON
WITH THE THING BECAUSE SO.
THE WAR IN NOTABLE YOUR THAT
THEN THERE ARE THOSE.
OTHER THAN THAT THEY'RE SOMEHOW
ORDER.
BUT EQUALITY THAT KAMEL.
GLOBAL KINNAIRD FROM BEIT OWNER
FEEDING FUEL.
BEGINNER'S. LUCK REALLY THOUGHT
THAT I NUMBERED ALL.
COOPER IS ANOTHER LINE.
MY NAME IS FABULOUS BE SENT DAY
I'M A HOUSEKEEPER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND A MEMBER OF
UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN.
THIS PAST DECEMBER MY UNION WAS
PROUD TO HAVE TO OF OUR WORKERS
HONORED AS THE SILENCE BREAKERS
THAT TIME MAGAZINE NAMED PERSON
OF THE YEAR.
I DO NOT US FILM FOR THE.
BUT REQUIRED.
BUT YEAH THERE THEN LEVEL HERE
IS REPEAT ALREADY LANDFILLS.
THAT A HOLLOW ENOUGH
THEY WERE FAIRLY.
THERE'S A REASON THAT SEVERAL OF
THE SILENCE BREAKERS WERE HOTEL
WORKERS.
NINE DO IS TEAR OPEN IT UP FOR
THIS SAID NGUYEN WETA MORALLY
BETTER GET ALSO BUT ACTED LEVEL
CRITICS. THAT ARE NOT
PARTICULARLY GOOD AT THAT I
THINK.
THE AUTO INDUSTRY CAN BE A
DANGEROUS PLACE FOR WOMEN TO
WORK.
IRV IS IT WILL NOT BECOME ADDED
I MEAN THAT I WILL NOT BECAUSE
HE'LL FINALLY BE ADELINE.
EVERY TIME THAT A HOTEL WORKER
ENTERS A ROOM TO CLEAN IT.
NO STUDY KIM FOR THE D. I
THOUGHT I THE INFERTILE. SHE
DOESN'T KNOW WHO COULD BE
INSIDE.
S. PERSONA ES UNA THING ONE OF
THE TESTS YOU DON'T OWN UP BUT
SON MAKES THE ONION.
BEING IN A ROOM ALONE A COMPLETE
STRANGER IDEA KIKWIT GET BUT
THOUGHT I THINK THE ERA.
AND GO MORE THAN.
CAN MAKE ANYBODY FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE.
FEDERAL WHEN THE FAMINE THAT ALL
OF THAT LEFT BOTH OF.
OR EVEN IF GAY CARELESS PAPA
THOUGHTS COMPANION OATH.
BUT WHEN YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
TERRIBLE THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED YOUR FRIENDS OR CO
WORKERS.
OR IS THE US BUT FELLOW I I
WOULDN'T I WILL MEAN MORE PLAY
THIS THERE. QUE.
KENNEDY AT THE HEART OF SIERRA.
AND WHAT THAT A VOTE
FOR YOU'VE EXPERIENCED SOMETHING
YOURSELF.
THE WORKPLACE CAN BE A VERY
SCARY PLACE.
I MEAN I CAN'T LAW IT WOULD HAVE
BROKEN THE SECOND PLUS KO AT THE
NEEDLE MOVIE FACELESS.
I'D TWO EXAMPLES THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT.
LIQUID LOW WHEN I WITH YOU GET
THE US AND IN THE END IT THEN IN
THERE ARE ALL.
I I REMEMBER.
I GUESS THAT I WAS EXITING FROM.
THE THE WASHROOM.
IT THEN YES SUPPORT OF WHAT THE
LEFT IN A FIELD IN LAGOS AND IF
I'M OUT OF SPELLS THAT PHONE
THEM.
THE HOTELS THEY HAVE VERY LONG
HALLWAYS AND I'M I WAS NEAR. THE
REAR.
IT OTHER NICHOLAS SUCH ANNOY
CHAINLINK WANTING IT BY FEEL YET
MAYBE GO THROUGH IVF DELUDE YEAH
BUT I THOUGHT I JUST. GAVE OTHER
HOW UP WITHOUT BE ANYTHING BUT A
HUMAN WITH YEAH.
DE GASTOS FOR TOWELS ON THAT
THEY BE DELIVERED TO HIS ROOM IT
WAS ABOUT EIGHT O'CLOCK AT NIGHT
AND HE SAID THAT HE WOULD LEAVE
HIS DOOR OPEN AND THAT HE COULD
DELIVER THEM TO THE ROOM.
YOU'RE CONFIGURING AIRPORT GALA
EVENT OFF BY AN HOUR LIMIT THE
POOR KIDS WITHOUT A WHOLE
SELLOFF WE OTHER HOW THE ECONOMY
AND MAYBE HOPE OPINION UP BUT
IBM.
HE'S I IT WAS MY JOB SO I
OBVIOUSLY DELIVERED THE TOWELS
AND VERY FRIENDLY.
.
I TRUSTED HIM I.
BETTER YET SYMBOLIC OKAY ACOSTA
AYE I THINK MAYBE HOPE IN THE
DATA LOVE IN A JOINT THEIR
PARKING UP WITHOUT IVF THAT.
WHEN THEY GO INTO THAT A IF
THINGS GOT THIS STUFF UP THEN
YEAH AT THAT POINT THAT.
NAY WHEN I A I WHEN I ARRIVE
STEM I KNOCKED ON THE DOOR.
AND THE GENTLEMAN ASKED ME TO
ENTER THE ROOM.
.
SO I ENTERED BY AND.
HE WAS.
IN A ROW.
IT CUANDO YOUR AESTHETIC AMITY
HAWKINS THAT YOUR INVESTMENT
GALLAGHER LOST Y. F. CUANDO YA
THOUGHT THAT PROBABLY IN STICKY
BUT I LOVE AKA. THE MICKEY SOME
OF IT OUT ON THAT I'M THOUGH
EUNOMIA WONDERING IF THE MOMENT
TO SEE THAT PETER JUST BY US
BOTH A LOT THEY CAN OMIT BUT ARE
YOU MISS THEM TO COURT IN THE
PARKING AT STEM A FELLOW IT
UNLAWFUL CHULANONT CHECK.
WHEN I ENTERED THE ROOM.
HE ASKED ME DID I COME GIVE HIM
THE TOWEL SAM AND AS SOON AS I
BROUGHT THEM CLOSE TO HIM HE
TOOK OFF IS A RELEVANT HE WAS.
COMPLETELY NAKED.
AND I WAS VERY SCARED.
IT WAS EIGHT O'CLOCK AT NIGHT.
AND.
.
IT DOESN'T BOTHER YOU ONLY A
LIAM AT THAT MINUTE WE THOUGHT I
HOPE WORKING AT THE NEW YORK AT
THAT NOT I LOVE KNOWING THAT I'M
NOT YOU. WONDER GO AHEAD LIT IT
MADE THE COMMENT THAT ARE LOST
BUT OF THE SODA.
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES WHO DON'T HAVE
A.
I I LAUGHED.
AND WHEN I REPORTED THIS. BY
THE TIME THAT I REPORTED IT TO
MY SUPERVISOR AT NINE O'CLOCK.
THAT THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING.
OUT OF.
BUT I IS THAT THE ENVELOPE IN
THE EMERALD LEVEL KNOWN OUR
YOUNG NOT I'M NOT IN THE EMBASSY
AND YOU GOT THE NORTH IN THE I'M
OF NOT A. LAW MUST KNOW MUST
THROW MONEY BUT FOUND THAT BUT I
THINK IT WILL NOT THAT MUNICIPAL
ABOUT HOW YOU LOOK AND IF I SAW
ONE OF. OUR YOUNG KNOWN NOR LOOK
IT WILL NOT BY FINALS BUT THE
FUNNY ON THE ONLY THING THAT IF.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
FOR ARE SUPERVISORS IS THAT WE
COMPLETE OUR WORK.
NOT WHAT HAPPENS IN THE HOTEL
ROOMS OUT WHAT HAPPENS DURING
OUR JOB THAT DOWN THAT WE GET
THE JOB DONE.
A CIRCUIT MITHRAIC GET KILLED I
WANT WITH THE WOULD TO GIVE THAT
A GUY YOU HAVE UNTIL WE SEE IT
OR NOT OF NOISE FEDERAL NOT FOR
ME.
THEY THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING FOR
ME THEY CAN SPEAK OUT FOR ME.
.
CUANDO GOT THE NEW YORK AT THAT
I HAVE ENOUGH THAT A JOKE IN THE
CALL IF ALL QUE UP FOR THE UC
LUCK ON THE BILL CALLING UP WENT
THAT'S IT CAVEAT TO ALLOW
COMMITTEE ON OUR. GEORGE GOMEZ
AND YEAH STOP WORKING WITH CUT
OUT BUT I GUESS GET THEM YET
THAT COME TO YOUR PLACE OF WORK
IN A HOSPITAL MEETING OKAY THE
CARE THEY OUT THAT ODIE SAGA.
I ALWAYS FEEL SCARED NOW WHEN I
GO TO AND HER ROOM FOR TURNDOWN
SERVICE OR TO BRING SOMEONE
WATER AND BECAUSE OF MY.
PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE.
.
AND.
THINK BOTH OF KNOW NO MORE THE
OWN OPINION WAS WITHIN THE COP
ON LOBBY AMONG ANOTHER ONE THAT
THE POTOMAC TO MAKE OUT ONE
THAT.
BIDDLE GET I THINK HAVING A
SAUDI DEL YET THEN ALMOST A
MONTH ANOTHER MOVE ON THOUGHT
THAT THEY THEN MOVED TO THINK
THE GOT THE. YET THEY GO WILL
NOT RULE OUT ONE UP FOR YOU CAN
THAT INSPIRED THE.
BEFORE WE GET I DID NOT HAVE.
A UNION I DIDN'T HAVE ANYONE TO
BACK ME UP.
NOW I DO AND I HAVE THE SUPPORT
AND.
I AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
OKAY LET HIM ON A BUS UP THE WAY
I WILL I WILL SEE ME NOT THEM
JOINT THAT GET IT FOR A LIVING
WHAT THE LAW. IS STATE ONE THE
GOVERNMENT THAT IT HAS GOT THE
STOMACH VULNERABLE TO THOU YOU
MET AT THE. FOOT THE BILL
DOESN'T METHODICAL.
I WANTED TO CLEAN THE ROOM IN
THE ROOM WAS COMPLETE MASS.
BUT I WENT IN ANYWAY I'M TO DO
MY JOB.
THE IDEA OF ME OKAY THIS THOUGHT
OF THEN THE HELL YOU KNOW YOU
WITH ALL OF THE OTHER YOU MAY
PUTS OUT OF IT BUT MONDAY BY BUT
THAT. ONE FOR ME THOUGHT BUT IF
SECOND NOT AND WILL NOT A LOT OF
THAT ON TOBACCO THAT I THOUGHT
THE NEW THE WOUND WITH A FIX A
LOT OF.
ONE I A I ENTERED THE ROOM.
A WAS SAYING WHAT A MASS AND
LOOKING AROUND THE ROOM.
AND DIE AS
I ON ONE OF THE SHELVES.
THERE WAS.
I.
SEX TOY.
A MASON THINK DON MODERN AND
VEHICLE MEAL PAID ONLY A QUARTER
THE COMPANY OKAY I'M OUTTA
ONLINE ON. THE TO BE SOUGHT LA
I'M ATV QUE. QUE YOU ARE AT THE
BOTTOM ONLY RUNTHE PEPPER
COMMISSION PMR BENEFIT BUT IN
LEGAL I MEAN WITHIN THE AMONG
THEM WITHIN THE UP KALRA.
A STE TOLD MY SUPERVISOR THAT I
DON'T WANT TO CLEAN THE ROOM
BECAUSE I DIDN'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE THEM AND THEIR.
IT WITH WITH THIS OUT.
ELABORATE COLLABORATIVE GOON
QUAN BETTER TO PUT DEL WHAT ARE
YOU IN THE THING WILL ME ALONE
AT THAT WOULD THE SCENE BECAUSE
I THOUGHT THERE MEDI FATHER. NO
POINT ALL I WANT THAT MICHAEL
MOORE LEVEES PATHETIC AND WE
THEATER WHEN I I WOULD ONLY
BECAUSE YOUR THUMB IN YOUR
SUPPORT THEM NOT THAT ARE GOING
TO PUT THAT YOU MISSED HITTING
QUAN MONEY VITUS Y. E.. IMAGO SW
WILL NOT OR LEAVE IT.
NOW I I FEEL COMFORTABLE
SPEAKING OUT I HAVE A MY THE
UNION TO.
HELP SUPPORT ME.
AND.
WHEN I FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE IN A
SITUATION IN A HOTEL ROOM I FEEL
COMFORTABLE SPEAKING OUT TO MY
SUPERVISORS.
AND I I KNOW THAT THEY WILL.
HAVE MY BACK.
I'LL IT UP WHEN I WHEN I GOT THE
ONE THEY THOUGHT ON IT UP
LOOKING THE ANIMALS THE CUP OF
THE AT THE NAME ON THE BOYS YEAH
YET THAT IT WILL SIMPLY NOT THE.
WITHIN BILL PULLMAN AND IF YOU
DON'T KNOW A A FICKLE MONOPOLY
MEN OF ESTIMATE BY SOAKING UP
THE CAL ONE THOUGHT YOU KNOW NO
NOISE HERE WILL NOT PORTANTINO
ANYTHING BUT THOUGHT UP YOU'LL.
BE UP ON THE STOMACH AND A
HONDA.
NOW.
I FEEL COMFORTABLE I FEEL LIKE
I HAVE A VOICE.
BECAUSE OF ITS SUPPORT FROM A
UNION AT THE I I DO NEED YOU TO
HURT US SO WELL.
WHILE I LAY THERE AND THEY THEN
WALKED HOME THAT FUNNY BECAUSE I
THINK BUT FOUND THAT BUT I'M A
FULL TO US. FOR GOOD.
THEN WHEN I MET KEN THUMB ALSO
LESSEN OF WHAT THE THING I FEEL.
FOR THEM WAS A BELIEF THAT IF A
BY THAT BUT I BUT I'M WITH THAT
BOOK THAT YOU SEE ALL.
THIS IS WHY THE PANIC BUTTON IS
SO IMPORTANT ON BECAUSE IN THESE
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS WE HAVE
SOMETHING.
TO PROTECT OURSELVES I THINK
BUT WHICH I THINK DONT ABOUT GAY
I A BATTLE BATTLE MANY SOULS
BANG THAT THOSE PEOPLE IF THEY
TO SOMEONE NOT. NOTHING WENT
THERE WE'RE GOING A POSSE ALSO
LEAD TO AND WE SAW AN OLDER HOLD
ELECTED EMPATHY OF MOVIES
FLORAL.
MATHIS.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS CAITLYN
BAKER FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE ARE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND LISTENING TO FIVE
LS SPEAK IT MAKES ME FEEL SO
PROUD TO REPRESENT THE LABOR
MOVEMENT AND THINK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE THAT IT MAKES IN SO
MANY WORKERS LIVE. UNFORTUNATELY
MANY WORKERS DO NOT HAVE THAT
PROTECTION AND ON THEY ARE
LITERALLY FORCED TO CONFRONT
THESE KINDS OF SITUATIONS AND
KNOWING THEY HAVE TO DO THEIR
JOB OR THEY WILL BE FIRED THEY
CAN'T SIMPLY LEAVE THE ROOM.
THEY CAN'T SIMPLY REFUSE TO
CLEAN THE ROOM I'M AND I I THINK
THAT THESE VERY COURAGEOUS HOUSE
KEEPERS HAVE REALLY HELPED TO
FUEL THIS MOVEMENT AND TO SAY.
THAT AND THE FIGHT FOR SAFE
WORKPLACES AB FOR FAIR TREATMENT
FOR WOMEN AND FOR RESPECT ON THE
JOB I'M GOES BEYOND A HOLLYWOOD
GOES BEYOND REALLY ANY
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY. AND IS MOST
IMPORTANT FOR SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS ONE THING
THAT PEOPLE OFTEN DON'T REALIZE
ABOUT HOTELS. IS HOW OFTEN
HOTELS THESE DAYS I'M CONTRACT
OUT THE WORK OF HOUSEKEEPING
EITHER THROUGH TEMP AGENCIES OR
OTHER LABOR CONTRACTORS WHICH
MAKES THESE PROBLEMS EVEN HARDER
TO ADDRESS. BECAUSE IT GIVES THE
AYE THE COMPANY RUNNING THE
HOTEL AND A LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE THEY THEY
CAN SAY ALL THAT'S UP TO THE
CONTRACTOR TO DEAL WITH THEIR
NOT MY EMPLOYEES IT'S NOT MY JOB
TO PROTECT THEM.
THAT MAKES THESE PROTECTIONS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND STRENGTHENING THIS
BILL. ON ONE COMMENT I WOULD
MAKE THEIR IT IS AN ISSUE AROUND
A EMPLOYERS CALLING LAW
ENFORCEMENT DIRECTLY WITHOUT THE
CONSENT OF THE WORKER AND. WE
ARE FINE TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I WOULD JUST FLAG
THAT IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
OBSTACLES FOR WOMEN IN THIS
INDUSTRY AND FOR SO MANY
IMMIGRANT WOMEN WORKERS. I'M IS
THAT THE FEAR OF POLICE BEING
INVOLVED IF IT'S A DETERRENT
FROM REPORTING THESE KINDS OF
ABUSES SO WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE TO REFINE THAT
LANGUAGE AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT. CREATING ANY
DISINCENTIVES OFFER WORKERS TO
COME FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GIVEN OTHER LESS.
THAT THAT ALRIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
SITTING ATTACK OUR CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS THE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
I GIVE.
ONE OF THE S. WE'LL UNLESS. EAT
YOU UP LOYALIST SUPPORT AT THAT
MEANS I HEALTH KEEPING IT UP AS
A SURVEYS GET ONE BUT HE IS ALSO
WAS HOLES LEFT BY IN LESS ANNA.
WAS MONDAY IF SOME ASSEMBLY AND.
IS IT IS IT GONNA LOOK DOES NOT
THE NAME ON THE MOON BY LAW AND
THEN OBVIOUS ELEMENT THAT.
LITTLE FELLA WHO ORGANISE US AND
I KNOW THE MIDDLE YOU KNOW
SCHOOLS BUT.
THIS IS THE THAT WAS A BOY.
BREAKING OUR THE CALIFORNIA PLAN
MILLERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CAN YOU GIVE US THAT.
TRANSLATION.
BRIEFLY PLEASE.
MY NAME IS YOLANDA ABOUT ON.
I AM.
HOTEL I'D ADD WHO MADE AND AND
IT'S AYE AYE.
WE NEED ON SUPPORT FROM AYE OUR
COMPANIES THEY DON'T GIVE A
SUPPORT CURRENTLY.
AYE AND.
.
THERE AYE WE NEED A VOICE.
AND.
THIS BILL WELL WILL GIVE US A
VICE BANK AND PROTECTION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M JOHN
CALDWELL REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE UP THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE THOROUGH AND
FAIR ANALYSIS OF THE BILL.
SPECIALLY THE PROBLEMS RAISED BY
THE BLACK LIST PROVISIONS.
WE THINK THE AUTHOR LOVE
REMOVING THAT PROVISION.
OUR MEMBERS ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF REVIEWING THE EXTENT OF
AMENDMENTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING IT IN PRINT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
TO RAISE ANY ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
I HOPE MARTY FISHER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I ECHO THE SAME REMARKS
OF MY COLLEAGUE. A WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AND
THE AUTHOR TAKEN THEM.
WE STILL NEED TO REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS ONCE OR IN PRINT AND
REVIEW WITH OUR MEMBERS AND SEE.
HOW IT IMPACTS OUR OUR CONCERNS
OF FOR CONSISTENCY WITH OTHER
OTHER REQUIREMENTS REGARDING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND?
ASSAULT VICTIMS.
ALONG WITH OUR WE STILL HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT THE EXPANSION OF
THE PAID LEAVE REQUIREMENT
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
OTHER PAID LEAVE REQUIREMENTS.
AND LEAVE OTHER LEAVE
REQUIREMENTS.
SO THIS TIME WE STILL REMAIN
OPPOSED BUT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
REVIEW THE LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS VERY BRIEFLY MIKE
FOLLOWED ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LODGING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WHERE AN INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OF SMALL LODGING
PROPERTIES OF FROM ONE TO IT.
PERHAPS A FIFTY ROOMS
A USUALLY INDEPENDENTLY OWNED.
WE OBVIOUSLY WE SHARE.
THE STATEMENTS MADE IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT THE BILL IS
DIFFICULT TO OPPOSE
CONCEPTUALLY.
ABOUT THE DETAILS IT'S ABOUT HOW
IT MAY APPLY TO SMALL LODGING
PROPERTIES WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE BUT WE
WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE AND EVERYONE
SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE. YOU ALL BUT
SOME YEARS AGO MADE IT VERY
CLEAR UNDER THE LAW THAT IF A
CUSTOMER IS HARASSING AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE BUSINESS WHETHER
LODGING OR LOBBYING OR ANYTHING
ELSE.
THE EMPLOYER HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE
REASONABLE STEPS TO STOP IT.
SO WE ALREADY TAKE A VERY
SERIOUSLY THE POSSIBILITY OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OF EMPLOYEES
IN THESE LODGING PROPERTIES
BECAUSE THAT OBLIGATION EXISTS
NOW REGARDLESS OF WHERE THE YOUR
HOTEL OR A RESTAURANT OR A. OR
ANY OTHER BUSINESS
SO WE'D LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SEEING HOW
IT APPLIES TO SMALL BUSINESSES.
SMALL PROPERTIES AND SEE WHAT WE
CAN WORK OUT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE THANK YOU
SHAUN LOSE THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO AT THIS
TIME STILL OPPOSE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHECK TWENTY
MEMBERS MICHELLE RESTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
WHICH YOUR ARE REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
THINKING.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
I THINK NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
CONSULT LECTURE.
OBVIOUSLY IT MOVE THE BELL.
JUST ONE REMIND YOU WANNA BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR YES.
WOULD GIVE A MOTION AS THEIR
SECOND AND A SECOND THANK YOU I
DO WANT TO.
NO AND I UNDERSTAND IT IT'S.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER TO THIS
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT TAKING THE
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD FORCE ON
THE EMPLOYEE TO INTERACT WITH
THE PLEASE.
SO I HOPE AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THIS WE CAN FIND SOME SORT OF
SITUATION I UNDERSTAND ON A
VIOLENT CRIME MAYBE THAT MIGHT
BE NECESSARY BUT.
.
IT IT IT'S COMPLICATED RIGHT I
MEAN WE DO WANT THIS TAKING CARE
BUT WE WANT TO PROTECT.
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE GONNA.
VERY.
UNIQUE SITUATION IN THIS
INDUSTRY LARGELY IMMIGRANTS.
THAT MAY DETER THEIR ACTUAL.
.
TELLING THEIR EMPLOYER TO DEAL
WITH A SITUATION IF IT COULD BE
DEALT WITH WITHOUT POLICE
INTERVENTION SAU I I JUST I
DON'T KNOW I I DON'T I FEEL BAD
BRINGING IT UP BECAUSE THEY MUST
FEEL LIKE.
PROBLEM ON BOTH SIDES WE ALSO
WOULDN'T WANT.
.
I WEHAVE LAWS TO PROTECT
EMPLOYEES NOW AGAINST US BUT WE
WENT WILL IT WOULDN'T WANT AN
EMPLOYER COLLEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS A MECHANISM TO. HARM EMPLOYEE
I'M NOT SITUATION SO WITH
EMPLACED ALL COULD COME BACK.
AND SO I'M SURE YOU WILL. DEAL
WITH KIND OF TRYING TO FIGURE
THAT POINT OUT I JUST WANT THINK
THAT REAL EFFORT SPEAKING.
BEAUTIFULLY ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCE IT'S A HARD THING TO
COME UP AND TALK ABOUT. AND.
.
SHE DID A GREAT JOB IN DOING SO
AND I KNOW SHE CAN UNDERSTAND
LISA.
THANK YOU MISSOURI.
I TO WANT TO THANK OF YOUR
LUGGAGE IS BUT I THAT OF ANY OF
THE OTHERS AT THE STEAM ON YOU
IS MORE IMPORTANT THOUGH EVEN IF
THAT. GUY WITH THE LLAMAS
IMPORTANT THE BUT AGAIN FINA IS
AGAINST IT ITSELF THAT I CAN GET
THE MOST BUT THE HIT CHINA I.
THEN THE OTHER I THINK IS MISTER
BILL OATES THAT.
THAT THE LAWS ARE ALREADY THERE
THE EMPLOYER HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO.
TAKE CARE OF A COMPLAINT WHEN IT
DOES LAUNCHED BY AN EMPLOYEE BUT
IT'S CLEAR FROM STORIES LIKE OF
YOUR LIFE AND YOUR LAND THE.
THAT THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN AND IT
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING MORE
THAT'S DONE TO PROTECT.
THESE EMPLOYEES I I DO THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
IT.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENCEMENT COMMITTEE.
SINGER THIS EMERGENCY MAKE
CLOTHES THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WOULD LIKE TO. ACKNOWLEDGE.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER WHOSE.
VERY.
IMPORTANT AND AN APPROPRIATE
COMMENTS I ALSO RECOGNIZED IT'S
IN IT'S A SALTY. A PROPOSED
COMMITTEE.
.
AMENDMENTS THE OF POTENTIAL
ISSUE.
.
OF.
WORKERS BEING RELUCTANT TO BUT
TO REPORT AND SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS HER.
OF ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS.
AND.
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE I RESPECT
LAST FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU AND.
FIVE SO I'M GONNA BREAK MY RULE
BECAUSE THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE THE
LAST WORD BUT I APPRECIATE THAT
AND AND THE GOAL WAS NOT.
TO CREATE A HARMFUL SITUATION
FOR THE EMPLOYEE WITH THE
SPECTRE OF ICE WITH THE ALL OF
THAT AS ONCE WE IF WE EVER GET
BEYOND IT. WE CAN DO A BETTER
JOB OF PROTECTING EMPLOYEES.
WE DO HAVE ISSUES OF.
BIAS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AS WELL
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE IS WORKING
ON.
IN THE PERFECT WORLD.
SHOULD BE A SUPPORTIVE SITUATION
WE DO NEED TO BE SENSITIVE TO TO
ADDRESS AND THAT'S MISTER
RICHARD I I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERN.
HAVING SPIDER THAT ISSUE AND
WERE ACTUALLY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU I THINK I AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON.
THANK.
THANK YOU SO.
TALK ABOUT.
BUT WE DO OF THE MOTION SECONDED
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED.
KALRA PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CHAO.
CHAU I CHU GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN. RACE.
REYES I.
NEEDS TO MORE FOR THE LONG HAUL.
SO NOW WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT
SOMERS ITCHY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I'VE
MOVING ONTO A AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT THIS BILL. PROPOSES
TO STRENGTHEN.
THE PENALTIES
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
ARE BY FACILITIES LIKE
REFINERIES THAT HANDLE HIGHLY
TOXIC AND FLAMMABLE CHEMICALS.
TO PREVENT ACCIDENTS THAT MY
POST SERIOUS RISKS
TO THE PUBLIC AND TO THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AS THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS THE
CERTIFIED UNIFIED PROGRAM
AGENCIES.
OR COOPER.
OVERSEAS CALIFORNIA'S ACCIDENT
RELEASE PREVENTION PROGRAM OR
CAL ARE.
TO PREVENT THE RELEASE OF
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS FROM.
THESE TYPE OF.
.
FACTORIES MANUFACTURES
REFINERIES FACILITIES THAT DEAL
WITH A HIGHLY TOXIC AND
FLAMMABLE MATERIAL.
SUCH AS THIS CHEVRON.
RICHMOND REFINERY OR THE
TORRANCE REFINERY IN MY OWN
DISTRICT.
THE COOP WAS ENSURE THAT THESE
FACILITIES ARE ACCOUNTABLE AT
THE SAFETY OF THE WORKERS AS
WELL AS THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES.
A TO ANTICIPATE PROBLEMS AND
PREVENT ACCIDENTS THAT MIGHT
MIGHT POSE SERIOUS RISKS
TO THE PUBLIC AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE CURRENT LAW ARE ONLY ALLOWS
A MAXIMUM DAILY PENALTY OF TWO
THOUSAND PER VIOLATION PER DAY
WHICH IS NOT AN ADEQUATE
DETERRENT FOR VIOLATIONS. THIS
BILL PROPOSES TO INCREASE THE
DAILY PENALTY FOR CALABRO GRANT
VIOLATIONS FROM TWO THOUSAND
FIVE THOUSAND. PER VIOLATION PER
DAY.
ALSO THIS BILL SEEKS TO UPDATE
THE STANDARD FOR THE MAXIMUM
CIVIL OR ADMINISTRATIVE
LIABILITY COUNTY. TO WHEN A
FACILITY KNOWINGLY.
VIOLATES OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
THAT THEY WERE VIOLATING CAL ARE
VIOLATIONS.
AND FINALLY THIS BILL ELITES.
THE REASON OR NOTICE
REQUIREMENT.
OF THE VIOLATION BEFORE FACILITY
CAN ASSESS THE MAXIMUM DAILY
PENALTY OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND.
A YEAR EXCELLENT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS HIGHLIGHTS THE REAL.
.
HURDLES THAT THIS A REASONABLE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT HAS.
POSE
TO.
ASSESSING.
THIS MAXIMUM PENALTY IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE THE ULTIMATE EFFECT
OF.
A SAFER COMMUNITIES.
FOR FOR US ALL.
THIS BILL. WILL CREATE A
GREATER DETERRENT EFFECT ON
THESE FACILITIES TO PREVENT
SERIOUS VIOLATIONS
PROTECT THE WORKERS IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. OF
COMPROMISE WITH THE OPPOSITION
REGARDING MOST OF THEIR
AMENDMENTS BUT.
WITH.
CONTINUE TO.
.
ASSERT THE NEED FOR OF THE
STANDARD OF WHEN THE MAXIMUM
PENALTY CAN BE APPLIED. A TWO OF
THIS KNOWING OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN STANDARD. GA WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS JUST IN
MILAN ON BEHALF OF THE COOPERS
WHO ARE SPONSORING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FIRST WHAT MONNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MOVE
ON BEHALF OF THE COOPERS.
THIS BILL REALLY IS OVER DO YOU
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH HIM FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE PROGRAM IS THE
FIRST TIME.
THIS PENALTY HAS BEEN UPDATED
AYE YOU MAY RECORD I DON'T IF
CAME TO COMMITTEE BUT. THERE WAS
A BILL LOST HERE THAT I PAID AT
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE. A LOW'S AND
THE PENALTIES TO SEVENTY
THOUSAND.
SO THIS IS TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
THIS IS ABOUT A THIRD OF THAT.
I'M I ALSO WANT TO STRESS THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS THAT THE INDUSTRY
REQUESTED AND HE SEEMS TO BE
THAT THEY STUCK ON THIS ISSUE AN
OPPOSING THIS WHOLE BILL.
BECAUSE HAVE ONE ISSUE AND THAT
IS.
IT SEEMS UNREASONABLE FOR
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO HAVE TO
GIVE NOTICE.
PRIOR TO IMPOSING A FINE AND
PENALTY.
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD A SITUATION
APRAXIA NOT TO MENTION THE
REFINERIES WE'VE HAD SOME
SERIOUS EXPLOSIONS ACCIDENTS
FIRES.
BUT PRAXAIR AND HER ANHYDROUS
AMMONIA WAS RELEASED THREE
TIMES.
AND THE CURRENT GLOBAL
REQUIRES US TO GIVE NOTICE
BEFORE WE CAN ISSUE THAT FINAL
PENALTY SYDNEY THAT THE MAXIMUM
FINE AND PENALTY.
SO THAT'S RATHER ASININE REALLY
DO THINK ANY ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
HAS ITS HANDS TIED BEHIND ITS
BACK AND GO TO RADIO WAITS UNTIL
THERE'S A SERIOUS VIOLATION.
UNTIL WE CAN TAKE THIS
ENFORCEABLE WOULDA.
THE OTHER THING THAT TIME THE
INDUSTRY IS OPPOSED TO DESPITE
HAVING TAKEN PRETTY MUCH ALL THE
OTHER AMENDMENTS.
IS THERE SAYING THAT THE
STANDARD IS CHANGED.
WHAT WE A CERTAIN I THINK THE
AUTHORS COMPLETELY CORRECT?
IF YOU HAVE DRAFTED A RISK
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
YOU SHOULD KNOW WHAT'S IN THAT
RISK MANAGEMENT PLAN AND IF YOU
THEN BEHIND BEHIND THE FACT THAT
YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT IT
HAPPENED.
AND YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT FINE AND PENALTY
I ISSUED EVEN IF IT WAS A
SERIOUS VIOLATION THAT ALSO
SEEMS A LITTLE ASININE.
IF YOU HAVE A RISK MANAGEMENT
PLAN YOU SHOULD KNOW WHAT'S IN
THE PLAN. YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT
YOU VIOLATE THAT THE PLAN AND
SHOULD SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES
SO WE CERTAINLY DON'T BY.
THIS ARGUMENT FROM THE INDUSTRY.
TO TRY AND REDUCE ITS FINDS DOWN
TO FIVE FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
DAY. THAT'S A PITTANCE FOR
SOMETHING AS LARGE AS A REFINERY
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT A
DETERRENT. AND UNFORTUNATELY OUR
PRINCIPAL WITNESS YEAH THE LA
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT WAS
UNABLE TO MAKE IT APPEAR THAT
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED TORRANCE
FIRE.
THEY ALSO HAVE EXPENSIVE IN
RICHMOND AND THEY KNOW THAT
THESE INCIDENTS.
SEE IT SERIOUSLY JEOPARDIZE THE
COMMUNITY IN THE WORKERS AND WE
THINK THIS IS A VERY VERY SMALL
UPGRADE.
I FIND THAT'S NECESSARY TO ACT
AS THE PARENT BEFORE NOT OFTEN.
INCIDENTS ARISE
THANK YOU.
THERE OPPOSITE.
AS HAVING LIVED IN LOS ANGELES
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND SEEN A
NUMBER OF TIMES.
WITH TORRANCE INDEED THE
SITUATION
REALIZE THAT TIME FOR BOTH A.
SHALL WE SAY CHEVRON UNDERGOES A
CONDO AND DOWN THERE IN THE
TORRANCE AREA THAT. ENFORCEMENT
IS SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT AND
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY DO NOT TAKE
IT SERIOUSLY SORRY GUYS.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
EIGHT CALMLY WITH LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT SAY NONE OPPOSITION.
I'M GENE URBAN I REPRESENT
ENDEAVOR.
.
AT THE OUTSET I WON A CONTEST
THE MISREPRESENTATION OF OUR
POSITION BY THE PROPONENT OF THE
BILL.
I GUESS OUR POSITION IS EITHER
ASININE OR LITTLE ASININE
DEPENDING ON HIS
MISREPRESENTATION OF OUR
POSITION.
WE OBJECT TO THE CONFLATION OF
INTENTIONAL MISCONDUCT WITH
NEGLIGENCE
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A RADICAL
POSITION.
THAT SHOULD BE WELL UNDERSTOOD
BY MEMBERSHIP JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
TYPICALLY INTENTIONAL
MISCONDUCT.
PUNISHED MORE SEVERELY THAN
NEGLIGENCE.
WHAT WE OFFER?
WAS TO INCREASE THE PENALTY FROM
TWO THOUSAND TO FIVE.
SUBDIVISION AT.
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY PERCENT
INCREASE.
WE OFFER TO DELETE.
PREVIOUS NOTICE REQUIREMENT.
UNLIKE AS REPRESENTED BY MISTER
MALIGN WE OFFER TO DELETE IT.
IN SUBDIVISION BE SO THAT
THEY'VE KNOWING VIOLATION WOULD
NOT HAVE TO HAVE A.
SHE DIDN'T NOTICE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CONTEST MY
CLAIM IS A CONTEST NOTICE.
KNOWING VIOLATIONS ON THE BASIS
OF A RECEIPT OF THE NOTICE.
IF WE VIOLATED KNOWINGLY WE
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
HER DAY.
HOWEVER WE STRENUOUSLY OBJECT
TO THE CONFLATION OF NEGLIGENCE
AND INTENTIONAL MISCONDUCT UNDER
A SINGLE PENALTY OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND.
I ALSO ASK
WHAT IS A COVER.
IF IF BE COVERS TWENTY FIVE
INTENTIONALLY NEGLIGENCE
ARE YOU NOW IMPOSING STRICT
LIABILITY ON US.
INCREASING IT FROM TWO TO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY IS THAT
WHAT.
IT'S BEING PROPOSED STRICT
LIABILITY.
AT FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
DAY.
FOR WHAT COULD BE HUNDREDS OF
PAGES OF DOCUMENTS IN A PLAN
THAT THAT'S NOT GOOD POLICY.
IT AND IT'S NOT IT IT IT'S NOT
NECESSARY WE LAST YEAR WE
SUPPORTED INCREASES AND AND THE
PENALTIES AND EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY.
THERE ARE.
TONS OF PENALTIES TO WHICH WE
ARE SUBJECT IF IN FACT THERE IS
A SERIOUS INCIDENT WE ARE ALSO
UNDER THE TERMS OF THIS BILL
LIABLE FOR ACTUAL RESPONSE COST.
IN ADDITION TO ALL THE OTHER
COMMON LAW TOWARD SH
TOWARDS FOR WHICH WE WOULD HAVE
LIABILITY.
OUR OFFER REMAINS
THE AUTHOR SHOULD KNOW THAT WE
WOULD INCREASE THE EXISTING
PENALTY IN SUBDIVISION A. FROM
TWO TO FIVE THOUSAND.
WE WOULD AGREED TO DELETE THE
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS AND
SUBDIVISION DE WHILE PRESERVING
THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
PENALTY FOR A KNOWING VIOLATION.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE'VE
ASKED.
TO BE ADDRESSED AND HAS NOT YET
BEEN ADDRESSED AS TO WHICH
CONDUCT IS NEWS INCREASE
PENALTIES APPLY.
SHOULD APPLY TO CONDUCT THAT
OCCURS HONOR AFTER THE FIRST OF
THE YEAR IT SHOULD BE
PROSPECTIVE
THAT ISSUE HAS NOT BEEN
ADDRESSED.
OUR POSITION IS EMINENTLY
REASONABLE AND.
I RESENT
THE MISS
THE DISTORTION OF IT.
AND WE ASK THAT WHAT WE OFFER
YOU BEFORE SIR YOU ACCEPT.
AND
I TRUST THAT COMMITTEE RATHER
THAN THE I'M SOFTER HIM SORRY WE
WE WE WOULD REQUEST THAT THE.
AMENDMENTS THAT WE OFFERED THE
AUTHOR THE ACCEPTED I CAN REPEAT
THEM AGAIN THEY'RE VERY FAIR IT
WAS. CHARACTERIZED BY MISTER
QUIRK IN THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE
IS A CHINA HAS TO OFFER.
WE WOULD INCREASE THE ABILITY
NEED YOU TO WRAP UP.
WE WOULD INCREASE A FROM TWO TO
FIVE.
WE WOULD DELETE THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT AB AND WE WOULD ASK
FOR CLARITY ON TO WHICH
CONDUCTIVITY NEW PENALTIES.
TAX.
THANK THANK YOU.
I'M.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKET PARKS WITH THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION.
.
WITHOUT REPEATING WHAT MR URBAN
IS THAT WE BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
OFFERED I'M. A REASONABLE
COMPROMISE.
WAS OUR SUGGESTION TO INCREASE
THE PENALTIES FROM TWO TO FIVE
AND AND COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THE DESIRE TO. ATTRACT THE
NOTICE PROVISION WE THINK THAT
THAT'S FAIR AND WORK I'M VERY
WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT AND.
AND MR IRVINE'S POINT AND THINK
IT IS FAIR TO RETAIN NOT KNOWING
PROVISION AND THE WAY THAT WE
LOOK AT THIS. I'M CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES A TWO PART TEST THERE
MUST BE A NOTICE AND THE.
THE VIOLATION MUST BE FOUND TO
HAVE BEEN A KNOWING VIOLATION
SO WHAT WE PROPOSE IS A
REDUCTION OF A TWO PART TEST ONE
PART TEST.
AND AGAIN INCREASE A PENALTY
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS FAIR I'M AND
WE THINK THAT WITH THIS KNOWN I
SHOULD HAVE NO LANGUAGE WE
REALLY ARE CONFLATING. AND.
VIOLATIONS THAT ARE SERIOUS AND
VIOLATIONS WHICH ARE NOT.
AND SO WE WOULD.
UNFORTUNATELY ASKING YOUR
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL ON.
AND WHAT ENCOURAGE SOME SOME
FURTHER THOUGHT ON.
I MAINTAINING THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THESE TWO TYPES OF
VIOLATIONS.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ADAM LIKELY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ALSO REMAIN IN OPPOSITION.
JOHN KEPT HIM BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE AND CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION BOTH OPPOSED FOR THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
TOM JACOB ON BEHALF OF THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNSEL OF
CALIFORNIA OF THOSE FOR THE
REASONS ARGUE.
P. MONTGOMERY ON BEHALF OF THE
CIVIL JUSTICE CESSATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
IT'S NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IT'S CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU.
SOME. ARE OF ANY PROBLEM WITH
CHANGING THE FINE AMOUNT.
.
BY VIRTUE OF.
INFLATION IF NOTHING ELSE
IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A DETERRENT
EFFECT.
FINES HAVE TO BE INCREASED OVER
TIME IN SOME FASHION I DO HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH THE STANDARD.
AND THE CONFLATION AS IT'S BEEN
PUT.
OF THE STANDARD BECAUSE IT DOES
OCCUR TO ME THAT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY
OR WHATEVER NOT.
SUPER INTERESTED IN THAT BUT.
IN TERMS OF A FINAL WORK PRODUCT
I MEAN IT IS FAIRLY STANDARD IN
LAW TO HAVE.
ONE SET OF FINES FOR.
AND NEGLIGENCE TYPE ACTIVITY OR
WHERE THERE'S PROOF THAT
SOMEBODY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN ABOUT
A PROBLEM THEY WERE NEGLIGENT
NOT KNOWING.
AND ANOTHER HIGHER STANDARD.
IN MORE SEVERE PENALTY.
WHEN A CAN BE PROVEN THAT
SOMETHING WAS DONE WITH INTENT.
THIS BILL AS I UNDERSTAND IN
ITS PRESENT FORM WOULD.
CONFLATE THOSE TO STANDARDS AND
I GUESS MY QUESTION TO.
OF THE AUTHOR THE WITNESS ABOUT
IS WHAT IS WHAT IS THE RATIONALE
FOR DOING THAT IT DOES SEEM TO
BE A VERY COMMON.
DISTINCTION AND IN THE LAW ONE
THAT I THINK DOES HAVE SOME
POLICY.
RATIONALE BEHIND IT.
IN THAT YOUR SOCKING PEOPLE WITH
A BIGGER FINE IF THEY.
SCREWED UP AND KNEW ABOUT IT.
.
AND THEY DID SO WITH SENT WITH
SOME INTENT AND IN THIS INSTANCE
I THINK THE. MATH TURNS OUT TO
BE LIKE FIVE TIMES THE AMOUNT
FINANCES SIGNIFICANT THAT'S MORE
THAN TRIPLE DAMAGES PERCIVAL.
FOR INSTANCE SO WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE FOR.
HAVING THAT STANDARD BE THE
SAME.
SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM AS.
FORMER ATTORNEYS.
I THINK WE BOTH SHARE. BUT IN
APPRECIATION FOR DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF OF PENALTIES FOR A
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF A.
OF ARE CULPABILITY.
.
THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS.
AS.
OUTLINED AND THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WHERE WE'RE
GIVEN THE AND PARTICULARLY.
THIS IS SERIOUS AND SIGNIFICANT
TELL A POTENTIAL HARM THAT
CONNECTS THAT CAN.
.
NOT OCCUR. NO AT REFINERIES AND
AND AT OTHER STATIONARY
FACILITIES AT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT IS THE REASON WHY WE ARE
PROPOSING. A TO GO BEYOND JUST
THE KNOWING VIOLATION BUT ALSO
THE CONSTRUCTIVE.
.
KNOWLEDGE THEY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
ASPECT OF IT IF.
IF A SUPERMARKET IS GOING TO BE
HELD LIABLE.
FOR THE MILK SPILLED ON THEIR
FLOOR WHERE THEY SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN NOT JUST THAT THEY KNEW
THAT THE MILK WAS THERE BUT THEY
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THE MILK
WAS THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE.
CONDUCTED THAT DUE DILIGENCE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDING A SAFE FACILITY.
THEN WHY NOT REFINERIES
WHY NOT BUT MANUFACTURES IT
HANDLED THE MOST TOXIC
CHEMICALS.
THAT IS THE POINT WE NEED TO.
YOU KNOW WEIGHT WHEN YOU'RE
REPRESENTING GOT A A COMMUNITY
LIKE I'M REPRESENTING WHERE YOU
HAVE COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE.
LIVING IN FEAR OF THE RELEASE
OF POTENTIALLY TOXIC AND LETHAL
CHEMICALS.
WELL OR WHEN WHEN YOU KNOW AS WE
SOUGHT IN THE RICHMOND FACILITY
IN AS DESCRIBED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
YOU KNOW.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT.
THAT TO THE COOPER AS HAVE THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO ENFORCE UPON
THE REFINERIES.
TO NOT JUST
OF PROTECT AGAINST KNOWING
VIOLATIONS BUT THEN TO IMPOSE
THIS.
DUTY THAT THEY SHOULD KNOW AND
THAT THEY SHOULD CONDUCT THE
INSPECTIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THEIR SAFE FACILITIES
AND THAT IS THE POINT OF.
THE THE EXPANSION OF THE STATE.
I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER IT DOES
RAISE THE QUESTION THOUGH THAN.
THEN.
UNDER IT UNDER THIS BILL.
WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD?
FALL UNDER THE SECOND PART FOR
THE FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR LOWER
AMOUNT AND IT'S.
I'M STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S.
WHAT?
PART B. THEN WOULD ENTAIL IRWIN
FACTUALLY THAT WOULD ARISE.
MISTER CHAIR THROUGH YOU MISTER
KENNY.
WE WE CONCEDE THAT WE HAVEN'T
ADDRESSED THE PROSPECT OF VERSES
RETROSPECTIVE ISSUE YET AND WE
DO INTEND TO DO THAT IT'S NOT AS
THOUGH WE AREN'T GRAPPLING WITH
THAT ISSUE.
WE ALSO HAVE ADDRESSED THE ISSUE
OF TO THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY
BORDERS ARE. RELATIVELY PAPER
VIOLATION IS VERSES A SERIOUS
VIOLATION.
BUT I THINK THAT THE OPPOSITION
IS CONFLATING.
THIS ISSUE ABOUT KNOWING OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN WE NOT SAYING
ITS INTENT.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT STANDARD.
WE'RE NOT SAYING THESE FOLKS ARE
INTENDING TO DO THIS.
WE JUST SAYING IF YOU HAVE.
PAID A RISK MANAGEMENT PLAN.
AND YOUR IMPLEMENTING THAT RISK
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
AND SOMETHING GOES WRONG.
YOU EITHER NEW OR YOU SHOULD
HAVE NOT WE NOT EVEN SAYING YOU
KNEW.
BUT YOU SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
AND IT IS A QUESTION OF DUE
DILIGENCE.
WE CANNOT GO OFF TO THE FACT
ONCE THE INCIDENT HAS OCCURRED
ONCE THE FIRE HAS OCCURRED AND
THEN IMPOSE A FINE AND PENALTY.
OR LIKE IN THE CASE OF PRAXAIR
RACK UP THE FREE VIOLATIONS
BEFORE WE CAN STEP IN ND
INDUSTRY HAS CONCEDED TO THAT
POINT. THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
ISSUE NOTICE.
ARE INTENT IS AN ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY
IT'S TO EXPECT THOSE PEOPLE IF
THEY ARE WRITING A RISK
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
TO KNOW WHAT'S IN THE PLAN
AND TO EXERCISE THE DO JUST
DILIGENCE
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
INTENTIONALLY LIVING HERE A
VALVE LEAK.
WAYNE PINCH ME OPENING SOMETHING
SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT THAT THE
DISTINCTION IS FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE DON'T THINK THAT
KNOWN OR SHOULD KNOW. IS SUCH A
BIG STEP IF YOU ARE OBLIGATED TO
WRITE THIS PAN AND FOLLOW IT.
CAN I JUST BRIEFLY ASK THE
OPPOSITION WITNESS TO ADDRESS
THE THAT WE DO HAVE YOUR SPONSOR
WHAT HE JUST SAID.
WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING THERE'S NO
LIABILITY FOR NEGLIGENT CONDUCT
WE HAD KNOWLEDGE THAT WE'RE
SIMPLY SAYING THAT THERE SHOULD
BE A DIFFERENCE.
IN THE PENALTY FOR NEGLIGENT AND
INTENTIONAL MISCONDUCT.
AGAIN NOT A RADICAL IDEA.
.
THAT THAT'S ALL WE'RE
SUGGESTING.
WE WE OBJECT TO THE.
EQUAL TREATMENT OF NEGLIGENT.
MISCONDUCT AND INTENTIONAL
MISCONDUCT IF WE PER PARA PLAYER
AND AND VIOLATED OF COURSE WE
HAVE SOME LIABILITY.
THAT'S THE LOWER STANDARD.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S UNUSUAL FOR
SOMEONE TO COME UP HERE AND IT
JACKED TO CONFLATING INTENTIONAL
AND NEGLIGENT MISCONDUCT THEY'RE
NOT THE SAME THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
THE SAME FOR TWO HUNDRED YEARS
WE WOULD SUGGEST A DIFFERENT
PENALTY SHOULD ATTACH. WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR IMMUNITY.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR SHOULD BE
LIABILITY FOR NEGLIGENT BEHAVIOR
BUT NOT THE SAME PENALTY AS
INTENTIONAL MISCONDUCT. PICTURE.
YEAH I IF I MAY I GUESS OR TWO
IF I GREW WITH MISTER URBAN
THERE THERE SHOULD BE DIFFERENT
PENALTIES FOR. NEGLIGENT VERSES
INTENTIONAL CONDUCT AND I.
WILL COMMIT MYSELF TO WORKING
WITH MR URBAN.
TO MAKE THAT DISTINCTION MORE
CLEAR THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
STILL LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON
THIS BILL.
SO THERE'S A MOTION. AND A
SECOND THANK YOU IT SOUNDS LIKE
THERE'S.
GROUNDS FOR COMING TOGETHER ALSO
SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
EMOTION GOING ON HERE. I WOULD
SUGGEST WE RATCHET DOWN THE
MOTION.
AND GET TO THE USE BE. BECAUSE
THERE'S OF.
THERE'S A POTENTIAL.
COMMON GROUND THAT I SEE.
FROM MY STANDPOINT.
THIS BILL IS WORTHY OF MOVING
FORWARD. SEEMS LIKE YOU HAVE
DOES WORK TO DO AND AND THAT IS
FINE.
AT THIS POINT IN THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
EACH OTHER QUESTIONS.
WRITING NONE WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MISTER WHERE TUTSI
MICHAEL THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD THAT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I.
THANK YOU MOTION ISSUE PASS.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU.
CHAU I CHIU. GONZALEZ FLETCHER
CONSULTS WATCHER I HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
PRESS.
REYES I.
IT'S TWO MORE VOTES WILL PUT UP
A LOT CALL ACCURATE.
MS RUBIO THAT TAKES US TO ITEM
NUMBER NINE A. B..
TWENTY SIX FORTY SEVEN
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX FORTY SEVEN. A BILL THAT
WOULD MAKE EVIDENCE OF AN
EMPLOYEE'S CRIMINAL HISTORY
INADMISSIBLE AGAINST AN EMPLOYER
IN A NAKED NEGLIGENT HIRING
LAWSUIT BASED ON THE CONDUCT OF
THE EMPLOYEE.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PUBLIC SAFETY
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA'S HELPING OUR EX
OFFENDERS POT ARE EX OFFENDER
POPULATION ACHIEVE SUCCESS. I'M
SORRY AXES TO GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT.
LAST YEAR I SUPPORTED.
THE US AND THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO
ZERO EIGHT EFFECTIVELY KNOWN AS
THE BAND BOX BILL. THIS BILL WAS
PASSED WITH THE INTENT OF GIVING
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND INCREASED ACCESS
TO EMPLOYMENT.
CONSISTENT WITH THIS ATTEMPT AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY SEVEN WILL
FURTHER INCENTIVIZE COMPANIES TO
HIRE PEOPLE WITH COMMENCEMENT
CONVICTION HISTORIES BY
PROVIDING LEGAL PROTECTIONS TO
EMPLOYERS. AND POTENTIAL
NEGLIGENT HIRING CIVIL CASES.
IN ESSENCE MY BILL HERE TODAY
WILL ESTABLISHED THAT AN
EMPLOYER WILL NOT BE DEEMED
NEGLIGENT WHEN HIRING AN
APPLICANT WITH A CRIMINAL RECORD
IF THERE IS NO RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN THE NATURE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS PREVIOUS CRIMINAL
RECORD AND THE NATURE OF THE
POSITION FOR WHICH THEY ARE
HIRED.
THIS PROTECTION FROM CIVIL
LITIGATION MINIMIZES THE
POTENTIAL FINANCIAL FALLOUT
FIRST
SMALL COMPANIES WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN EXPANDING THEIR
TALENT POOL BY HIRING PEOPLE
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS.
IN ADDITION TO PROTECTING
SMALLER COMPANIES FROM THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF FACING A
NEGLIGENT HIRING LAWSUIT. AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN WILL
ALSO BENEFIT LARGER COMPANIES
THAT ALREADY HAVE ESTABLISHED
FAIR CHANCE HIRING PRACTICES
THROUGH INDICTMENT
INDEMNIFICATION FROM NEGLIGENT
HIRING LAWSUITS BASED ON
CRIMINAL RECORDS.
FURTHERMORE.
UP AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
PROVIDES A POSITIVE INCENTIVE
FOR BUSINESSES AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
TO ADHERE TO ESTABLISH LAW.
AND UPHOLDS MODEL FAIR CHANCE
HIRING PRACTICES THAT ALL
BUSINESSES SHOULD STRIVE TO
INCORPORATE IN THEIR HIRING
PROCESSES.
WITH ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I HAVE LARRY TOM THOMSON
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
THANK YOU.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE GOOD
MORNING.
AND THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I MY NAME IS LARRY THOMPSON I'M
WITH THE LA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND.
WE SUPPORT SOME SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED BUSINESSES AND THE LOS
ANGELES REGION.
WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REELS.
RUBIO'S HAIR INTRODUCTION AND WE
ARE AND.
PORT AND SPONSORS OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
.
STATE THAT OUR INTENT RELATIVE
TO.
TEN OVERWEIGHT IS TO FURTHER
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THAT
LEGISLATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT.
THIS LEGISLATION THAT WERE
SPONSORING IS
IN CONCERT.
AS WELL AS COMPLIMENTARY TO THAT
LEGISLATION.
ORGANIZATION.
THE CHAMBER AS SUPPORTER PROP
FORTY SEVEN.
WE WOULD THE LARGE'S BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION SUPPORT THAT
LEGISLATION WE SUPPORTED PROP
FIFTY SEVEN AS WELL.
OF COURSE WAS SUPPORTING HERE
TODAY.
AND AND AND WE'VE GOT IT A
CHALLENGE IN TERMS OF HIRING THE
ET DE FORECAST FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS SAYS THAT CLEAR THE
CALIFORNIA.
WELL HIGHER OVER SIX.
HOUSE HAS GIVEN ME SIX MILLION
EMPLOYEES OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
VERY VERY AGGRESSIVE OUTLOOK
VERY AGGRESSIVE TARGET.
AND FOR BUSINESSES TO MEET THAT
DEMAND.
SO WE SUGGEST THAT.
WE GET NOMINAL NOMINAL MEASURE
OF PROTECTION
BUT IN THE HIRING PROCESS TO
COMPLETE THAT GOAL AND
OBJECTIVE.
SO.
.
IN CLOSING I SWEAR THANK YOU
FOR.
CONSIDERING THIS MEASURE.
WE AGAIN.
I BELIEVE THAT.
RELATIVE TO TEN OH EIGHT.
WE'RE NOT UNDERMINING THAT
LEGISLATION IN ANY WAY IN FACT
WERE SUPPORTED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
.
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BYERS MURRAY
QUE S. HARLOT THAT CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
HERE RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF ORGANIZATIONS I'M
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY SEVEN. INCLUDING THE LEAD
ADVOCATES OF AB TEN AWAY FROM
JUST LAST YEAR SO FIRST I JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT. A. B.
TENDO IT HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS
NOW FOR JUST FOUR WHOLE MONTHS
SO WE THINK IT'S A LITTLE
PREMATURE TO BE. WORKING ON.
FOLLOW UP MEASURES TO THIS
HISTORIC VICTORY THAT WE HAD
JUST LAST YEAR TO HELP REDUCE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT FOR
PEOPLE WITH RECORDS.
.
AB TEN KNOWING IT WAS A BILL
AGAIN PASSED LAST YEAR THAT.
PROHIBITS EMPLOYERS FROM
ACQUIRING INTO CONVICTION
HISTORY UNTIL AFTER A
CONDITIONAL OFFERS MADE.
AT THAT POINT THE EMPLOYER CAN.
ASK ABOUT CONVICTION HISTORY BUT
IS REQUIRED TO DO AN
INDIVIDUALIZED ASSESSMENT UNDER
A BE TEND A WAIT THERE'S A LIST
OF FACTORS THAT THE EMPLOYER IS
REQUIRED TO CONSIDER. IN
DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT TO HIRE
THAT PERSON.
SO I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THE. THE THE CHAMBERS
LETTERS STATES THAT AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY SEVEN HELPS EMPLOYERS
MINIMIZE THEIR EXPOSURE TO RISK
GOING CONSIDERING APPLICANTS WHO
HAVE CRIMINAL RECORDS. BY
LEGALLY ESTABLISHING CLEARING
CONCRETE PRACTICES A BUSINESS
CAN FOLLOW TO AVOID ENOUGH
BUDGET HIRING SU. BASED ON
RECOGNIZED INDUSTRY GUIDELINES.
AND I WOULD AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
SEVEN DOES NOT DO THAT IT DOES
NOT. PROVIDE CONCRETE PRACTICES
A BUSINESS CAN FOLLOW THAT IS
WHAT AB TEN NO WAY DID LAST
YEAR.
AB TUNNEL EIGHT AGAIN PROVIDE A
CLEAR CONCRETE PRACTICES A
BUSINESS CAN FOLLOW WHICH WOULD
MINIMIZE THE REST WERE NEGLIGENT
NEGLIGENT HIRING RISK ARE
NEGLIGENT HIRING LAWSUIT.
SO IF THE EMPLOYER FOLLOWS THE
GUIDELINES THE GUIDANCE THE
ROADMAP THAT'S PROVIDED IN IT AB
TEN NO WAIT THEY WOULD BE
MINIMIZING THE RISK TO ANOTHER
AND HIRING LAWSUIT BECAUSE IT
WOULD. SHOW THAT THEY WERE
EXERCISING THEIR THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE TO SEE IF THERE WAS
ANY FORESEEABLE RISK. THAT THAT
THIS NEW HIRE WOULD POSE HARM TO
THE WORKPLACE.
I'M.
SO THIS ON THE OTHER HAND THIS
JUST PROVIDES WHAT WE SEE AS AN
OVERBROAD UNNECESSARY
EVIDENTIARY EXCEPTION THAT
REALLY JUST REINFORCES THESE
HARMFUL STEREOTYPES AN INHERENT
BIASES AB TEN ONLY. REALLY
SOUGHT TO ELIMINATE.
SO IF WE ARE IN FACT JUST
TALKING ABOUT NEGLIGENT HIRING
CLAIMS THIS BILL REALLY IS
UNNECESSARY IT LAYS OUT THREE
PROVISIONS ONE NO ONE ON CRIME
CONVICTION HISTORY WOULD BE IN
IT IT ADMISSIBLE. SO FIRST IT
WOULD BE INADMISSIBLE IF IT DOES
NOT BEAR A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP
TO THE FACTS UNDERLYINGCIVIL
ACTION. WHICH IS WHAT A
RELEVANCY STANDARD IS FOR IF IF
IT IS NOT RELEVANT IF THE
INFORMATION IS NOT RELEVANT.
IN OTHER WORDS IT DOES NOT BEAR
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP TO THE FACTS
UNDERLYING CIVIL ACTION THEN IT
WOULD BE INADMISSIBLE. THE
SECOND PRONG IT SAYS.
THE INFORMATION IS INADMISSIBLE
BEFORE THE. IF THIS CONVICTION
IS SEALED REVERSED OR VACATED
PARDON DISMISSED ARE EXPUNGED.
AND ALL THOSE INSTANCES UNDER
AB TEN AWAY AND UNDER LABOR CODE
SECTION FOUR THIRTY TWO POINT
SEVEN AND AN EMPLOYER COULD
NEVER EVEN CONSIDER THAT
CONVICTION HISTORY ANYWAY. SO
THERE'S NO WAY THAT THE
INFORMATION WOULD GO INTO
ANOTHER HIRING LAWSUIT. THE
THIRD PRONG SAYS OF THE CRIMINAL
HISTORY CONSISTS OF AN ARRESTOR
CHARGE A DID NOT RESULT IN A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION AND AGAIN
UNDER A BE TOTALLY AND UTTERLY
BECAUSE ACTION FOR THIRTY TWO
POINT SEVEN. AN EMPLOYER CANNOT
CONSIDER THE INFORMATION THEY
CANNOT CONSIDER AN ARREST THAT
DOES NOT RESULT IN A CONVICTION
SO THAT INFORMATION ALSO WOULD
NOT COME IN FOR ANOTHER IN
HIRING. LAWSUIT
SO. IN THAT SENSE IT'S IT'S
UNNECESSARY BUT THE BILL'S ALSO
OVER BROUGHT IT DOESN'T APPLY
JUST TO NEGLIGENT HIRING
LAWSUITS APPLIES TO ANY ACTION
ANY CIVIL ACTION AGAINST AN
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYERS AGENTS OR
EMPLOYERS. OTHER EMPLOYEES SO
THERE'S THIS WHOLE UNIVERSE OF
OTHER CASES WHERE THERE MIGHT BE
TORTIOUS CONDUCT WHERE A
CRIMINAL CONVICTION HISTORY
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE RELEVANT.
.
I DO NEED EUROPE OKAY THE LAST
THE LAST POINT IS THAT.
IT'S IT'S ONE SIDED THIS BILL
ONLY MAKES THE INFORMATION AND
INVINCIBLE.
AGAINST AN EMPLOYEE YOU'RE SO
ACTUALLY UNDER THE SPELL OF A
PLAINTIFF WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
USE CONVICTION HISTORY OTHER
EVIDENCE AGAINST AN EMPLOYEE. AN
EMPLOYER OR ITS AGENTS OR ITS
EMPLOYEES. BUT THE EMPLOYER
COULD ACTUALLY USE CONVICTION
HISTORY AGAINST THE PLAINTIVE.
SO YOU KNOW AGAIN IF WE THINK
THAT THE GOAL IS TO ESTABLISH
LEGALLY BUT TO LEGALLY
ESTABLISHED CLEARING CONCRETE
PRACTICES THE BUSINESS CAN
FOLLOW TO AVOID A NEGLIGENT
HIRING LAWSUIT. WE THINK THAT
MEANS MAKING SURE WE'RE DOING
THE EDUCATION OUTREACH ENSURING
COMPLIANCE WITH A. B. TUNNEL AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
PLEASE IF YOU CAN WITH THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE ALSO AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ANALYSTS AT ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MISTER ISHIHARA.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
THREE ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS THE CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SEEING NONE I'M GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THIS WILL BE I. APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS A COMPLEX CONVERSATION
AND AND THAT TRYING TO SUPPORT.
THOSE WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS
GETTING INTO THE WORK FORCE AND
HELPING BUSINESSES
ACCOMPLISH THAT AND I THINK
THAT'S THE BASIC GOAL HERE AND
AND I THINK THAT'S.
THAT'S A WORD THE NOTION.
FOR ME THOUGH.
THIS BILL DOESN'T REALLY DO THAT
OR I DON'T THINK WE'LL IT WILL
ACCOMPLISH THAT SO I'M NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
AND IT DOES POTENTIALLY GO
BEYOND WHAT.
WHAT IT STATED AND THAT AND THAT
DOES CONCERN ME WHERE?
THOUGH BECAUSE THE CONVICTION
INFORMATION OR THAT EVIDENCE
USUALLY WE EXCLUDE THAT TO TO
PROTECT THE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
BEING HIRED.
AND A LOT OF THE EVIDENCE RULES
WOULD ALREADY SUPPORT THE
BUSINESS IN A NEGLIGENT HIRING
SITUATION REMEMBER THE BAND THE
BOX TO.
PANTS THE BOX UP FRONT BUT STILL
ALLOWS THE EMPLOYER TO DO THEIR
DUE DILIGENCE ON THAT INDIVIDUAL
AND HAVING RUN BILLS IN THIS
AREA AND DEALING WITH A NUMBER
OF. CATEGORIES OF INDUSTRY.
WHO WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT?
STATUTES THAT WE HAVE DONE SO
THAT THEY DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
INTERVIEW AND AND. MAKE
APPROPRIATE DECISIONS ABOUT
EMPLOYEES WE WE'VE REALLY TRIED
TO TO SORT OF WORK THAT THAT
BALANCE SIDE WOULD RATHER THAT
WE SEE WE GIVE THE LOVE. A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME.
UNDERSTAND.
BETTER THE EXTENT TO WHICH IT
DOES REPRESENT ISSUES FOR
BUSINESSES AND THAT AND THAT WE
CAN FINE. TUNE THE LAW IN VERY
SELECTED AREAS RATHER THAN THAN
SOMETHING.
QUITE SO BROAD AS THAT SO I I
APPRECIATE THE NOTION AND AND
WANTING TO HELP IN THIS AREA FOR
ME RIGHT NOW JUST NOT SURE THAT
THIS IS THE RIGHT APPROACH I'M
NOT GOING TO BE A LIST.
I THINK IT WHAT WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT I THINK.
THAT ONCE HE IN A PART OF THE A
ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT IS THAT ONCE
THEY CHECK THE BOX THAT DIDN'T
AND EMPLOYER IS. ABLE TO LOOK
INTO THE BACKGROUND TO ME IN MY
OPINION AND THE REASON THAT I I
I.
AND SPONSORING OR HELPING WITH
THIS BILL IS BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
YES THEY DO.
CHECK THE BOX OR THERE'S NO BOX
TO CHECK THEY CHECK THE
BACKGROUND AND THEN IT GIVES THE
BUSINESS OF COVER TO SAY WELL
YOU KNOW IF IT'S KIND OF A
BORDERLINE OFFENSE FOR.
I CAN EVEN GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
BUT IF THE BORDERLINE OFFENSE
AND AND THE BUSINESS FEELS LIKE
THEY HAVE COVER THEM THEY'RE
MORE WILLING TO TAKE THAT CHANCE
AS OPPOSED TO JUST SAYING
NOW I HAVE. YOU KNOW A REASON
NOT TO HIRE THE PERSON SO SO FOR
ME THIS BILL REALLY DOES MY
INTENTION IS REALLY TO GIVE
COVER TO SOME OF THOSE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE GOING TO
TAKE A CHANCE ON SOME OF THESE
EMPLOYEES.
ARE POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE.
AFTER.
THE INITIAL OFFER WHEN THEY DO
BACK THE BACKGROUND CHECK.
MAY SAY UP WHAT IT THERE'S.
YOU KNOW WHATEVER UP OFFENSE MAY
BE.
THERE AND SAY WELL I'M NOT
GONNA YOU KNOW TITLES FOLKS AS
OPPOSED TO GIVING THEM COVER SO
THAT. THEY CAN SAY WELL I'M
GOING TO TAKE A CHANCE BECAUSE
NOW I HAVE COVER AND I AM ABLE
TO. TO TO BE ASSURED THAT I
WON'T BE HELD NEGLIGENT.
IF I DO ARE THESE PEOPLE SO
AGAIN WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I.
I APPRECIATE THE THE
CONVERSATION BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT YOU KNOW TALKING ABOUT HOW
QUICKLY WE WE FOLLOW UP ON ON A
LOT THAT THAT'S THE NATURE OF
THIS BUSINESS IS. YOU KNOW WE WE
LOOK AT WHAT. WORKED THE LAST
TIME AND TRY TO EXPAND AND
HOPEFULLY MAKE I MAKE IT EASIER
FOR THAT LOT TO TAKE INTO EFFECT
FOR MONTHS YES IS A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME BUT YOU KNOW WE DO THIS
ALL THE TIME IT'S NOT YOU KNOW
FOR ME THAT REASON IS NOT. A
GOOD ENOUGH REASON NOT TO DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY WERE JUST
BASICALLY SAY NOT WHILE SOMEBODY
ALREADY DID DID IT I'M NOT GONNA
DO IT ANYMORE ITSELF. AGAINST
AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS TO
KILEY.
I MEAN FOR THE WITNESS FROM THE
LA CHAMBER COULD JUST MAKE IT A
LITTLE MORE I CONCRETE FROM US I
MEAN YOU'VE HEARD FROM YOUR
MEMBERS THE SORT OF BAD
SITUATION WHERE THIS NEW BASIS
FOR AN ADMISSIBILITY MIGHT. HAVE
AN IMPACT I MEAN WHAT KIND OF
ACTIONS WOULD MY WOULD BE
DEALING WITH WOULD BE SOMEONE
WHO DID SOMETHING OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE OF EMPLOYMENT OR WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
BUT WHAT WE WE WE HOSTED A A
FOCUS GROUP ABOUT SIX MONTHS
AGO.
AND AND AND TALKED
AROUND WHAT ANY IMPEDIMENTS FOR
FOR HIRING. AND AND THEN WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING TO.
A COMPANY WOULD LARGER A LARGER
FIRM WITH THE WITH THE. LEGAL
COUNSEL AND AND HOLD IT STAFF
AVAILABLE.
IT IS NOT AS CONCERNED WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT SMALL BUSINESSES YOU
TALK ABOUT THE RISK THAT A SMALL
BUSINESS RUNS.
AND I'M AND POWER ARE ARE THEY
WILLING WITH THE RISK THAT THEY
MAY RUN TO TAKE THIS CHANCE AND
AND WHAT WHAT WHAT WE'VE. HEARD
IS.
IT IT IT'S QUESTIONABLE AND SO.
WE WANT TO ELIMINATE ANY REASON
WHY PEOPLE WHO PREVIOUSLY WERE
IN CHRIST READ OR HAVE SOME
RADICAL SOME RECORD. ARE NOT
HIGH.
AND IT AND SO THAT'S THE GIST OF
OUR OUR SUPPORT.
I IT IS IT IS VERY VERY
DIFFICULT THE DAY WE'VE WE'VE
GONE THE COMPANY'S IN AND AND WE
HAVE A MAJOR HIRING EFFORT IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY. TO PLACE SOME
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THAT WERE AFFECTED BY PROP FORTY
SEVEN WEEK WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE
MADE A PLEDGE TO IN LA COUNTY TO
LA COUNTY SUPERVISORS.
TO TO TO ENABLE THE HIRING OF
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS.
WE AND EIGHT IF YOU SIT DOWN AND
TALK TO BUSINESSES LARGE AND
SMALL.
HOWEVER THEIR INTENTIONS ARE
GREAT IT IS CHALLENGING TO DO
THAT.
IT IS CHALLENGING TO DO THAT SO
WORST SAN. CUT LET'S ELIMINATE
AS MANY QUESTIONS
AS POSSIBLE LET'S ELIMINATE THE
RISK IF POSSIBLE AND AND AND AND
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THIS IN IN IN THIS
LEGISLATION. WHO WE BELIEVE US
NOMINAL SO WHY NOT DO IT?
YEAH JUST A QUICK FATHER MEAN
GENERALLY I WILL TALK ABOUT
GENERAL RESPONDENTS BICU OR
LIABILITY.
THAT'S KIND OF THAT STRICT
LIABILITY FROM THE EMPLOYERS PUT
YOU RIGHT THERE DE JUST
AUTOMATICALLY FLOWS TO IT FROM
THE EMPLOYEE I. TO THE EMPLOYER.
I WANT YOU TO ESTABLISH
NEGLIGENCE THERE.
SO THIS WOULDN'T REALLY AFFECT
THOSE ACTIONS SO JUST IT WOULD
BACK SEPARATE NEGLIGENT HIRING
ACTION SO WHY DO YOU THINK YOU
WOULD PROVIDE. ANY SORT OF
MEANINGFUL PEACE OF MIND TED
HERE MEMBERS.
.
AGAIN IF IF IF IF IF I'M A I'M
THAT I'M GONNA HOLD IT MISS
KILEY. YOU ASKED THE SIMILAR
QUESTION YOU'RE ASKING BASICALLY
TO SAY HAD THE SAME THING AGAIN
I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOU FISHING
FOR.
YEAH THIS IS ACTUALLY MUCH.
I'M JUST. I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT KIND OF ACTIONS LIKE A
NEGLIGENT HIRING ACTION THAT YOU
COULD HAVE JUST REGULAR
RESPONDENTS PURE LIABILITY SO
WHY IS THIS IS SPECIFIC TO
EGGMAN HIRING YEAH AND I WHY IS
NOT A PARTICULAR CONCERN THE
FOLKS.
IN TERMS OF HOW THIS NEW LAWS
CAN IMPACT THAT OKAY THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY THE QUESTION YOU
ASKED BEFORE DON'T HAVE IT
DIFFERENT NIGHT NO I DON'T SO.
.
AND. MAY I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
BEING COLOR ARE.
BUT.
.
HAVE AG AT THAT MY RESPONSE.
WAS ONE THAT.
.
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
THIS RACE.
AS A.
JOINT AUTHOR OF AB ONE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT I CAN TELL YOU WE WENT
THROUGH.
SO MUCH TO TRY TO GET THE RIGHT
LANGUAGE TO GET. THE THE THE
CHAMBER TO GET A NUMBER OF OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE. TO
PROVIDE THOSE PROTECTIONS NOT
JUST FOR THE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED BUT ALSO FOR THOSE
EMPLOYERS WHO WERE GOING TO.
GIVE THEM THE JOBS.
AND IT INITIALLY WHEN I READ THE
BILL I THOUGHT OKAY SO NAY OUT
JUST A PROTECTION FOR THE
EMPLOYER.
BUT AS I READ THROUGH IT FURTHER
I REALIZE THAT IF. IF THE
OBJECTION IS.
INTRODUCING RELEVANT.
EVIDENCE
THERE'S ALREADY OBJECTION FOR
THAT
SO IF IT'S IRRELEVANT TO
WHATEVER THE ACTION IS IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE ALLOWED TO BUY ANY
JUDGE.
IF A. B. ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT
OPEN DOORS AND ALLOWED.
EMPLOYERS UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES READ THAT THEY DO
CONDITION CONDITIONALS  OFFER.
THEY THEREAFTER CAN DO THE
RESEARCH TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS A PROBLEM WITH THE
HIRING OF A PARTICULAR PERSON
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
CONVICTION.
THEY'RE ALREADY THOSE
PROTECTIONS FOR THE EMPLOYER.
AND I THINK THAT.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IN THIS BILL
IS?
IF YOU'RE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
ALTHOUGH YOU'VE PAID YOUR DEBT
TO SOCIETY.
YOU'RE OF BIGGER RISK.
EVEN THOUGH YOU'VE ALREADY PAID
YOUR DEBT TO SOCIETY AND THE
WHATEVER THE CONVICTION WAS.
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE JOB.
THAT'S WHY YOU WERE HIRED
BECAUSE AT NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE JOB WITH QUALIFICATIONS OF
THE JOB TYPE I'M JUST CONCERNED.
ABOUT AYE CONCERNED.
.
WITH. WHAT THIS IS DOING?
OUR UNDOING AB ONE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT
I'M JUST IN RESPONSE TO TO.
THE THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
JUDGE THE DECISION OF WHAT
EVIDENCE IS INCLUDED ALWAYS
RESTS ON THE JUDGE. AYE BUT NOT
EVERY JUDGE IS IS YOU KNOW IS
THE SAME WE ALL I'M OBVIOUSLY
YOU GUYS KNOW BETTER THAN I.
AND SO FOR ME IT THIS WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THE JUDGES WOULD
BE CONSISTENT AND WHATEVER ON
DECISIONS THAT MAKE OF WHAT
EVIDENCE IS USED.
IT'S JUST MY OPINION.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IS RUBIO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU OUT AGAIN.
.
THINK CLOTHING I WOULD LIKE TO
REEMPHASIZE THAT THE PURPOSE OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS FOCUSED ON
FINDING EMPLOYMENT FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS THE BELL HAS
POTENTIAL. TO INCREASE THE
CHANCES THAT COMPANIES WILL HIRE
FROM THIS POPULATION AND DOES
NOT ABSOLUTELY.
UP ABSOLUTE NO HARM TO THEIR
CHANCES OF FINDING EMPLOYMENT
AGAIN THE MY INTENT IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT SOME OF THESE OTHER
COMPANIES HAVE COVER. SO THAT
THERE IS NO.
BIAS AGAINST.
THE POPULATION THAT WE'RE ARE
TALKING ABOUT SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK VERY AYE.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T HAVE A MOTION YET.
SO THERE IS A MOTION IS THEIR
SECOND.
AND THE SECOND.
THAT MOTION WOULD BE.
TWO PATHS I'M ASSUMING ROUGHLY.
STONE. STONE NO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CHAO.
CHIU.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
PRESS.
BUT WITH UMBILICAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER TING ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY TWO NINETEEN.
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
CAPTION.
SO WHAT HAVE YOU ALSO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
FIRST LET ME JUST THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO BEEN WORKING
VERY DILIGENTLY TO FIND A. AYE
COMPROMISE AYE EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY A COUPLE PORTIONS OF
THE BILL. AND AS YOU KNOW WE HAD
ME HOMELESSNESS PART CRISIS UP
AND DOWN.
THE STATE OF ONE OF THE EASIEST
WAYS TO HELP AVOID.
PUTTING PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
IS TO HAVE A LANDLORDS AND ARE
POPULAR AS PEOPLE TO ACCEPT A
THIRD PARTY PAYMENT WIND
VIRTUALLY HAVE HEARD THAT THIS
HAS BECOME AN ONGOING ISSUE
WHERE. ARM THIRD PARTY PAYMENTS
HAVE NOT BEEN ACCEPTED UP DOWN
THE STATE'S I'VE FIVE TWO.
WITNESSES WHO CAN WHO CAN TALK
TO THAT ISSUE I GUESS ARE
BRIEFLY. AND.
BRIT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWO NINETEEN.
GOOD THANK YOU FIRST ONCE WE'RE
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS. TRYING
TO GET STAFF ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION JUST
BRIEFLY ECHOING AUTHORS.
COMMENTS HERE WE HEAR FROM OUR
LEGAL AID OFFICES ALL THE TIME
ABOUT FOLKS WHO COME IN. TO
THEIR OFFICE
THERE IS A PROGRAM WILLING TO
HELP THEM MEET THE RENT AND KEEP
THE FAMILY HOUSE. AND FOR.
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS THE
LANDLORD IT'S REFUSING TO ACCEPT
PAYMENT ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
FROM A. FROM A THIRD PARTY AND
WERE YOU KNOW THE STRUGGLE TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
THIS OF THE ROOM A KEY STRATEGY
IN CALIFORNIA.
KEEP PEOPLE HOUSING AVOID
INCREASING HOMELESSNESS AUTUMN
OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE RUN BOTH
BY COUNTIES AND NON PROFITS.
AND.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ADDRESS
THAT AND ENSURE THAT IN THE
RIGHT INSTANCES ITEM WE COULD
KEEP HIS FAMILY'S HOUSE AND
AVOID ADDING ADDITIONAL FOLKS.
AVATAR STREETS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WOOD URGENT ABOUT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
HI MY NAME'S ANDRONOVO I'M A
MEMBER OF RESIDENT UNITED
NETWORK OR RUN RUN AS A
STATEWIDE NETWORK AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RESIDENTS WHO ARE UNITED
TO WORK FOR MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM HERE TO SHARE STORIES OF
TWO OTHER RUN MEMBERS COULD NOT
BE FAIR BECAUSE OF CURRENT LAWS
ALLOW LANDLORDS REFUSE TO. RENT
PAYMENTS FOR THIRD PARTIES MANY
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND
AND KEEP THEIR HOUSING SUCH AS
SENIORS WHO CAN NO LONGER RUN
THEIR FINANCES PEOPLE BE IN
SUPPORT OF BY MENTAL HEALTH
AGENCIES CHARITIES. ARE COLLEGE
STUDENTS RECEIVING SUPPORT FROM
RELATIVES.
MARSA IRONY FROM SAN DIEGO ASKED
ME SHARE THIS STORY BASTER
COORDINATOR PROGRAM WHICH
SUPPORT YOUTH VOLUNTEERS WHO
WORK WITH KIDS.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME LOOKING
FOR APARTMENTS THAT WOULD ACCEPT
THEIR PARTY PAYMENTS.
EVEN WITH THE FORMAL LETTER
PROVING THAT THE ORGANIZATION
HAD FOUND THE LANDLORD WOULD
DENY THE APPLICATION OR REQUIRE
A COSIGNER INSTEAD.
THIS WAS SLOW DOWN THE PROCESS
AND CUT INTO THE VOLUNTEERS TIME
SERVICE.
JANET COULD STEAL FROM OAKLAND
ASKED ME TO SHARE THIS STORY.
MY FATHER LIVED IN A BELOW
MARKET RATE UNIT IN SOME PABLO I
MANAGES FINANCES AND SHARED A
BANK ACCOUNT WHERE I PAY HIS
BILLS FROM.
ONE MONTH UNDER A NEW STAFF
MEMBER THEY RETURNED HIS RENT
CHECK BECAUSE THEY HAD MY NAME
ON IT.
WE HAD BEEN PAYING THAT WAY FOR
YEARS BECAUSE THE STAFF
CONSIDERED AT THIRD PARTY CHECK
IT WAS REJECTED WE HAD TO CANCEL
THE CHECK AND RESUBMIT AND KNEW
WHEN ENTERED MY FATHER'S NAME
ONLY SHORTLY AFTER THAT THEY
RAISE HIS RANT.
AND AGAIN CAUSING HIM TO MOVE IN
WITH ME.
FORTUNATELY JENNY HAD THE
RESOURCES TIME TO DEAL WITH HER
FATHER SITUATION BUT MANY LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY HIRED YOU TO
SUPPORT. AB TWENTY TWO NINETEEN
AND HELP PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS
WHEN THERE ARE MANY TO PAY FOR
THE BETTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING ALEXANDER HUNTING
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY AS A FORMER
LEGAL AID ATTORNEY HAVE SEEN
THIS ISSUE COME UP IN A RANGE OF
SITUATIONS AND I THINK THAT
DOES.
NONPROFITS INDIVIDUALS AND
AGENCIES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IS
STEPPING UP TO HELP US DEAL WITH
THIS CRISIS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT ASSISTANCE IS ACCEPTED
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
JEFF TURNED AGAIN I WILL TAKE
OFF MY CAR SHOOT FOR THE MOMENT.
AS THE DEALING WITH THE SENIORS
BUT IS RUN AND IT'S GOING TO
SACRAMENTO STEPS FORWARD AND
OTHER DISABILITY THINGS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. HE REPEATEDLY THE
THIRD PAYMENT ISSUES LANDLORDS
MANAGEMENT AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
HAVE A HARD TIME AND JUST
REFUSE BECAUSE WHAT THE CHANGING
GOING ON SO IT'S A VERY TIGHT
SITUATION AND HE'S A SO
DIFFERENTLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PLEASE.
THANK YOU OTHER THAN SPORTS.
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
CHRISLEY ON WE HAVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
WHAT MR GENEROUS PATRON WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS?
IN WITH THAT WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
LAUREN CLIMB WITH THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
SYLVIA'S ALICIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT.
AEROBIC CLASS POOREST SECOND
ATTENTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MAKING THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WHILE WE DON'T HAVE
A FORMAL POSITION WE REALLY WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH US
DILIGENTLY ON THIS ANTICIPATE
FOLKS MOVED A SUPPORT POSITION.
Q. ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORTS.
SEEING NONE OPPOSITION.
CHIU FIX A ROOM FOR THE
OPPOSITION.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CATHARINE BOARD
WITH THE WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES SOCIO XIN WE
ARE I'M STILL IN OPPOSITION WE
ARE WORKING WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE TO. GO OVER THE
AMENDMENTS
AND LOOK AT THOSE ISSUES I'M ONE
THE ISSUES THAT DID COME UP FOR
US IS THAT FOR MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES WE HAVE.
.
MMHM WHAT IS THE WORD I'M
LOOKING FOR.
.
JUST BECAUSE IT ACTION.
AND I'M A WE HAVE VERY STRICT
JUST BECAUSE OF ACTION SO OFTEN
TIMES.
WIN A RESIDENT DOES NOT PAY
THERE USUALLY ARE NOT AT A GREAT
TENANT AT THAT POINT ANYWAY BUT
BECAUSE OF THE STRICT JUST
BECAUSE OF ACTION THAT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE NO OTHER REMEDY TO EVICT
THEM AND SO WHEN A RESIDENT IN
THIS CASE DOES NOT PAY.
SOMETIMES THE RESIDENTS AROUND
THAT PERSON AND THE MANAGEMENT
DO YOU WILL HAPPY DANCE THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY OF VIC'S THEM BASED
ON A VERY LEGITIMATE REASON.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
LANGUAGE MAY BE THAT YOU KNOW IF
THE RESIDENT IS TOM. YOU KNOW IN
GOOD STANDING WITH THE COMMUNITY
YEAR OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT WE.
WHEAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH OF
AN ISSUE WITH A THIRD PARTY
PAYMENT ON WE UNDERSTAND THE THE
INTENT OF IT. BUT ON IN OUR
SITUATION WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOMETHING WHERE IF THEY ARE
OTHERWISE A.
A BAD TENANT THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO MAYBE NOT ACCEPT ABOUT
THIRD PARTY PAYMENT IN THIS CASE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LISTEN OPPOSITION.
BOB MISTER CHAIRMAN RON KINGSTON
I REPRESENT FOR REGIONAL PARTNER
ASSOCIATIONS ORANGE COUNTY EAST
BAY.
SOUTHERN CITIES NORTH ARE
VALLEY. A WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
STEADILY WITH THE AUTHOR.
STAFF AND THE.
SPONSORS THE BILL FROM THE VERY
GET GO ON THIS.
BILL.
WE ARE DOWN TO ONE WORD.
AND.
THIS MORNING WE I UNDERSTAND
MISTER CHANG AND SPONSORS I
ACCEPTED THE WORD IT
CONSEQUENTLY AND MISSED THAT THE
STAFF IS VERY WELL AWARE OF
THIS.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN AND A WITH
THAT WE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING.
CREAM GREASY AND THAT'S THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
MY POLITICS FOR GETTING OUT OF
ORDER IN TERMS THE SEQUENCE OF
TESTIMONY.
AS INTRODUCED US YEAR WAS.
DID HAVE AN OPPOSE LAWS MANY
POSITION ON THE BILL HOWEVER
WITH THE US FIVE ONE AMENDMENTS
AS WAS THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WE WILL BE MOVING TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION I JUST WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK. NOT
ONLY THE AUTHOR BUT ALSO THE
SPONSORS AND COMMITTEE STAFF OF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION OR NOT SO
MUCH OPPOSITION ARE GOING
NEUTRAL.
ALRIGHT SINGH NANDA BRING BACK
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISTER KALRA.
I THOUGHT I HAD.
WELL SINCE MISTER KINGSTON
LAUGHTER THERE'S A PLACE WHERE
TO HAS. A RENT PAYMENT AND HE
WOULD LIKE IT TO BE.
RENT PAYMENT WHICH WE AGREE
WITH.
THE CHANGE OF A.
DEFINITELY THE INDEFINITE
ARTICLE.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECONDS THANK YOU MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT CIGNA IS SITTING IN MY
CLERK JUST RESPECT THE
OFFSPRING.
THANK YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CHOW. CHOW I CHIU.
CHIU AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CONSULT FUTURE AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THEY DO SOMETHING THAT TAKES US
TO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE WHICH IS
MY OWN AB THIRTY ONE OH NINE AND
THEN WE WILL DO ITEM FIFTEEN. AB
THIRTY TO FORTY NINE MISTER
CUNNINGHAM BUT YOU.
TAKE THE HELM PLEASE
.
THIS IS ITEM TWELVE AB THIRTY
ONE ON NINE MISTER CHAIR
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIRTY.
AB THIRTY ONE OH NINE ADDRESSES
A COUPLE OF PROBLEMS THAT HAVE
COME TO LIGHT OVER THE LAST YEAR
OR SO.
AND ONE IS.
THE SITUATION OF NON DISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS THAT WOULD SILENCE
SOMEONE WHO WE NEED TO COME
FORWARD AND ESPECIALLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT SUITS WE'VE
SEEN. TOO MANY EXAMPLES
INCLUDING SOME VERY FAMOUS ONE
WAS SOME OLYMPIC CHIN
JOURNALISTS AND OTHER OLYMPIC
ATHLETES WHO WOULD SIGNED
AGREEMENTS THAT. SHUT THEM DOWN
AND ARE NOT ABLE TO BRING
FORWARD THE CONVERSATION INTO A
PUBLIC.
SITUATION LIKE OURS.
AND SO IT WOULD ENSURE THAT
SOMEONE WHO HAD SIGNED A NON
DISCLOSURE THAT THAT COULD NOT
BE USED. IN AN AREA WHERE
THERE'S JUDICIAL ADMINISTRATIVE
OR LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS TO BRING
OUT THAT INFORMATION.
THE SECOND WOULD LIMIT
SETTLEMENT PROVISIONS THAT
PREVENTS AND EMPLOYER FROM
SAYING.
YOU'VE BEEN VICTIMIZED
WE'RE KNOW SETTLING WITH YOU YOU
CANNOT NOW COME BACK TO OUR
ORGANIZATION WHICH IS SEEMS
PATENTLY OFFENSIVE WE'VE SEEN IT
HERE WE SEEN IT ACROSS A NUMBER
OF ORGANIZATIONS WHERE SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN VICTIMIZED. GETS RE
VICTIMIZED BECAUSE THEY LOSE
THEIR JOB THEY LOSE THEIR CAREER
THEY CANNOT COME BACK INTO THAT
ORGANIZATION.
THIS DOES GET TO BE.
A CAN BE A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE AS
WE DEFINE IT OR TRYING TO
DEFINE.
WHAT THAT ORGANIZATION IS WHO
THAT THAT IS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ON THIS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DEFINING IT VERY
SPECIFICALLY I THINK IT'S CLEAR?
IN A PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT CONTACTS
GETS A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT
AND PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT CONTACTS
AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CHAMBER TO SORT
THROUGH DEFINITIONS AND ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE. SOMETHING THAT
WILL PASS THROUGH A BUT WILL
ALSO REALLY START TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES THAT IS OUR INTENT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK.
WHEN IT'S ISN'T SUPPORT. I THINK
YOU KNOW MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AMERICA YOSHIHARU WITH
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF BUT
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS ONE OF
THE MANY THINGS THAT ARE BECOME
GLARINGLY OBVIOUS IN THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT IS JUST HOW. PERNICIOUS
AN OFFENSIVE SOME OF THE
OPPRESSIVE SORRY ON SOME OF
THESE SETTLEMENT TERMS CAN BE.
IN PARTICULAR WITH HARVEY
WEINSTEIN THE LARRY NASSER SOME
OF THESE HIGH PROFILE CASES. I
THINK THIS MISCONDUCT WAS ABLE
TO CONTINUE BECAUSE OF THE NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS THAT
REALLY SILENCED THESE VICTIMS
AND IN THE LARRY NASSER CASE IN
PARTICULAR PREVENTED THEM FROM
EVEN TESTIFYING IN A CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING. THIS DOES HAPPEN IN
THE EMPLOYMENT CONTEXT AS WELL.
ONE OF OUR ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTED FIVE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WAS HARASSED BY THE SAME CEO OF
THE COMPANY.
ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES HAD TO SIGN
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENT SOME OF
THEM WERE PART OF A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT SOME ARE JUST AS A
CONDITION OF HIGHER. BUT THIS
REALLY DID PREVENT THESE WORKERS
FROM PARTICIPATING IN THE
INVESTIGATIONS.
WITH THEIR CO WORKERS WHO WERE
AGAIN HARASSED OR ASSAULTED BY
THE SAME PERPETRATOR. WITH
REGARD TO THE NO REHIRE
PROVISIONS AGAIN THIS HAS BECOME
IS BECOMING STANDARD AND
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS WHICH
AGAIN OFTEN ADDS INSULT TO
INJURY WHEN SOMEONE'S TRYING TO
RESOLVE THEIR CASE MOVE. AND
FIND THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO.
TO MOVE ON IN THEIR CAREER FIND
ANOTHER JOB BECAUSE OF THE SNOW
RIGHT REHIRE PROVISIONS ONE OF
OUR ATTORNEYS REPRESENT.
REPRESENTED A WORKER WHO WAS
SEVERELY SEXUALLY HARASSED AND
ASSAULTED WHO WORKED FOR A LARGE
TIME SHARE CORPORATION.
SHE SETTLED THE CASE.
SHE HAD TO AGREE TO A NO REHIRE
PROVISION.
SHE WORKS FOR AND SO SHEMOVED
ON TO ANOTHER TIME SHARE COMPANY
THAT WAS THEN ACQUIRED BY THE
PREVIOUS TIME SHARE COMPANY AND
SHE HAD TO LEAVE HER JOB SHE WAS
TERMINATED JUST BECAUSE NOT NO
REHIRE PROVISION.
SO AGAIN WE THINK.
THIS IS PROBABLY ALREADY
COVERED UNDER THE RIGHT BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE.
SECTION SIXTEEN SIX HUNDRED ON
THIS BILL WILL JUST MAKE THAT
CLEAR THAT IT DID IT IS A
CONSTRAINT ON.
FINDING MEANINGFUL GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
ENERGY SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NOT OUT.
SORRY. DON'T.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER BROWN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND I DO WANT TO START OFF BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR. I'M FOR
WORKING WITH US IN A STAFF I'M
FOR WORKING WITH THE DIFFERENT
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL TO SORT
OUT OUR CONCERNS WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH.
PROVISION A OF THE BILL THAT
THAT ESSENTIALLY TALKS ABOUT THE
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENT WERE
TOLD THE FINE WITH THE LANGUAGE
IN THAT SECTION REALLY JUST
FOCUSED ON THAT A NO REHIRE
PROVISION. AND WHILE WE AGREE
I'M WITH THE AUTHOR IN HIS
INTENT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT SOME EMPLOYEE
WHO HAS.
ORTIZ SUFFERED.
ALLEGED HARASSMENT ETCETERA
IT'S IN.
RETALIATED BEGINS WITH THIS NO
REHIRE CLAUSE WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR EMPLOYERS HAVE THE
ABILITY IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS
WHEN IT IS APPROPRIATE TO HAVE A
NO REHIRE CLASS AND HAVE THAT
DISCRETION TO CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE UTILIZE THOSE
PROVISIONS.
IN THE APPROPRIATE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SO WE.
AGAIN WORKING WITH HIM TO TRY
AND FIX THAT LANGUAGE TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
IT ADDRESSES BOTH OF OUR
CONCERNS WILL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THEM ON THAT THINKING.
MR MEMBERS A JOHN TORTILLA. AS
PART OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
SITUATION CALIFORNIA I'M PART OF
THE COALITION.
THAT HAS BEEN.
WORKING ON THE SENATE WE DO
AGREE THAT WERE VERY CLOSE.
JUST WANT TO MAKE TWO POINTS ARM
FOR A TESTIMONY ONE IS THAT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL.
AS LAID OUT IN SECTION ONE IS
TO FOLLOW THE GOLDEN VERSES
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS.
AT CASE.
WHICH READS THEM WHICH IS WHERE
WE GET THIS RESTRAINT OF A
SUBSTANTIAL CARROT ON A PERSON'S
ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN A LAWFUL
PROFESSION. AND WERE A BIT
CONCERNED THAT IN.
ON PAGE FOUR WHEN YOU INCLUDE
ALONG WITH STATE AGENCY
EDUCATION SYSTEM. ON AND THE
FINAL THING WHICH IS A
BUSINESSES SO DOMINATES THE
LABOR MARKET YOU INCLUDE ANY
BUSINESS WITH FIVE OR MORE
LOCATIONS IN THE STATE. ON THAT
COULD BE TAKEN AS A SUBSTANTIAL
RESTRAINT EVEN THOUGH A COURT
WOULDN'T ACTUALLY FIND THAT IF
SOMEBODY OWNS FIVE MCDONALDS IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
NOT BEING HIRED AT ONE OF THOSE
FIVE MCDONALDS IS GOING TO BE.
THE ISSUE THE OTHER THING IS.
PEOPLE GET ON UP FIRED AND THAT
THEN SUE FOR ALL SORTS OF
REASONS IS IN FACT.
YOU COULD FIRE SOMEBODY WHO IS
UNDER CONTRACT BECAUSE YOU
BELIEVE THEY'VE BEEN SEXUALLY
HARASSING THEIR CO WORKERS THAT
PERSON COULD COME BACK AND DO A
BREACH OF CONTRACT.
YOU SETTLE THAT OUT BECAUSE
IT'S CHEAPER TO SETTLE AND THAT
PERSON COULD THEN COME BACK AND
SAY WE WANT TO BE HIGHER AND SO.
SO THAT THE CASES ARM THAT THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP A VERY
SYMPATHETIC NEED TO BE HANDLED
ON BUT I DO THINK WE HAVE TO
HAVE THAT BALANCE OF.
EMPLOYERS TO ON ACTUALLY DOING
THE RIGHT FIT THING AND FIRE
PEOPLE FOR.
APPROPRIATE REASONS.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION HELLO KITTY
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE
HERE WITH CONCERNS REGARDING THE
RE HIGHER POSITIONS. UP FOR
EMPLOYERS WITH FIVE LOCATIONS
ARE MARK
THINKING.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS.
JERRY MAKE CLOTHES AND I'M
SUPPOSED TO ASK IF YOU'LL BE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS O..
YEAH THE TOUGH AMENDMENTS AND
THAT WE'VE NEGOTIATED BUT YEAH
WILL BE TAKING THE COMMITTEES OF
ON.
THANK YOU ANY CLOSER I ASK
DERIVA.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND I
BELIEVE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
PLEASE KALRA STONE. BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
CHIU I CONSULT FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES I.
THAT BILLS OUT.
AND WE WILL MOVE TO ITEM FIFTEEN
A. B. THIRTY TO FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THIS WILL BE QUICK AND EASY.
ALWAYS IS THANK YOU THIS IS THE
STAPLE HARPO.
AND AS YOU SPEND.
WATCHING THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS THIS HAS BEEN A A
CONTENTIOUS AND. ISSUE AND IN
FACT LAST YEAR'S BARBELL WAS
PROBABLY THE MOST SOME OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT REFORMS TO THE
STATE BAR IN A LONG TIME.
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO
CONTINUE THAT BUT ALSO TO.
TO IT ENSURE THAT THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING PUBLIC PROTECTION AND.
FILLED FULFILLING OUR OBLIGATION
OF OVERSIGHT OF THE STATE BAR AT
THE SAME TIME TO THEIR NUMBER
PROVISIONS THAT ENHANCE PUBLIC
PROTECTION ESPECIALLY WHERE
THERE THE STATE BAR CHORD IS
DEALING WITH.
WITH ATTORNEYS WHO HAVE HARMED
THE PUBLIC.
THEIR NUMBER PROVISIONS TO THOSE
OF.
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS WE CAN GO
THROUGH THOSE.
WE ALSO ARE ASKING IN THIS ONE
FOR INDEPENDENT A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW.
THE BAR WE KNOW AND HAD SOME.
BATES AND EARLY INDICATIONS OF
RAISING BAR DUES THAT SOMETHING
BAD IS.
CONTROVERSIAL IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND CERTAINLY CONTROVERSIAL
AMONG ATTORNEYS AND IF WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
THEN WHAT.
I FEEL WE NEED IS TO HAVE ENOUGH
OF AN AUDIT THAT'S DONE
TYPICALLY WHEN WE DO BUDGET
ITEMS THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE
THE LA DOES THE BENEFIT OF THE
ALLELES OPINION TO LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING WHAT THE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
AND HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
REAL IMPACTS ARE.
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO ENTERTAIN
THE QUESTION NEXT YEAR OF
RAISING THE BAR DUES WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE KNOW WHAT IT
IS WHY IT IS HOW IT'S JUSTIFIED.
AND FOR THAT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER.
THE FINANCIAL WORKINGS OF THE
BAR TO THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE
THERE AND THEN WE CAN HAVE THE
THE CONVERSATION.
NEXT YEAR ABOUT THAT ANOTHER
PROVISION THAT WAS ADDED IN AND
THIS IS WHY MS RAISES HERE. IS
THAT.
WE AGREE THAT TO TAKE A DOLLAR
FROM.
THE. LAWYER ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
AND MOVE THAT INTO AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS GOING TO
RUN AND SUPPORT ATTORNEYS
RECOVERING FROM SUBSTANCE AND
ALCOHOL ABUSE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PROVISION. IF WE'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS THAT DID
SITUATION OF ATTORNEYS THAT DAY
WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM ALCOHOL
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND REALLY
GIVE THEM A PATH.
DEAL WITH THAT THEIR OWN DEMONS
DEAL WITH THE ISSUES THAT THEY
HAVE RAISED AND ISRAEL'S PROPOSE
THAT IN A SEPARATE BILL AND
APPRECIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT THAT
INTO THE BARBELL BECAUSE WE TRY
TO HAVE EVERYTHING.
DEALING WITH THE BAR IN ONE BILL
THIS ALLOWS US TO DO THIS I
THINK THIS IS A VERY WORTHY
CAUSE FOR US TO BE ABLE TO DO
IT'S A VERY APPROPRIATE. IN IN
OUR BILL.
THE OTHER ANOTHER ASPECT THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO APPROACH THIS
YEAR'S ENHANCING DIVERSITY.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT DIVERSITY
ACROSS THE LEGAL PROFESSION WE
NEED TO LOOK AT.
DIVERSITY AND JUDICIAL RANKS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDING SERVICES
TO CALIFORNIANS LOOK LIKE
CALIFORNIANS INCOME FROM THE
VARIETY OF BACKGROUNDS WE ALL
COME FROM. AND THAT'S ANOTHER
ISSUE IN THIS BILL THAT WE'RE
BEING THAT WE'RE RATE BEING
RAISED.
AS WELL AS AND SEAL THE FOR PRO
BONO PROVISIONS WORKING WITH MR
GRAY WHO HAD BROUGHT A BILL FORD
THAT AGREED AGAIN TO BRING THIS
APPROPRIATELY INTO THE BARBELL.
AND ASKING THE BAR TO LOOK AT
HOW WE.
HOW WE REALLY INCENTIVIZE AND
PRO MAY INSURE THAT LAWYERS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PRO
BONO WORK? ACCESS TO JUSTICE IS
A VERY VERY CLEAR ISSUE ACROSS
STATE. AND THE WORK THAT
TOURNEY'S DO ON A PRO BONO BASIS
OR CONTRIBUTING TO THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES.
IT'S CRITICAL FOR US SO THAT'S
WHY THAT'S ANOTHER ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE.
IN THE BAR BILL THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SORT OUT THIS YEAR
IT'S A COMPREHENSIVE BILL ALLOWS
US TO HAVE A SINGLE CONVERSATION
WITH THE BAR AND GO THROUGH A
MYRIAD OF ISSUES. THESE
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE AS
AS FAR MOVES FOR OUR THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTES.
AND WOULD ASK MS ERUPTED FROM
HIS REYES TO PRESENT AS WELL AND
THEN MOVE ON TO US WITNESSES
PLEASE.
VERY GOOD.
.
AMONG THE PROVISIONS ISN'T NOTED
EARLIER IS A CHANGE IN THE
LAWYERS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT
WOULD DIRECT ONE DOLLAR FROM
EACH FEE COLLECTED. FOR THE
PROGRAM TO THE OTHER BAR THE
OTHER BARS APPEAR SUPPORT GROUP
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
ATTORNEYS.
AS NOTED EARLIER RECOVERING FROM
ALCOHOL AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
DUE TO BUDGET CUTS THE OTHER BAR
LOST MOST OF ITS FUNDING AND NOW
SURVIVES ON PRIVATE
CONTRIBUTIONS.
THE OTHER BAR CONTINUES TO
PROVIDE A WIDE RANGE OF FREE
CONFIDENTIAL SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS RECOVERING
FROM ALCOHOL AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE.
REACHING AS MANY AS TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND LAWYERS AND LAW
STUDENTS ANNUALLY.
THE OF THE BAR HASN'T JUST SAVED
CAREERS SAVED LIVES.
AND WITH WITH US TO SPEAK ON
THIS IS A JERRY BROWN FROM THE
OTHER BAR.
ELLEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM
GERRY BRON I'M AN ALCOHOLIC WITH
TWENTY ONE AND A HALF YEARS OF
SOBRIETY.
SOON TO VITAL STATISTICS TO MAKE
A POINT.
I'M EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS OLD AND
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING LAW FOR
SIXTY FIVE YEARS.
NEITHER OF THOSE THINGS WHATEVER
OCCURRED HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR THE
INTERVENTION AND MY WIFE OF THE
OTHER BAR. WHICH IS A CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT WHOSE SOLE MISSION.
IS.
TO PROVIDE PEER SUPPORT FOR
LAWYERS JUDGES LAW STUDENTS PARA
PROFESSIONALS AND OTHERS IN THE
LEGAL COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE A VERY ELABORATE
PROGRAM.
DAVID MAMMALS WEEK TO THAT HE'S
A OTHER BAR CONSULTANT AND A
VERY GOOD ONE.
WELL A GREAT DEAL AS WE DO THE
STATE BAR. THANK YOU MICHAEL AND
ASSEMBLYMAN REYES ASSEMBLY
PERSON PRAISE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
A I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT I KNOW TIME IS
PRECIOUS.
SO I WILL YIELD THAT DAVID AND
WE WILL NOTE FOR THE RECORD THAT
DAPPER NECKWEAR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
DON'T.
LIVES DAVID MATT I AM A
CONSULTANT FOR THIS FOR THE
OTHER BAR HAVE BEEN FOR TEN
YEARS.
AND THE.
THE PIECE I WANT TO ADDRESS IS
THAT.
CO EXISTENCE OF THE LAPD WHICH
HAS BEEN THE STATE BARS.
.
EFFORT TO AND A GOOD ONE AT
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE THAT YOU
MAY OR MAY NOT BE AWARE OF IT
BUT IT'S BECOMING MORE.
UNDENIABLY APPARENT THAT THE
LEGAL PROFESSION HAS A BIGGER
PROBLEM.
WITH DRUG ALCOHOL ABUSE THAN ANY
OTHER PROFESSION THERE'S.
SOME RATHER.
WELL.
CIRCULATED STUDIES THAT HAVE
COME OUT IN THE LAST YEAR HAVE
ESTABLISHING THAT.
I'VE COMPLETED THE LA P. PROGRAM
WHICH IS A FIVE YEAR PROGRAM. I
WORKED FOR THE LA P. PROGRAM FOR
A YEAR AND NOW I'M INVOLVED WITH
THE OTHER BAR. FREQUENTLY PEOPLE
WANNA SET UP BUT A DICHOTOMY
BETWEEN THE TWO IS SO ONE OR THE
OTHER IS BETTER OR. THE ONLY ONE
IS NECESSARY.
AND THE IMPORTANT POINT I WANT
TO MAKE IS THAT.
WE SERVE OVERLAPPING BUT
SUPPLEMENTAL AND COMPLEMENTARY
FUNCTIONS BUT THERE ARE SOME
VERY CRUCIAL DIFFERENCES.
IF SOMEBODY'S GOING TO SEEK HELP
FROM.
THE LAPD THEY HAVE TO CALL.
PERSON WHO IS AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
STATE BAR.
THEY HAVE TO GO DOWN SOMETIMES
TO TEN EIGHTY HOWARD STREET FOR
THEIR INTAKE INTERVIEW.
AND THEY HAVE TO PAY QUITE OF
BIT OF MONEY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM. DESERVE SOME
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS.
PEOPLE TO GET THAT HELP BECAUSE.
ATTORNEYS ARE MORTIFIED TO HAVE
TO SEEK HELP FOR THIS PROBLEM IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR REPUTATIONS AND THIS IS A
DISEASE THAT STILL HAS A
HORRIBLE STIGMA.
.
SO THE OTHER BARIS CONFIDENTIAL
IT'S FREE IT'S VOLUNTARY AND IT
PROVIDES A PLACE FOR ATTORNEYS
TO GO. WHO WE REALLY ARE NOT
WILLING OR YET ABLE TO GO
ANYWHERE ELSE?
AS ARE GOAL IT'S USUALLY OUR
FUNCTION TO GET PEOPLE BEFORE.
THEY NEED TO GO TO THE LAPD
FRANKLY PEOPLE ARE THEY ALL
APPEAR ALREADY BEING DISCIPLINE.
THEY CAN CALL UP AN EIGHT
HUNDRED NUMBER THAT WE HAVE
BETTER WE'VE BEEN IN EXISTENCE
FOR FORTY YEARS.
AND THEY CAN TALK TO OUR
CONSULTANT WHICH HAPPENS TO BE
ME AND MY PHONE IS RINGING RIGHT
NOW. BECAUSE WE WORK ON US.
STREAMLINED BUDGET AND.
.
WE WASTE NONE OF THE MONEY ON
FRIVOLOUS THINGS.
AND THEY CAN GET CONFIDENTIAL.
ADVICE AND SUPPORT AND
INFORMATION.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY WITH THEY
CAN GET IS LONG TERM MUTUAL
SUPPORT GROUPS.
AND IF YOU STUDY THE PROFESSION
OF DRUG TREATMENT YOU'LL FIND
IT.
THERE ARE MANY DISPUTED FACTS
THERE'S ONE THAT IS NOT
DISPUTED.
AND THAT IS THE BIGGEST.
VARIABLE THAT CORRELATES WITH
LONG TERM SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES IS
PARTICIPATION. IN LONG TERM
ONGOING MUTUAL SUPPORT GROUPS
AND FOR MOST CITIZENS THAT IS A
A OR AN A.
LAWYERS ARE NOTORIOUSLY
UNWILLING AROUND. HAPPY ABOUT
GOING TO AN A OR A. AND WE HAVE.
FORTY MEETINGS
EVERY WEEK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHERE THE LAWYERS
CAN GO AND THEY'RE SURROUNDED
BY?
LAW STUDENTS LAWYERS AND JUDGES
THEIR CONFIDENTIALITY IS
RESPECTED AND THEY GET WHAT THEY
NEED IF THEY'RE IN RECOVERY TO
MAKE SURE THEY STAY IN RECOVERY.
WE HELPED GET THEM THEIR IT WE
HOPE KEEP THEM THERE FOR EVERY
LAWYER WHO IS NOT DYSFUNCTIONAL
BEHIND DRUGS AND ALCOHOL. THERE
IS A BOOK OF BUSINESS AND
CLIENTS WHO ARE LIKELY TO BECOME
VICTIMIZED THAT THE PUBLIC WHO
WERE HERE THANK YOU AT IT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE ALSO TIME. FOR
QUESTIONS AND HIS ODD WITH THEIR
LAST SALE THE REST OF THAT I
THINK IS SIGNIFICANT IS THAT. WE
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING TO STAY
FINANCIALLY.
SOLVE IT FOR YEARS
AND IT.
A DOLLAR IS NOT A LOT OF MONEY
BUT WHEN YOU ADD UP. THE FEW
DOLLARS WHAT YOU END UP WITH IS
A GAME CHANGER FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION.
FINANCIALLY AND ONE OTHER THING
THAT WE DO THAT THE LAPD IS NOT
DO IS WE WELCOME LAW STUDENTS.
AND YOU CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN
LAPD UNTIL YOU HAVE PAID. YOUR
FEET TO TAKE THE BAR EXAM.
WE HAVE A LOT OF LAW STUDENTS
AND FOR EVERYONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO. HELP WE WE HAD
OFTEN A PROBLEM LATER ON THANK
YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES BRIEFLY
PLEASE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MICHAEL CALLING TO KNOW I'M THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE STATE BAR. I
WANT TO THANK START BY THANKING
MISTER STONE AND THE COMMITTEE
AND ITS STAFF FOR YOUR
PERSISTENT LEADERSHIP IN SEEKING
REFORM OF THE BAR. MY OWN
SERVICE ON THE BAR OVER THE SICK
LAST SIX YEARS REFLECTS THAT OF
PERSISTENCE I WAS APPOINTED BY
ONE SPEAKER REAPPOINTED WHICH
WAS NOT PREVIOUSLY POSSIBLE BY
ANOTHER SPEAKER. I WAS ELECTED
THE LAST PRESIDENT TO THE BAR BY
MY PEERS AND I WAS CHOSEN THE
FIRST CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES BY THE US THE US
SUPREME COURT.
WE HAVE HAD A SUCCESSFUL YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTING THEM GROUNDBREAKING
PERFORMANCE THAT THIS COMMITTEE.
WAS THE ARCHITECT OF LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY SEPARATED
THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND WISH THEM WELL
IN THEIR PRIVATE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FUNCTION.
WE HAVE RENEWED OUR FOCUS ON
PUBLIC PROTECTION.
WE ARE ESTABLISHING A MEANINGFUL
EFFORT TO PRIORITIZE OUR CASES
SO WE CAN PUT OUR RESOURCES
WHERE THEY DO THE BEST FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
WE ARE ENGAGING IN MEANINGFUL
OUTREACH TO CONSUMERS OF LEGAL
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THEY KNOW
ABOUT THE SERVICES THAT WE CAN
OFFER THEM.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA SUCH
AS THOSE AFFECTED BY THE
UNAUTHORIZED PRACTICE OF LAW IN
IMMIGRATION AND OTHER SETTINGS
WE ARE WE REACHING OUT TO
CALIFORNIANS IN THE LANGUAGES
THAT THEY SPEAK.
WE ARE COOPERATING WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ADDRESS UNAUTHORIZED PRACTICE OF
LAW.
WE HAVE BUILT AND RENEWED A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE SEIU THAT
REPRESENTS OUR EMPLOYEES.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED COOPERATION WITH THEM
TO BUILD A BETTER BAR.
I WILL SAY THAT WHEN STRONG
MANAGEMENT WHICH I FIRMLY
BELIEVE WE HAVE.
FOLLOWS WEAK MANAGEMENT.
ALL THE NEWS IS BAD AT FIRST
VAN COVER ALL THE PROBLEMS THAT
HAVE DEVELOPED IN YEARS OF
NEGLECT THE LEADERSHIP AND THEY
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THEM. AND SO I
CAN'T TELL YOU THE WORK IS DONE
IT IS FAR FROM DONE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THE WORK AND THAT
WE WILL IDENTIFY PROBLEMS BE
HONEST ABOUT THEM AND FIX THEM
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF IN THAT REFORM EFFORT.
WITHOUT A FOR TO THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OF THE PARTLY LOS.
THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY
REMARKS I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BAR HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO NUMBER BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU LET ME FIRST.
ECHO THE WORDS OF THE PRESIDENT
BY THANKING EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE OPTICALLY ARE CHAIR
WHY KNOWS BEEN.
TRY HEARD CATS ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
LEADERSHIP OF THE BAR FOR WHERE
WE'VE COME.
WE'VE HAD SOME DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS LAST COUPLE YEARS
AND I DO THINK WE ARE. ON A
BETTER TRACK.
I WLL SAY I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN A REPEATED REQUEST FOR FEE
INCREASE AND AND I THINK ALONG
WITH MOST MY COLLEAGUES. ARE NOT
PREPARED TO DO THAT AT THIS TIME
UP FOR VARIETY REASONS OF FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE NOT HERE.
BEYOND LAST YEAR WE'VE HAD
SIGNIFICANT CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
A LOT OF ISSUES HAVING TO DO A
STATE PARK FINANCES AND AND
FRANKLY A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
THAT.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE THE HANDLE
ON OUR EXPENSES. AS WE WOULD
WANT.
ISSUES AROUND EXECUTIVE PAY
ROUND TRAVEL EXPENSES AROUND.
BUSINESS EXPENSES INVOLVING%
SLUSH FUNDS AND SIGNIFICANT
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTIONAT THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN PARITY THE
PAPERS.
QUESTION A REAL STATE DECISIONS
OF ONE OF THE THINGS I'D HOPED
WAS GONNA BE PART OF THIS BILL
WAS. REAL TRUE ZERO BASED
BUDGETING ARE THIS IS.
THE BUDGET PROCESS THAT APPLIES
TO OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND THE
COURTS ARMED AND. GIVEN OUR
OVERSIGHT MY HOPE WAS THAT WE
WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE. OF I KNOW THAT THE
BAR HAD CONCERNS WITH ZERO BASED
BUDGETING AND AND I I REALIZED
WE HAD A MEETING LAST WEEK I DID
HAVE A CHANCE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT. COULD YOU GIVE US A
PERSPECTIVE ON WHY THAT WOULD BE
CHALLENGING.
FOR YOU AT THIS TIME.
FIRST CRACK IN AND OUT OF THE
FOR LEO TO SEE ACTUALLY HAS TO
MAKE THE TRAINS RUN ON TIME.
WE HAVE AT YOUR ENCOURAGEMENT.
DOWN TWELVE STUDIES OF THE BAR
AND ITS MANAGEMENT AND OPERATION
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS THAT
WE SPENT ARMS A COUPLE MILLION
DOLLARS AND THOUSANDS OF STAFF
HOURS DOING THAT.
WE ARE TRANSPORT WE UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT
HOW WE MANAGE PUBLIC RESOURCES
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A CASE TO
MAKE TO YOU BEFORE WE ASK FOR A
FEE BILL NEXT YEAR.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO TRANSPARENCY
AND THAT THOSE FURTHER STUDIES
THAT YOU THINK ARE NEEDED BUT WE
DON'T WANT TO DUPLICATE EFFORT
BECAUSE THE TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING
FOR THIS.
WE WANT IT TO BE ACHIEVABLE IN
THE TIME YOU SET FOR US WHICH IS
BEFORE THE FEMALES ARE NEXT YEAR
AND WE WANT IT TO BE MEANINGFUL.
WE'VE SEEN THE LANGUAGE THAT
STAFF IS PREPARED WE'VE HAD A
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE ABOUT THAT
LANGUAGE AND WE INTEND TO
CONTINUE THAT DIALOGUE WE KNOW
WHAT YOU WANT AND WE WILL
PROVIDE IT TO YOU.
SO DEFTLY APPRECIATE THAT THAT
ANSWER ALTHOUGH I HAVE WONDERED
IF ZERO BASED BUDGETING AND
WOOD.
REALLY CUT TO THE CORE OF WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IN A VERY
HEALTHY AVOID THE NEED FOR
FUTURE AUDITS BUT.
I I AM I AM.
A.
IT WHILE I WOULD PREFER ZERO
BASED BUDGETING.
YOU KNOW I I I THINK I'M
WILLING TO SUPPORT MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
BUT UNDERSTANDING FOR ME THAT
THE AUDIT IN THE STUDY THAT'S
BEEN CALLED FOR IN THIS BAR
BILL.
REALLY REPRESENTS I THINK AGAIN
THE BARE MINIMUM OF WHAT WE
WOULD NEED FOR RESPONSIBLE AUDIT
APART SPENCE'S SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO.
SEE WHAT WE GET AND.
AND MOVING FORWARD FROM THERE.
ARM ON A SEPARATE TOPIC IN THIS
IS ONE THAT I'VE DISCUSSED I
THINK WITH ALL THE PARTIES
INVOLVED. OF THE TOPIC OF
DIVERSITY AND JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT AS WAS NOTED IN THE
STAFF ANALYSIS AT THIS MOMENT.
IN OUR CALIFORNIA STATE BAR
EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE ATTORNEYS
ARE WHITE. ARE AT A TIME WHEN.
Y. CALIFORNIANS MAKE UP THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF OUR POPULATION
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS FOR FOR
NON WHITE ATTORNEYS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM DO NOT
REALLY ENGAGE WITH THE STATE
PARK.
AND I KNOW THIS.
BECAUSE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
ATTORNEYS OF COLOUR.
INTERACT TYPICALLY WITH WITH
ETHNIC PARSIS YOU ASIANS OR
WOMEN'S BAR ASSOCIATIONS ARE
LGBT BAR ASSOCIATIONS.
AND AS SOMEONE WHO USED TO BE
THE PRESIDENT OF ONE OF THE
LARGEST ETHNIC BAR ASSOCIATIONS
IN THE STATE.
THAT IS IN PART BECAUSE OF A
PERCEPTION AND I THINK A REALITY
THAT THE STATE BAR HAS NOT
FOCUSED ON ISSUES OF DIVERSITY
AND ADVANCEMENT. AND ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN IN A WAY THAT WE
WOULD WE WOULD HOPE.
.
THERE AS YOU KNOW BEEN SOME
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT A ABOUT
DECENTRALIZING THE FOCUS OF
DIVERSITY.
WITHIN THE BAR IT USED TO BE
THAT THERE WAS A A UNIT WITHIN
THE BAR THAT REALLY FOCUSED ON
THIS AND. NOW THE PROPOSAL IS TO
ESSENTIALLY DISBAND THAT AND TO.
WITH THE EYE OF OF HOPEFULLY
IMBUING IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE BAR ARE A COMMITMENT TO
DIVERSITY BUT AT THIS MOMENT
THAT IS NOT YET. IN PLACE AND
SO.
I JUST WANNA SAY THAT THIS IS AN
AREA THAT I'M GONNA BE VERY
FOCUSED ON THIS COMING YEAR. I
APPRECIATE IN THIS BAR BILL.
THERE WILL BE AN ANALYSIS OF OF
OF HOW DIVERSITY IS IS ADDRESSED
AND WHAT AS.
A STATE BAR WE COULD DO TO FOCUS
ON UP PROMOTING.
THE ISSUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT
TO ALL ON BUT IT'S A IT'S ONE
THAT I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
AND AND FRANKLY HAD THOUGHT
ABOUT NOT SUPPORTING THIS BILL
FOR THAT FOR THAT REASON. ARM I
THINK SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES
IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT.
THE CALIFORNIA BARS STANDARDS
AND THE IMPACT OF A PASSING
SCORE LEVELS ON DIVERSITY WITHIN
THE FUTURE OF THE BAR.
WERE VERY TROUBLING AND.
I'D LOVE ANY PERSPECTIVES ON
THAT BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
SPELL I AM WILLING TO SUPPORT
THIS.
BILL.
BUT WITH AN EYE TO THE FUTURE
AND AND CERTAINLY NEXT YEAR WHEN
WE GET ALL THIS INFORMATION BACK
CERTAINLY THERE'S A PUSH FOR FEE
INCREASE.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT I'LL BE
SCRUTINIZING SO IF YOU HAVE ANY
INITIAL COMMENTS ON THAT LOVE TO
HEAR THEM BUT I I YOU KNOW I
KNOW I'VE HEARD FROM BAR
LEADERSHIP THERE IS A COMMITMENT
AND I BELIEVE THAT. TO BE TRUE
BUT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE NEED
TO WE NEED TO SEE SOME GOOD
RESULTS.
THANK YOU THE LEGISLATURE HAS
GIVEN US THREE CHARGES WE ARE TO
REGULATE THE PROFESSION FOR THE
PROTECTION OF CALIFORNIANS.
WE ARE TO PROMOTE DIVERSITY IN
THE PROFESSION AND THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND WE ARE TO PROMOTE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE BY
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL MEANS WE
TAKE THOSE THREE MISSION
SERIOUSLY. I AM PERSONALLY
COMMITTED TO THE DIVERSITY
AGENDA AS THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
PRESIDENT OF THE STATE BAR AND
THE LAST AS IT HAPPENS.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO MENTION
THREE INITIATIVES THAT WE'VE
RECENTLY UNDERTAKEN TO REFLECT
OUR COMMITMENT OF THIS AGENDA.
ONE AS WE'VE REVISED OUR LEGAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BAR FOUNDATION SO THEY MAY DO
THEIR GOOD WORK UNFETTERED BY
PROP TO A NINE.
SECONDLY WE HAVE INITIATED A
PROJECT THIS YEAR THAT PROVIDE
PSYCHOLOGICAL INTERVENTIONS FOR
THOSE WHO WERE PREPARING TO TAKE
THE BAR EXAM. IT IS OPEN TO ALL
COMERS WITHOUT RESPECT TO THEIR
RACE GENDER CREED CLASS ETCETERA
BUT THE PSYCHOLOGICAL WORK
THAT'S DONE SUGGESTS THAT PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND WOMEN ON THE OTHERS
FROM DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO PARTICIPATE
AND MORE LIKELY TO BENEFIT. WILL
SEEK WE'RE GONNA MEASURE THE
RESULTS OF THAT PROGRAM IF IT
DOES WELL WE WANT TO SEND IT OUT
INTO THE WORLD TO HELP IT'S
REPLICATED THE DOESN'T DO WELL
WE'LL TRY SOMETHING ELSE.
AND THEN LASTLY WE ARE
UNDERTAKING A CENSUS OF ALL OF
THE APPOINTMENTS THAT WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR TO DETERMINE
WHERE WE ARE IN TERMS OF
DIVERSITY AT THIS MOMENT SO THAT
WE KNOW WHAT OUR BASE WERE
BUILDING FROM AS. SO WE WE GET
IT WE'RE COMMITTED TO IT THAT WE
CAN DO BETTER AND WE INTEND TO
DO BETTER AND WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
COLLABORATE WITH YOU ON THAT
ISSUE SOMEONE I HAVE YOU DONE A
SURVEY OF YOUR MEMBERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT JUST
OCCURRED TO MY BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK I'VE EVER TAKEN ONE BUT
AGAIN I'VE SPOKEN TOO LITERALLY
AND I'M NOT EXAGGERATING.
HUNDREDS UPON HUNDREDS OF
ATTORNEYS OF COLOUR WHO JUST
DON'T PARTICIPATE IN STATE BAR.
ACTIVITIES AND DATA JUST CURIOUS
WHETHER THAT'S HAPPENED WHEN YOU
SAY A SURVEY OF OUR MEMBERS ON
THESE ISSUES WOULD BE REFERRING
TO EXACTLY WELL I EXCUSE YOU
HAVE A SENSE OF WHETHER YOUR
MEMBERSHIP THINKS THE BAR IS
DOING A GOOD JOB AS FAR AS
DIVERSITY. ADVANCING THE ISSUES
IMPORTANT TO ATTORNEYS OF
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS.
EXCEPT FOR NO I DON'T HAVE A
SENSE OF WHETHER WHAT OUR
MEMBERS THINK OTHER THAN AN
ANECDOTAL FUNDS THAT COMPORTS
WITH YOURS BOB.
OKAY GREAT AND AND AGAIN YOU
KNOW I DO I DO.
VALUE I THINK THE COULD THE
COMMITMENT OF CURRENT LEADERSHIP
TO THIS SIDE I JUST I HOPE WE'LL
GET TO.
SOME REAL RESULTS.
AND THAT THIS WILL NOT BE A
CONVERSATION THAT WE
FORGET ABOUT IN HERE.
THANK YOU.
JERRY MIKLOS.
THANK YOU SO ON THE DIVERSITY
ISSUE WHEN THINGS I AM GONNA
PROPOSE FOR THIS COMMITTEE. IS
THAT WE HOLD A HEARING ON
DIVERSITY IN THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
THAT WE HAVE A BETTER HANDLE
AROUND THAT. AND AND IT'S A VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE THIS COMMITTEE OR
BY ITSELF I WILL SPEAK FOR ME
BUT A LOT OF YOU HAVE BACK THIS
IT. HAVE RAISED QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE CUT SCORE IN THE BAR.
THE PURPOSE OF THE.
OF THE BAR THE BAR EXAM IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
QUALITY OF ATTORNEYS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT I'VE
NOT BEEN CONVINCED THAT THE CUTS
CORPS THAT WE USE.
IS IS WHAT IS IS REALLY GETTING
THAT AN APPROPRIATE WAY AND THE
AFFECTED IT TENDS TO HAVE. IS TO
MAKE IT HARDER FOR.
LAWYERS OF COLOR TO COME INTO
THAT THE LAW PRACTICE AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE VERY VERY SERIOUSLY SO IT'S
NOT ONLY LOOKING AT.
THAT THE SERVICES THE BAR THAT
THE PERSPECTIVE OF LAWYERS TO
THE BAR BUT IT IS HOW WE ENSURE
THAT THE BAR.
ULTIMATELY LOOKS LIKE CALIFORNIA
OVER THE YEARS AND LOOKING AT
THE BARRIERS TO ENTRY INTO THE
LEGAL PROFESSION IS ONE OF THOSE
SIGNIFICANT ONES THERE ARE ALSO
OTHER WAYS WE CAN ADDRESS. THAT
QUALITY ISSUE AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE FUNCTIONS THE BARS TO ENSURE
PUBLIC PROTECTION.
HAVING A HIGH QUALITY HIGH
STANDARD FOR LAWYERS IN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT THE CUTS
SCORE DOESN'T NECESSARILY I IN
MY VIEW I DON'T THINK IT IT.
MEANS THAT WE HAVE HIGHER
QUALITY OF ATTORNEYS THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS THAT WE CAN AND
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT.
AND SO IF WE HAVE HIGH BARRIERS
TO ENTRY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE THE
DIVERSITY IN THE LEGAL
PROFESSION IF WE ALLOW.
APPROPRIATE DIVERSITY LEGAL
PROFESSION BUT KEEP THE
PROFESSION STRONG THAT SOMETHING
THAT THAT WE DEFINITELY NEED TO
BE LOOKING AT.
AND AS TO THE AUDIT.
THE WEATHER ZERO BASED BUDGETING
WE'VE HAD THESE CONVERSATIONS
RIGHT NOW. I DON'T GET TIED UP
IN A PARTICULAR TYPE OF AUDIT
BUT IT DOES NEED TO BE
COMPREHENSIVE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF STUDIES THAT
WERE DONE AND THAT'S A FAIR
POINT. WE DO NOT WANT THE BAR TO
REPLICATE THE STUDIES WE WANT TO
USE THE STUDIES WHERE WHERE
APPROPRIATE IN THAT INFORMATION
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO DO THAT.
BUT WE ALSO NEED THE BUT THE
STUDIES ARE. SNAPSHOTS OF
CERTAIN CERTAIN TYPES OF
INFORMATION WITHIN THE BAR
UNIVERSE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ENOUGH OF A COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEED. AS
DEMONSTRATED WHERE THE BAR IS
GOING TO NEED TO GO FOR I THINK
FOR THIS COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO
WEIGH IN.
POSITIVELY ON A A FEE INCREASE
THAT HAS TO BE JUSTIFIED AND TO
DO THAT WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
FULLY UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE BARS EXPENSES ARE WHAT
THE STRUCTURE IS AND WHETHER OR
NOT?
A FEE INCREASE IS NECESSARY OR
EVEN HOW MUCH
THAT'S WHAT THE REQUEST IS WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE BAR.
ON THE SCOPE WHO'S GOING TO DO
IT THERE'S DISAGREEMENT ABOUT
THAT.
BUT IN THE END.
IF WE DON'T GET THE RIGHT
INFORMATION I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO STRUGGLE
WITH A FEE INCREASE REQUEST IF
WE GET THE RIGHT INFORMATION WE
CAN HAVE THE ROBUST CONVERSATION
THAT WE NEED THAT IS BACKED BY.
FINANCIAL DATA THAT REALLY
ESTABLISHES THE NEED SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO SET UP IN
THIS PART TO SPELL IS GET US
THAT INFORMATION IF THAT REQUEST
IS GOING TO COME NEXT YEAR. THEN
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ACT ON IT
IN A RATIONAL AND INFORMED WAY
SO THOSE ARE ISSUES THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS IN HERE.
AND I REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MOVING IT FORWARD.
AS HAS BEEN IN THE PAST I FULLY
INTEND TO KEEP EVERY BAMBER THIS
COMMITTEE INFORMED ABOUT WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO GO I WELCOME YOUR
INPUT ON THE PROCESS OF THINGS
THAT WE DO IS WE TRY TO
NEGOTIATE. WITH THE STATE BAR
WITH THE SENATE THE CHIEF
JUSTICE ALL THOSE PARTIES WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN THIS BUT AT
THIS POINT I'M HOPING WE CAN
MOVE THIS FORWARD. HEADED TOWARD
THE FLOOR AS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND WILL
CERTAINLY KEEP YOU INFORMED
ABOUT WHERE WE STAND ON ALL OF
THESE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES AND
I ASKED HER ABOUT.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
SHE HAS BEEN DEPRESSED DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL STONE. AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I. CHOW. CHOW I CHU. CHU AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY AYE. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS
HI CHRIS I.
NOTHING.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT SO LET'S GO QUICKLY IF
WE CAN THROUGH ALL OF THE ITEMS
AND GET EVERYONE AT AND WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF ITEMS ON CALL.
THE NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT GOT OUT
BUT WE WILL JUST GO THROUGH THEM
ONE AT A TIME A LIFT THE CALL AS
APPROPRIATE. SO FIRST OF ALL WE
HAVE THE CONSENT AGENDA I'M
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL. VOLUMES
MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
AYE CHOW. CHOW I CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA.
KALRA SO THAT IS AB EIGHTEEN
NINETY SIX OR BONTA IS AB TWENTY
NINE TWELVE IRWIN. AND AB THIRTY
TO FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BILL THOSE
ARE ALL ADULTS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS ON CALL AND
WIN A LIFT THE CALL.
CUNNINGHAM.
AND THAT THIS WAS THERE WERE SO
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE NOT TAKEN
MY RECOMMENDATION WAS IN NO
CHAIR VOTING NO.
CUNNINGHAM.
CHIU NOT VOTING.
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
SO THE THAT BILL IS ONE ONE THAT
BILL FAILS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO IS ALSO CALL I'M
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL THIS IS
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY ONE MISTER
BERTUCCI THIS WERE TO SEE IF
ACCEPTED ALL THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT CHAIR IS RECOMMENDING TO
PASS.
AS AMENDED CHAIR VOTING I PULLED
UP THE MEMBERS CHIU AYE CHIU
AYE.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA I. MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I.
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER THREE IS AB TWO ZERO
SEVEN ONE BLOOM IS ALSO CALLING
THE LIFT THE CALL. BUSH'S DO
PASS AS AMENDED.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CHAO.
JOE I CHU. CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS ALREADY OUT
WE CAN ADD ON ABSENT MEMBERS
THIS IS AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE CERVANTES.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHU CHU AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
IF YOU OUT OF NUMBER FIVE TWENTY
TWO NINETEEN IS OUT THIS IS
MISTER TING SPILL.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING TO AYE.
OKAY SO THAT ITEM IS DONE WE ARE
THAT AND OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX
IS AB TWENTY TO THIRTY MISTER
BERMAN SPELL. THAT TO PASS AS
AMENDED IT IS ALREADY OUT BUT WE
CAN AT ON MEMBERS IF THEY WOULD
LIKE. CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CHU CHU AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE.
YOU I'VE NEVER SEVEN IS AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY THREE MISTER
FRASER IT IS ON CALL AND WIN A
LIFT THE CALL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU CHAU AYE
CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA.
KALRA THAT BILL AS ADULTS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR BLOOM. IS ALSO CALL
MIDDLE IF THE CALL.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHIU.
CHIU I HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER.
NINE IS MS RUBIO SPILL AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY SEVEN.
CHAIR VOTING NO THAT BUILDS ON
CALL ON GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
CHIU.
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
THAT BELIEVES ONE ONE IT ALSO
FAILS.
ITEM NUMBER TEN IS AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT MISTER CALDERON IT
THE BILL'S ALREADY PASSED BUT
CAN AT ON MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CHIU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE.
IF YOU I'M NUMBER ELEVEN IS MS
RACES BILL AB THREE ZERO ONE
NINE.
IT IS ALREADY OUT AND WILL WILL
ADD ON MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
THIRTY ONE OH NINE TO HAVE
EVERYBODY.
OKAY
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY EIGHT MERIT SUCI IS
ON CALL I'M GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL.
CHAIR VOTING AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NOW.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB THIRTY TWO
SEVENTEEN BERMAN.
HIS HEAD HE HAS PASSED THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WANT WISHING
TO ADD ON.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
THAT AND OF
THE WE HAVE EVERYONE.
WHEN.
WITH EVERYTHING.
OKAY WE THINK WE HAVE EVERYONE
IF YOU DON'T THINK SO.
LET'S NO.
OTHERWISE THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH AND WE ARE ADJOURNED